are sitting on my left your right in
this area over here if you do not have a
mask you would be sitting Center or to
the
right same thing is applicable for
committee members if your name plate is
in a location where we have non-mas to
my right your left and the mass would be
over this side change your change your
name plates please to reflect where you
would be
seated
we
e
I
okay we're ready to go ahead uh I will
put the gavel down here in about 30
seconds for those people wandering
around in the back please try and find a
seat thank you very
much this hearing of the education
committee will come to
order prior to our getting into the bill
which we have to hear today I want to
establish rules and conduct that will be
expected of all in this room committee
members and the
public so I will go through some of the
rules which we have not just the rules
which we have for the education
committee but the rules for the House of
Representatives the rules for this
sacred
chamber
one there will be no signs allowed in
this room at all that is a rule which we
all uh follow and do during the course
of various sessions which we have here
for those that want to testify we have
pink cards available for the person who
is choosing to testify uh to fill out
and those will be handed to uh Jif for
four which is our research assistant in
the rear of the room she will bring
those cards down to the clerk who is
sitting in front of me represented
Barbara
Shaw those cards should have on your
name and any organization your address
in any organization that you may or may
not
represent when you come to speak at the
mic please make sure that you are close
to that mic so all can hear you and that
you stay your name and your residence
and your position on the particular bill
that you may be
addressing cell phones are allowed in
the chamber but you should not be using
them in the chamber in terms of
voicemail and talking back to somebody
if you have a message comes in and we
understand we all do have emergencies or
contacts we have to deal with during the
course of a day you go out to the antiy
room and uh do your business out there
do not uh try to use your cell phone in
this chamber there again that is another
rule of the House of
Representatives if you're testifying
please do not repeat and repeat and
repeat what others have said if you have
something unique and something that's
pertinent to as to your experiences
we're pleased to hear that but uh uh in
order to have everybody have the
opportunity to testify today we like to
keep it succinct and and and uh not do a
lot of repetition if you have written
comment and want to test uh submit that
comment for the record it can be
presented to Jennifer for our research
assistant Jennifer would you please put
your hand up and wave to everybody so
they know who you are she is over to my
right your left and in the back there by
uh section two uh she can bring that WR
testimony down to the clerk or if she's
not in the room at that moment you can
bring it to the clerk which is
representative Shaw below when you're
testifying due to the number of folks we
have here today we're going to invoke
the three minute rule that's an informal
rule which we have when we have large
bodies we've had that here often when we
dealt with homeschooling or Charter
Schools or any numerous bills that have
generated a lot of public input and
desire to communicate with us
the legislature so you will have three
minutes at the end of uh two and a half
minutes you will see a yellow uh piece
of paper that you see represent Hobson
putting up that means caution you have
about 30 seconds remaining and start
thinking about wrapping up and then when
you see the red up there it's just like
it is it doesn't mean put your foot on
the pedal and go faster it means
stop wind it up and and and uh we will
try to uh move on as quickly as we
can this particular hearing is being
streamed so a note of caution to those
on the committee
below uh if you have your electronic
equipment on it does interfere with the
streaming and so if you're a Committee
Member uh put everything on a a stop or
turn your uh your phones off please uh
as a matter of etiquette and respect for
our public we should be listening to
those people testifying and not looking
at our own
computers okay the executive session for
this particular hearing will follow the
hearing the hearing will be closed and
then uh there'll be a short break
perhaps depending upon the time of day
whether it's for lunch or just a a break
and then we'll come back and exec the
bill
I think that is taking us through many
of the rules I'd like to and and the
things I want to communicate for the
record my name is representative Rick
lad I'm from hail the Hail in New
Hampshire not Massachusetts and I chair
House
Education and due to the fact that I am
the maker of the amendment I will not be
conducting this meeting I will be here
presenting the amendment coming back act
and acting as the vice chair during the
rest of the
meeting and the chair will be acting
Vice chair now representative cordelli
to my right representative bom to my
left is a ranking member on the
committee and uh he is here for the
purpose of uh trying to help sort out
these cards which are passed up to us
from uh representative
Shaw so with that I'd like to
move forward and I will present the
bill and then come back to this Podium
and uh sit the remainder of the hearing
out as Vice chair I will be acting in
charge of the executive session with the
committee when we deal with action on
that bill so thank you for coming today
and please remember that when you are
testifying we want everybody to do it in
a civil manner there will be no
tolerance there's never been tolerance
in my committee for behaviors which I
feel are
unacceptable and so please let's testify
with respect for each other and for a
differing opinion thank you very
much okay prior to my uh walking off the
podium here I'd like to welcome fourth
graders which are coming in it's a a
policy and an event that the uh session
usually has we welcome our fourth
graders my background is I was a fourth
grade teacher years and years ago in
winr Maine and then went on to become a
school principal and administrator and
spent many my days as that as an
administrator and principal in the grand
state of Alaska for 25 years the Last
Frontier I'm glad to be back home here
where I was brought up in Maine not too
far from here in New Hampshire so I
welcome all our fourth graders and
enjoy
thank you chairman lad um I think uh he
covered all the ground rules for today
um just want to emphasize there is three
minutes and you'll get the notice uh in
relation to your time and um with that
we will begin the public
hearing um and to start the public
hearing um we would like to All Rise for
the Pledge of Allegiance um
representative lad would you lead us in
the pledge
please thank you very much I pledge
allegiance to the of the United States
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all thank you and I will not try and
sing the uh national
anthem uh but I I will call on uh
representative lad to introduce the
amendment to House Bill
255 thank you very much representative
cordelli and members of the education
committee for the record my name is Rick
lad I come from hail New Hampshire which
is up north I also chair education and
I'm pleased today to introduce HB 255s
Amendment
H this amendment
2239 provides that no New Hampshire
entity shall compel receipt of a
covid-19 vaccine by any individual who
objects to such vaccination for any
reason of personal
conscience religious belief or for
medical reasons including prior recovery
from
covid-19 part
two the term
entity so with that I'm going to get
into a little bit of where I am in my
position and why I am presenting this
amendment HB 255 is original language
was established as a limitation on
liability for higher education in
businesses that's no longer needed the
amendment however is submitted for the
purpose of rejecting the federal
directive establishing a mandatory
vaccine work
requirement this unnecessary mandate is
trampling State powers and local private
businesses imposing new burdens on
employers when they can least afford it
an infringement on personal rights
and making life harder for the
unvaccinated who want to work in an
economy which is
already workers there are a number of
reasons for rejecting this Federal
mandate article four of New Hampshire's
Bill of Rights is titled rights of
conscience
unalienable this article reads among
natural rights some are there for very
are their very n uh nature un
alienable because no equivalent can be
given or received for them of this kind
are the rights of conscience all men and
women have certain natural essential and
inherent rights amendment
22398 specifically addresses personal
conscience along with religious belief
medical reasons and natural covid
immunity as exceptions to the
vaccination mandate to work in 1868 the
New Hampshire Supreme Court in the case
hail verse Everett ruled that the rights
of conscience can be
surrendered can't be surrendered to
government nor could Society or
government have any claim to assume to
take them away or interfere with them
our state constitution provides citizens
a number of Rights in which choices are
made constitutional rights include but
not limited to the right to bear arms
religious freedom morality and piety
freedom of speech and sovereignty and
more in the court case State verse Drew
1937 ruling was made that an
individual's ideas whether conscience
religious or scientific do not appear to
be more than
opinions the rights of conscience and
religion are unalienable rights that
should not be trampled upon by a single
stroke of any administrative pen it is
therefore my constitutional right to
either be vaccinated or not it's my
choice not that of the government to be
denied employment based upon not being
vaccinated is nothing short of
discrimination and V violates those same
principles as some are currently
advocating for diversity equity and
inclusion this is looking more and more
like a double standard at this point I
want to make it known that I have been
administered three covid vaccinations I
did this in my own bition and as an in
individual choice not because some
entity told me that I had to lastly I
want to address the issue of natural
immunity the Centers for Disease Control
the CDC when asked has said that it has
no record of people who are naturally
immune or transmitting the virus that
causes
covid-19 the CDC did have any didn't
have any documentation reflecting any
case of an individual who never received
a covid-19 vaccine was infected with
covid Once recovered and then later
became infected again and three
transmitted SARS Co 2 another person
when
reinfected however the civil and natural
rights of these individuals who have a
natural immunity are provided no
exception from the vaccine work
requirement even though the CDC has no
objective data supporting the need for
this directive for this group or
naturally immune individuals in closing
this amendment is about personal rights
and personal choice the unnecessary
mandate is a direct assault on state
Powers imposes new burdens on employers
when they can least afford it and makes
daily life much more difficult for the
unvaccinated and their families who want
to work in our New Hampshire economy
with already too few
workers in closing again this uh
Amendment put was put forth to express
the will of the people in New Hampshire
and I hope with all that my belief that
this amendment can be passed thank you
very much for listening to this
presentation
I thank
you thank thank you for thank you for
that but we are not going
to thank you but I as a as a member of
the committee I want to make sure that
you're aware what we just did is
contrary to rules of the house and folks
can be expelled from this chamber
chamber for that so please uh follow
what representative cordelli is probably
going to say after this thank you yes
thank you um I have C here so uh please
pay attention also uh no shows of
emotion the Clapping like we just saw
please um we want to move this as long
as quickly as we can um and that is the
normal decorum in the uh house chamber
uh what we'll be doing is there are two
microphones I'll call call uh two people
at a time the person who's coming up to
speak and the person who's on Deck so
please move to the microphone uh when
your name is called so we can move this
along and um I will start with a uh
state representatives who have signed up
to speak and we will also be trying to
alternate as much as possible between
those who uh support and those who
oppose the
amendment so the first speaker will be
representative Leah kushman and on Deck
will be representative Laura
tersi and let me start uh out by also
saying I apologize in advance if I uh
mispronounce anyone's name just as a
blanket uh apology
representative thank you representative
um so I a few months ago I started an
organization called New Hampshire
healthcare workers for freedom um this
was in response to this was in response
to um the New Hampshire Hospital
Association coming out with language
saying that they encourage all of the
New Hampshire Health Care Systems to
implement vaccine mandates for covid-19
uh for all
employees and uh a lot of nurses doctors
physical therapists respiratory
therapists ancillary staff were
scrambling um you know what do we do and
uh a lot of people weren't informed on
this complicated process to get a
religious or medical exemption under
federal law it's um the religious
exemption is under title seven of the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 and there's a
process for that but it's complicated
and many people don't know it and the
the policies that were coming out from
these Healthcare organizations were in
contrary to the rights that are afforded
under that act and so I
gathered some expert panelists and we
got together and we made a video and um
to try to help people um and direct them
to that video and just help them
understand what their rights are and so
that they could assert them and um you
know push back when these entities were
trying to trample them uh so you have
I've got over a thousand healthcare
workers on on that mailing list and uh
despite all of these efforts many have
been fired many have had their religious
exemptions object uh
rejected um it's a travesty I I know
that um in conquered Hospital there's
something like 30% of the healthcare
workers there didn't want to get a
vaccine and now many have uh been
coerced because they have to care for
their family and they don't have the
option to lose their
income um and
so you know there's this complicated
process for a religious exemption and
then on top of that there are people who
don't have religious beliefs they may
have medical and they're having a hard
time even getting a medical is um
exemption so they can't doctors are
afraid to write them notes saying that
they are it's contraindicated for them
to get the vaccine because they're
afraid of Retribution from the medical
boards um so it's just a very convoluted
difficult thing for all these healthcare
workers who you know many of them swore
an oath to uphold the rights of patients
and one of those rights um I know in
nursing ethics the first provision of
the Ana code of ethics is to um protect
patient dignity and under that falls
self-determination that's bodily
autonomy we have to protect that right
for all of our patients and when we are
deciding whether we take a um medical
treatment or not
that is that that's a medical
intervention and we should be afforded
those rights too it doesn't stop just
because we've chosen a career in
healthcare um and briefly I just want to
read a um a quick testimony from do
Danny steel he's a doctor in the North
country and a master in public health um
proposed infringement into the area of
bodily autonomy and rights of refusal
for medical procedures treatments Etc
should be handled with extrem extrem
scrutiny as these areas are the most
foundational Bedrock of Independence and
Liberty the right to personal property
is absolutely essential to a free and
Democratic Society and what property is
more basic and personal than one's own
body vaccination mandates essentially
constitute a corporeal manifestation of
imminent
domain thank you for for allowing me to
testify thank you uh next is
representative tersi and following her
will be representative
BLK
good morning colleagues of House
Education and thank you for giving me a
moment to speak my name is Laura tersi
and I represent Hillsboro 35 which is
Nashville's w 8 I'm here today to
register my opposition to the non-
gerine amendment
2239 that is being proposed for HB
255 in the last few weeks we have seen
numbers that show co9 is spreading at a
rate our state has not seen since last
winter last week daily numbers surged
past 1,000 new positive cases a day the
most we have seen since January when
vaccinations were just beginning the
7-Day positivity rate has surged to
88.8% the highest weekly rate since
testing began hospitalizations continue
to rise and out of the large number of
active cases the majority are under the
age of 18 children in our schools many
of whom have not had the time yet to be
vaccinated with the recent approval
which is why I'm even more baffled that
this amendment is being proposed in an
education committee if we want to get a
grasp on this crisis and eventually
start to repair the damage it has done
to our state this is not the time to
consider this
amendment this amendment is overly Broad
in the groups it would apply to
including private businesses private
schools and even daycare centers if a
child care center makes the choice to
hire only vaccinated employees because
that is what their client families want
want and a service for the protection of
their children they should be able to do
that if a private business believes a
healthy and safe work environment for
all employees begins with vaccination
they should be able to require it and if
a club or nonprofit wants to assure its
members they will be safe when
participating or volunteering they
should be able to offer that
guarantee now is not the time to be
passing this wide sweeping amendment
that didn't go through the normal
process a bill takes for the public to
be notified and educated about we should
be trying to figure out how we can come
together to slow down the spread of the
disease not opening the floodgates and
encouraging it I'd like to remind
everyone that at last count there are
1,630 families in our state who are
mourning the loss of a loved one to
covid-19 and I encourage you to oppose
Amendment 2239 H thank you for the time
thank you representative uh
representative BLC is up next and
representative Horgan will
follow um hi I'm representative Melissa
blasik I represent Hillsboro 21 the
testimony I'm going to give was reviewed
by doctors and scientists and created
with their help I will be giving a list
of their names to the
committee before I get started I want to
present this compilation of studies to
the committee I will be giving it to
them it's 141 studies over 1,600 pages
that support the claims I'm going to
make here today that natural immunity is
Broad durable and long lasting that the
covid-19 vaccinations cannot prevent
Community outbreaks that the covid-19
vaccine efficacy wains and that the
covid-19 vaccinated people can spread
covid-19 just as easily as an
unvaccinated person when infected I want
to I want to state that we are all
hoping to find the best solution to the
covid-19 pandemic that saves the most
amount of lives and prevents the most
amount of suffering the vaccine mandate
cannot accomplish this goal let's begin
with natural immunity um I'm going to
consider some of the studies I'm
presenting to the committee today study
number one comparing SARS Cove 2 natural
immunity with vaccine induced immunity
reinfections versus breakthrough
infections natural immunity confers
longer lasting and stronger protection
against infection um SARS um CO2
vaccines had a
1306 increased risk for breakthrough
infection with a Delta variant 27 fold
increase in risk of symptomatic covid
and eight-fold increased risk of
hospitalization study number two SARS Co
2 reinfection risk in Austria protection
against SARS Cove 2 after natural
infection is comparable with the highest
available estimates on vaccine e
efficacies study number three
quantifying the risk of SARS code 2
reinfection over time reinfection was an
uncommon event with no study reporting
an increase in the risk of reinfection
over time I could go on all day but I
will move on um there is no evidence
that the co 19 vaccine sto transmission
um I had charts but apparently I'm not
allowed to show charts in this room um I
was going to share the UK data because
they track the data on vaccinated versus
unvaccinated individuals uh the best of
any country in the world and the rates
are almost double in most age categories
amongst the vaccinated versus the
unvaccinated because of the waning
effect especially in older populations
so the next question is can an infected
uh vaccinated person transmit Co 19 the
answer is most assuredly yes viral load
is the amount of virus the higher the
viral load the more likely a person is
infectious study number one no
significant difference in viral load
between vaccinated and unvaccinated
asymptomatic and symptomatic groups when
infected with SARS Cove 2 Delta variant
study number two vaccinated and
unvaccinated individuals have similar
viral load in communities with high
prevalence again I can continue all day
but I will move on these vaccines have a
very marked waning effect in both
breakthrough infections and disease out
outcomes that means if you're going to
mandate a vaccine you would need to
mandate continuous boosters to maintain
any type of efficacy and we have zero
data on the health effects of continuing
these shots indefinitely again I was
going to show some other studies um
showing that uh higher the vaccination
rates are not correlated in any way with
disease outbreaks in fact it can be the
opposite so in conclusion while vaccine
mandates Shred the principle of informed
consent violate bodily autonomy and
infringed upon the most basic of
individual liberties there is also zero
scientific basis for mandating covid-19
vaccines thank
you please no applause please um
representative Horgan and then
representative
gay thank you very much Mr chair I will
uh hopefully you can hear me with my uh
with my mask on I would be very
reluctant to take it off but I I can for
a couple of minutes if you need
me to be heard um I can hope hopefully
this won't go against my four minutes or
three minutes that the uh the gentle
lady charts she is um welcome to
reproduce them on 8 by1 size and
distribute them as written testimony to
the committee and hopefully they'll have
a chance to look at it during the few
minutes we mean the hearing and it'll be
in the record so if she wants those
charts in the record there is a way she
can introduce them please proceed thank
you okay well there process issues
Galore first of all this proposal
totally does not belong to the education
committee at all um it's also amends the
wrong RSA it's about uh conditions of
employment and that's just part of what
this proposal tries to do and um and of
course the reason I know we all know the
reason why we're the education committee
is doing is because every other
committee has finished their work and
this is the only retained bill this
amendment can be attached to but um we
don't need it this should have been
taken up in the normal course of
business next year like in
January um also it B vaccine mandates by
any entity in New Hampshire which is
vague and overly broad includes many
entities which the state of New
Hampshire has little no jurisdiction
over in in fact we now know it was
directly um directed against the federal
government which uh we don't have
jurisdiction over um I won't get into
the fact the definition entity is
topological basically boils down to
quote a quote entity is any entity so
it's kind of a meaningless definition
nor there's also course there's no
penalties no enforcement
mechanism but the big problem is this is
fundamentally a bad idea the state
should be encouraging as many people as
possible to get
vaccinated and it should be supporting
those employers who recognize the need
to require their Workforce to be
vaccinated and or tested not undermining
them we haven't heard it here yet but
I'm only the fifth or sixth speaker but
the antia forces have co-opted an old
Progressive slogan from the early 70s my
body my
choice I want to co-opt slightly older
conservative slogan from the late 60s
the silent
majority to refer to those who recognize
how serious the covid P 19 pandemic is
and also recognize that the
vaccinations and the other precau we
have been taking for the past two years
aren
necessary in fact I think the silent
majority of the American people
instinctively sense how bad the pandemic
was back when the media and president
Trump were still pretending the vaccine
would go away in a few days and actually
I'm a Democrat I should admit we had a
primary campaign going on and most of
our candidates didn't address the
pandemic before mid-march when turned
into a
crisis I think they um and they
recognized that the masks were necessary
they they now recognize the vaccines are
necessary and they've been quietly doing
the right thing for the past 2 years
with no whining with no unnecessary
drama without making big fuss I think
they're not here because they're just
getting on with their lives so I myself
count myself as one of the sign the
majority why because I want to live and
I also want those who breathe the same
air as me which includes everyone on
Earth to
live represent please conclude uh and
anyway please but please vote no in this
amendment and also say I understand
these masks like this one I'm wearing
they're not 100% effective the vaccines
are not 100%
uh the vaccines are not 100% safe or
100% effective but they're far better
than the pandemic this has killed
760,000 people just in the United States
5 million
Nationwide this is the worst catastrophe
in American history since the Civil War
anyway so please vote no and if you want
to take this up next year we can have
another hearing we thank you
representative representative gay and
then uh Dr Amy
hos representative Betty gay from Salem
and I speak because I know that this is
a scary scary disease but it does have
treatment but
unfortunately
unfortunately our media and a lot of our
government has bought into the fear that
there is no treatment uh that you have
to take a vaccine and now that we've
been doing it for for months and months
and months we the truth is coming out
that vaccines do not protect you except
for a very few months and your own
natural immunity does work for a very
long time it's the best India is a poor
country they have contained the the
disease twice they did it with
Ivermectin which we can't get because of
the prejudice against the the medicine
it used to be really cheap now if you
can find it it's gone from at least 87
cents a pill to $10 a pill the
pharmacies I called every pharmacy
around where I live in Salem every one
of them has been ordered not to fill
prescriptions every one of them I found
one independent compounding one that
will make it but they're having a hard
time getting the powder now now they're
down to uh filling prescriptions with
liquids it's like 10 milligrams per
CC okay the real important thing is we
have to fight fear with information and
we have to press for being treated
that's how India stopped The Scourge and
they had a I have a map on the back I
don't know if you can see it but they
have many states like we have even
though they're much smaller and when
they had the first surge in the
2020 they gave icton out it was very
cheap they make it it suppressed The
Surge then some woman I'm glad I don't
know her name she's now she she got very
high in India and she said this is wrong
we shouldn't do it so they
stopped after the surge this year they
decided they were GNA put her on trial
and they were going to give it to
everybody again so this map shows all
but one state had already started
suppressing the count and there was just
one that hadn't received
it c19 vax
reaction.com
c19 vax
reaction.com is why why we should not
require people to take a vaccine people
are being even if it's a low number of
people who are getting horrendous
lifethreatening
life paralyzing
reactions you don't confuse low odds
with low stakes the stakes can be your
life it should be your choice to take a
vaccine I know lots of people have taken
it but I'm not going
to
pleas
please no shows of emotion um we've said
that again U and next is Dr hos and she
will be followed by repres former
representative
H good
morning uh I'm Dr Amy H I have been a
business owner and a resident of NASA
for a decade I'm writing I'm speaking as
it concerns citizen to voice my
opposition to Mandate of the covid-19
shots here in our state I support the
amendment which stipulates this bill
prohibits New Hampshire entities from
compelling receipt of a covid-19 vaccine
by any individual who objects to such
vaccination I'll open by stating my
qualifications for the opinions that I
hold I hold a masters and a PhD and I
completed a post-doctoral fellowship at
Harvard and transition to a biotech uh
to work as a research scientist due to
concerns about the Pharma industry and
specifically about the process of FDA
approval I left my career as a scientist
and chose to pursue a career in
chiropractic care I'm currently a
practicing doctor of Chiropractic I'm
I'm privileged to pursue my passion of
helping people to restore and promote
health I'm so sorry I'm a little bit
nervous uh with these qualifications I
hope it is clear to you that I do not
make these statements like lightly and
when I State my case it is supported by
research evidence biology statistics and
experience in short I won't say that uh
for the following statement I will not
be rattling off references but I'll will
be happy to provide those to any of you
if you wish I have plenty of references
peer review to support my statements
I'll start with the matter at Hand by
stating that these shots do absolutely
statistically reduce the incidents of
severe complications of covid-19
including hospitalization and death and
that's
wonderful especially for those who have
pre-existing conditions that put them at
high risk the impacts on the rate of
infection and transmission however have
been less striking as data have been
coming in since the release of these
products last year indicate the results
have actually been very disappointing
from the perspective of this former
scientist who has been reading the
papers the CDC itself recently stated
that these shots do not stop
transmission
and the statement is supported by a
multitude of peer-reviewed research
therein lies the distinction between
Public Health as compared to a personal
or private Health
decision a decision that affects others
is about public and Community Health
where whereas a decision that affects
you is about your personal health and
your personal choices if the shots
cannot stop transmission then they do
not benefit Comm the community as a
whole rather only the individuals within
it therefore the choice as to whether to
accept or decline the shot is a personal
one and not one that should be mandated
by any school employer state or
president allow me to take that
distinction a bit further the choice to
accept or decline this medical
intervention is and should be informed
Choice instead of free will indeed
informed choice is a basic human right
as outlined by the UNESCO Universal
Declaration of bioethics and human
rights in
2005 uh without
right the right to decline without
punishment or consequence is a human
right that is violated by any medical
mandate regardless of it regardless of
its efficacy and this is the issue at
Center Stage today truly that's what
we're looking at the issue do we have
the choice to put what we wish or
decline what we wish in terms of a
medical Intervention which may actually
not be necessary or helpful for certain
people thank you very much for listening
and thank you for listening to all of us
thank you
please uh next is uh former
representative hle and then will be
Priscilla moral of
Peterboro thank you members of house
education for the record representative
hle town of
Dunbarton uh a former member of this
committee I would like to set thank
representative lad for introducing
Amendment 20222 39h and I would like to
speak in favor of it I wear Three Hats
today I'm going to speak personally for
a minute I'm going to speak as a founder
or co-founder of reopen New Hampshire
and I'm going to read some testimony
from former State Rep um its as
well the Constitution has given under
part 2 Article 2 the following the
supreme legislative power within this
state shall be vested in the Senate and
the House of Representatives Each of
which shall have the negative of the
other unlike all the other states in our
Union this legislative body has more
Authority we're not like Massachusetts
we're not a collection of small cities
the legislative authority to run this
state is it within the body that you
guys are part of and that's great news
and it gives you guys the chance to do
something about this the second point
I'd like to make is corporations are not
individuals they're not
citizens what they are is a construct of
the state you guys have an obligation
under part 1 Article 4 to protect the
rights of the citizens not necessarily
to go out and advocate for corporations
so I would just at corporations are a
great thing i' I've built them right I
I've run them I founded a corporation I
currently have an LLC but they are a
construct of the state they do not share
the same rights as
Citizens and then lastly I'd like to um
reopen supports the amendment would ask
that you guys would even consider at
some level um there needs to be some
penalties this is great in terms of a
policy Direction but what happens if
someone goes ahead and just puts in
place a covid requirement for work puts
in the the jab versus job requirement um
how do we stop that and then I'd like to
read from representative V for various
reasons could not be here today his
testimony and I quote HB 255 right of
conscience Amendment members of the
House committee on education thank you
for taking the time to hear my testimony
I am urging you to stand in defense of
our state constitution
the operative articles in question are
the Bill of Rights articles four and
five article four States among natural
rights some are in their very nature
unalienable because no equivalent can be
given or received for them of this kind
are the rights of conscience Article 5
goes on to describe a prot protection of
one right of conscience in particular
worshiping God according to the dictates
of your
conscience and this is Dan speaking or
representative D speaking I for one do
not believe the objection to these
vaccination needs to be a religious
exemption last winter my wife spent
about 4 hours on the phone with the
CDC sorry needs to be a religious
exemption she first she had to wait 20
minutes on the phone to be answered she
spoke with a young woman asking if any
of the covid-19 vaccinations contained
human fetal tissue in about 20 more
minutes the woman came back oh I'm going
to run out of time um he goes on to note
that um there is in fact fetal tissue in
all the vaccinations either in the
development or the production thereof
and that is that is um antithetical to
his belief as a Christian I would I have
copies of his testimony I would ask that
you you read them and thank you for
listening to me take
care please Applause
again uh represent excuse me uh M moral
and then will'll be uh representative
Aaron hello uh I'm Priscilla moral I
live in Peterboro New Hampshire and um
I want to just express my appreciation
for everyone who's here today because I
know it's because we care that we're
here and that's why I love living in New
Hampshire I've lived here longer than
I've lived anywhere else in my life and
um I'm really grateful to be
here um I'm deeply concerned about
vaccine mandates I had a flu shot 5
years ago and um I became very very ill
um where before I had rarely ever been
ill in my lifetime I could count on one
hand the number of
times um so I I went to my doctor um
many many times and there were tests
after tests after tests and
um at the time there was you know no
connection made between the vaccine and
um the numerous symptoms I suddenly had
for some people vaccines mean a lifetime
of illness and disability and when I
wasn't able to figure out what was going
on with me I had to start doing some of
my own research and I found that the
symptoms that I experienced were not
dissimilar from other people who' have
had bad reactions from
shots so
um I have three friends who did get the
Corona virus vaccine actually I probably
have more than that but they uh they
reported to me um some illnesses one of
them had to go to the emergency room and
is still dealing with
symptoms um another has suffered heart
issues and
hospitalization and a third rep reported
debilitating illnesses that lasted for
months so these are some of the
short-term effects of the vaccine
what are the long-term
effects no one here today can say
because it's an experimental
product instead of the vaccine I have
chosen to focus on vitamin C zinc and
vitamin D among other
supplements and those who have chosen to
get a vaccine I respect their decision
everybody has to make their own choice
about what is right for their health
I see no reason to force me to get
it given that those who have chosen to
get a shot have done so and are able to
do so if they are worried about their
health I will not expose this body to an
experimental product whose long-term
effects are unknown and I urge you to
pass the amendment thank
you
that
please said it multiple times no
applause um after each speaker uh next
is representative Aaron and she will be
followed by uh Dustin Richwine of
Manchester
representative thank you committee uh
chair and and thank you uh to the
committee for having this hearing
today I'm a co-sponsor of HB
255 and I am delighted to see this
amendment come
forth of course I'm testifying in favor
of this
amendment and I'm asking you to vote OTP
on
it with people being threatened with
losing their jobs over covid vaccine
mandates I believe it is imperative for
New Hampshire to make this
law New Hampshire is at a Crossroads
here and I think it's important to
realize that a lot of our
businesses are somewhat being put in a
position to make these mandates because
of what's coming out of the federal
government maybe what their insurance
company is advising them to do there's a
host of reasons and I think it's
important for us as a state to make
policy so that they are not forced to do
these kinds of things that perhaps they
don't want to
do
and you know for all those people who
say oh we shouldn't be telling
businesses how to run their business we
do this every
day we tell businesses what size grease
trap to put in to install we tell
businesses how many people they can
serve in their premises we tell
businesses how many cars they can have
in their parking lot so we tell
businesses how to operate all the time
I don't see that that's a valid excuse
for not passing this
amendment
and I believe that this amendment is
important in order pres in order to
preserve personal and individual rights
especially as it applies to an employees
own decisions regarding their own health
care if we continue to allow businesses
to dictate to their employees that they
may take that they must take the covid
vaccine specifically in order to keep
their job will there be no end to what
other covid treatments they might
mandate uh at the whim of the CDC and
the federal government and at whose
expense especially if there's no
liability for this vaccine makers or the
employer
for sick or even dying and with this
covid vaccine there has been people who
who who have died from it how do we
allow employee employers to mandate
something um a treatment that could
cause death or
injury and no one should be um coerced
to doing this medical decisions are
personal and you know I I'm I'm hearing
people saying if you don't like it then
find a new job well you can't always do
that people have seniority they have
pensions they have mortgages to pay they
have a livelihood and you many times you
just can't start out and start over
thank you so I want to end by saying
please OTP this this amendment and I
appreciate your time listening to all of
us thank you U next is uh Mr Rich wine
and he will be followed by Derek
Arnold hello Representatives my my name
is Dustin Richwine I I'm a concerned
citizen from Manchester I here in
support of HB
255 the current moment is a time of
unprecedented change in this country we
live at the very tail end of the golden
age of this
Republic history will one day tell the
story of the precipice on which we sit
today our actions here will be looked
back on with Wonder and likely
regret fellow new hampshirites I ask you
what power do we have
left are we but a handful of the 340
million subjects of an
Empire every president of this country
acts more as a dictator than the one
before more executive powers have been
usurped than I can possibly mention
here I don't need to convince you here
that the threat to our Liberty comes not
from this body of government but from
above fortunately we have begun to see a
trend of push back against this
overreach in recent years from Sanctuary
cities to the Cannabis industry to
Second Amendment
protections states are finally saying no
to unconstitutional Federal action
the executive vaccine mandate decree by
President Biden is yet another
unprecedented power
grab that will not end with
vaccines ladies and gentlemen I implore
you to finally push back we must
directly oppose these big Pharma
mandates while we still have any
sovereignty left as a state we must
protect our rights to privacy and
medical autonomy
we must stand as a lone Bastion of
freedom in our corner of this vast land
to show others that we hold to our
principles to give to those from the
many fascistic states which ignore their
constitutions a guarantee that if they
come here that their lives and
livelihoods will not be taken away from
them not in New
Hampshire when this unsustainable
immoral system finally meets its
inevitable demise when the dollar no
longer has value when the failed Federal
Behemoth Falls who will we be I hope we
can be proud to say we are from New
Hampshire thank
you please once again please no
applause um next is um Mr Arnold and uh
he'll be followed by Virginia held or
healed from
miramac good morning we the people and
good morning the people that serve We
the
People bottom
line out front I said this last week
some heard this but maybe when everybody
leaves here today they should stop at
the monument on the front lawn that
states
preser
preserve
freedom of
humanity that means all
Humanity all life
matters preserve means we save lives we
don't take lives I'm not here to change
Minds I'm here to change
hearts and turn
biological into
logical 1776 we had the common law the
act of 1871 turned us to maritime law
2021 we're going to Common Sense law
with logic awareness and wisdom use it
do your research like I do I don't have
a degree but I have a lot of hours on
the road a lot of States traveled a lot
of faces seen in different places
so I'm asking the hearts of everybody
that is serving we the people that took
Oaths including teachers that are
forcing mask on children each child
forced to wear a mask to breathe carbon
monoxide in is child abuse and when we
see on our constitution to preserve
Humanity child abuse is crimes Against
Humanity and anybody forcing it should
be ashamed of
themselves I'm here not for me I'm here
for my children I'm here for my six
grandbabies I'm here for all of you and
I'm also here for
you so step in the light shine
bright do what is
right let's go Brandon
[Applause]
please good morning committee I'm
Virginia heeld from marac New Hampshire
thank you for letting us be here get
closer um my testimony today is a very
personal one based on uh the situation
that we are all facing today please bear
with me I am going someplace with I
promise I spent 20 years in an abusive
marriage for the better part of 20 years
I was told what I could and could not do
what I could and could not wear or even
cut my
hair I was restricted from having
certain friends and even from seeing my
family and from where I could and could
not
go these restrictions actions and
movements were monitored if I went
against these rules quote unquote there
were consequences always emotional
degrading consequences sometimes often
times
worse many would ask why did I stay why
did I Endure this every time every day I
had to make the decision to make the
choice to weigh the pros and cons and
take a hard look at my options do I
leave and lose my home my family
possibly my child and much of what I had
worked for do I stay and continue to
endure this further abuse physical harm
or worse after much soul searching and
praying I finally found the strength and
The Bravery to leave no matter the
consequences I had no money no job and
no place to go I did lose everything
everything I was afraid of losing I
lost many would say and I'm sure many
here would agree that's not right it's
not fair it's wrong it's criminal no one
woman child or man should have to live
live like that to be forced to make this
decision no one should lay a hand on you
with the intent of harming you or worse
why didn't I call the police why didn't
I fight
back why didn't I leave the first moment
at
happen fear the fear of leaving was
greater than the fear of staying figure
that one
out if this amendment is not approved
vaccine mandates will be required for
employment attending school social
public Gatherings and anywhere go
anywhere we go it will be contrary to
our freedoms rights and privileges that
so many have fought and died for us to
have for the ne necessities and the
pleasures of life and God willing to
enjoy our lives if this amendment is not
approved we will be forced to comply
with those mandates or there may be
consequences now I ask you how would
that be different from what I went
through it is not okay for a man to beat
his wife for child then why is it okay
for have us to have to receive a vaccine
that could harm us possibly Mame us for
life or worse I am faced again now with
the very real possibility that I could
lose everything again lose my job lose
my home everything that I have worked so
hard to rebuild it's not right it's not
fair it's wrong it's criminal it is
abuse committee please approve this
amendment be the change be one to join
this movement to stop the abuse and to
retrieve retrieve and preserve our
freedoms thank you um Mr uh Wayne Wright
Scott Wayne Wright is next and it will
be followed by uh Karen
testerman good morning my name is Scott
way I'm from Lebanon um um I don't have
a prepared statement I'm just coming
here to express my uh support for this
bill
um I have that had the vaccines um my
current employer is is following through
with the mandates I'm safe because I've
submitted the paperwork but that's not
right it is just not right I know at
least personally three people at my at
my employer that are leaving or have
already left because of this
mandate it's just not right
it goes against our freedoms it goes
against what everything everybody's
already said here today I can I could
have on for hours about it but I just
feel like we need to pass this mandate
we need to push
back thank
you thank you
sir Miss testerman to be followed by
Russ
Payne thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
committee for being here and thank you
all of you for taking the time out of
your day to show up because this is what
New Hampshire is all about we are the
only state in the Union where you can do
this where we do not get closed out
because some uh committee chairman
decides they want to change things I'm
here to plead with you to please pass
this amendment but I'm asking you also
to please add some teeth to any
violations of this amendment because
without the legislation having teeth so
many of the laws that you've already
passed and are in our um in our law
books now are ignored and I bring to
your
attention RSA 126
u4 which specifically says
you are not allowed as a school or any
treatment facility to inhibit the
breathing of a
child and if you go through and you read
the
definitions and you read the
law every one of the schools in this
state are breaking the
laws anybody who owns a business and
requires a child to put on a facial
cover uing is also breaking the law and
yet there's nothing that is ever done
when those laws are broken and instead
our parents are called domestic
terrorists and it's time that we stop
and it's time that you in do your due
diligence and make sure that there's
teeth in the laws that you pass please
pass this amendment and
please
make this the state that we've all come
to love and Live Free or Die not live to
comply thank you thank
[Applause]
please enough um Mr Payne will be
followed by Dr
Nas good morning my name is Russ Payne
from
marac I support the
amendment met a guy the other day had
asked me if I was vaccinated and I told
him by hippol laws I don't discuss that
with anybody except my
doctor I okay uh lenon Soviet
dictator is on record as saying that
Health Care is the arch Stone the
Keystone of the communist
state uh just as uh just just as without
the Keystone of Arch the communist state
Falls without health care I say the
keystone arch of American ordered
Liberty is that both citizens and
leaders need to obey the constitution in
the United States in the summer of 2020
and hundreds of cities we had Anarchy
while state and local authorities for
the most part ignored these criminal
acts of destru ction even more a threat
of
Liberty
is moral Anarchy leaders in the federal
government and state government servants
both elected and appointed who refuse to
obey the Constitution they are sworn to
this flies in the face of article one
section one of the US
Constitution that says all legislative
power power here in granted is vested in
the House of Representatives and the
Senate underline
all all means all it does not mean these
powers can be farmed out to
bureaucracies like the
DHHS Rogue powers that ignore the law of
the
land you and the state legislature are
the checks and balances critical to our
Liberty an inherent responsibility that
our Founders placed in your hands for
such a time as this America did not
become great because of what the
government did for us America became
great because of
what the government was prevented from
doing by the
Constitution I urge you to support this
amendment this ever in increasing lust
for power and control will not stop
itself the New Hampshire legislature
must fulfill one of the primary purposes
one of its primary purposes protect our
people from the federal power that our
children and children's children may
live in Liberty thank you very much
thank you n
please Dr Nash will be followed by Kate
fry
my name is Marl Les I'm a main physician
vaccine expert chaired a main
legislative committee and testified to
six congressional committees um excuse
me for trying to reduce a six minute to
a three minute talk so the UK's top
vaccine expert Andre Pard said herd
immunity with vaccines is not a
possibility since we can't achieve her
immunity with these vaccines the
inevitable result is that practically
everyone will eventually get
covid there is no reason to think
boosters will prevent transmission when
the initial series didn't instead it's
crucial to focus on early treatment why
doesn't everybody know this because had
the benefits of existing drugs been
acknowledged there could have been no
emergency use authorizations or euas
issued for vaccines were Des severe or
monoclonals all of which are
multi-billion dollar patentable
products hydroxy chloroquin and icton
were already approved adequate and
available as well as being cheap and
they had to be suppressed in order to
issue euas for these other things um I
created a handout of treatments please
in New Hampshire don't allow treatments
to be restricted nor persecute doctors
and pharmacists who issue them few
people are aware that in a senate
hearing on May 11 um Peter marks winsky
of CDC and fouchi were asked how many
people in their agencies were already
vaccinated no one gave a number but
fouchy and Marx estimated a little over
half what did thousands of scientists in
the NIH FDA and CDC know that you didn't
know they knew about Skyhigh rates of
myocarditis in young men in especially
teenagers and deaths which had been
discussed in the Israeli media in April
but had not been disclosed in the US
until June they knew deaths were
extremely high there have been more
deaths reported to the vaccine adverse
event reporting system for covid
vaccines in 10 months than were reported
for every other vaccine used in the
United States over 30 years
cumulatively record setting rates of
death have also been reported in the US
and Europe and most of these occurred
within 48 Hours of vaccination or half
of
them CDC estim imates at least half our
kids are already immune but the feds
have not allowed Americans to use any
test to prove
immunity yet FDA accepts antibody tests
as evidence of immunity in covid vaccine
clinical trials why the double
standard the younger you are the greater
the risk of
myocarditis in 12 to 17y old males the
risk is a 100 times higher after
vaccination than men over
65 a study showed teenage boys are three
to six times as likely to be
hospitalized for myocarditis as they are
to be hospitalized for covid it's a
serious side effect uh that I'll try to
wrap up that can cause sudden death in
three months a quarter of people are of
kids are still not
cured did you know that in three major
cities children are being vaccinated
without parental
consent thank thank you
uh Kate fry and then Dr
soilson good morning members of the
committee uh I will be brief and I have
written testimony so I will not read my
testimony today just hit the highlights
we appreciate the opportunity to testify
in opposition to this non- gerine
amendment relative to prohibiting
vaccines in New Hampshire new Futures is
a nonpartisan nonprofit organization
that Advocates advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all New Hampshire residents
in this role we work with policy makers
healthare providers and communities to
improve overall Public Health Equity
across the granite state the covid-19
vaccine has played a significant role in
changing the course of this pandemic
time and time again Public Health
experts have said that widespread
vaccinations including booster shots is
the best way to lessen the impact of the
covid-19 Mandate based on the public
health science
from experts some employers have made
decisions to mandate vaccines for the
health and safety of their employees and
individuals they serve while several
organizations have chosen not to the
freedom to make these decisions should
be made left up to private
entities this amendment proes proposes
to allow any employee to request a
conscientious exemption this effort
would apply to every employer including
private schools clubs religious
organizations nonprofits corporations
Etc if passed the amendment would tie
the hands of these
organizations to employ um uh Public
Health policies medical and religious
exemptions are a necessary compon
component to employee mandated covid-19
vaccines however an an an objection
based on conscientious or philosophical
reasons essentially allowing an easy opt
out to anyone would reverse the progress
New Hampshire has made in defeating this
pandemic
state government should not prevent a
private entity from making new futures
or from making choices based on the
public health safety concerns especially
during a public health pandemic new
future strongly urges the committee to
vote against this
amendment thank you Dr sobl is next and
he will be followed by Katherine
Deon acting chairman cordelli and House
Education committee members uh my name
is Dr Gary soilson and I'm a family
physician I in conquered and I'm past
president of the New Hampshire Academy
of family physicians and the New
Hampshire Medical Society I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Medical
Society uh in support of the New
Hampshire Public Health Community in
opposition to the amendment
2239 the reason we oppose this amendment
is largely because such measures help
the health of our patients uh very
limited other concerns or all bring up
some some issues of medical ethics as
well non-governmental vaccine
requirements have long demonstrated
Effectiveness in reducing work spread of
disease and there's increased evidence
from Healthcare environments which only
over the past two months have imposed
mandates and requirements that they are
increasing vaccine rates and reducing
the rates of disease I came here today
from a nursing facility in this
community with the difference between
the impact of our current outbreak and
the prior outbreak because of the
Mandate in this case the Genesis
Corporation the National Corporation has
posed on its employees has made a huge
difference in the AM impact of this
particular pandemic In This Very
high-risk Community the healthcare
environment including hospitals doctor's
offices long-term care facilities and
other Allied Health professional
businesses know we have special
requirements and special responsibility
in fact many hospitals in our states
have long had requirements for
vaccinations including flu vaccinations
and there's other examples too we
mandate invasive testing for
tuberculosis
we mandate hygiene we mandate at times
even the way you dress um we've banned
smoking in many of our workplaces
because you can't light up without
affecting the air others breathe we
allow drug testing in many Industries
because it's dangerous and we worry
about the safety of the work
environments without such practices many
of these are not government requirements
they are decisions made by thousands of
individual business owners and employers
and they work to keep us healthier and
better off but government's been
involved too and they've protected our
children from historically horrible
illnesses spread by classmates by
mandating vaccinations in schools and
through dozens of Public Health measures
that give you confidence in the water
you drink and the air you breathe and
vaccination against covid-19 is only the
latest measure of such and is such an
example there are ethical principles too
that the health profession has
beneficence the obligation to do good
bring about good health non-maleficence
the obligation not to do harm and
autonomy the obligation that people have
to make their own decisions the
amendment you're considering throws out
two principles in the name of the third
and it flies in the face of our sense of
scientific reason we ask that you not
place the principle of autonomy of
individual rights over its companion
principles not putting those principles
in Balance puts puts is example of of
something like supporting Typhoid Mary
the food worker
who spread life-threatening illness to
New York City residents until she was
stopped where it's the equivalent of
allowing someone to have free speech by
yelling fire in a crowded theater the
New Hampshire medical society and its
2200 member Physicians respectfully
request that you and the legislature
step back from imposing government
regulation on the rights of thousands of
businesses both in health care and on
Main Street thank
you excuse me uh doctor would you uh
accept the question
question thank you Mr chairman
representative Tim Lang representing
belnap 4 um I guess my question Dr View
and I asked the medical society this
before in hp220 Committee hearing and I
was unable to get a clear answer so my
guess my question for you is involving
around informed consent and the ethical
concerns for the medical community in
that when when an individual is only
giving informed consent over threat of
coion of losing their job or a financial
incentive doesn't that create a healthc
care Quagmire for doctors on whether or
not a person's informed consent is free
and
[Applause]
voluntary uh representative absolutely
informed consent is a is a very basic
ethical principle of making medical
decisions and I would never stand
against that that there's no question
that individuals have the right to make
a decision not to get a vaccine the
question really is whether or not that
right then extends to the
right sorry whether or not that extends
to the right to hold the job exactly so
the Typhoid Mary example I think is the
classic one in medical history that an
individual there who had a infectious
disease which presented risk to others
um had her right had her rights
eventually settled in the courts of New
York City to lost the right to
employment so so I think it's a very
good point though there's no question
that informed consent is a basic ethical
principle followup my thank you again my
question came down around the ethical
Quagmire we're putting health care
providers in in that a person who is
giving informed consent is either being
coarsed financially because they have to
keep their job to keep a roof over their
head food on their uh table for their
families and that the informed consent
is no longer free and voluntary and how
does it doctor H how do you navigate
that what is the way you can actually
ask that question are you asking that
question of informed consent or are you
just assuming because they're showing up
they can get in the shot that their
consent free and
[Applause]
voluntary I don't personally see those
in I don't personally see those in
Conflict I think individuals have to
make that decision they absolutely
should be giving their consent with the
information of the consequences of that
decision if someone has an acute append
comes to me and I say to them you know
you have you know I you need to have
this operation they say well I'm not
going to have this operation you know I
I don't believe in that that's fine and
they accept the consequences of that
decision I think most decisions of of
import have consequences and I think we
would both agree on that I think in this
particular case the decision not to get
vaccinated these are not unreasonable
consequences from the from the medical
professional's
Viewpoint thank you please
this is a a historic chamber we will
exercise decorum in it representative
did you have a question I did thank you
very much Mr chair um and thank you very
much doctor for uh for joining us uh
this morning I was wondering if you
could uh comment a little bit on the um
the uh uh level of protection through
antibodies in a in a person who has
recovered from
covid-19 um and uh and talk a little bit
about how that um uh uh compares to um
to the protection received through
vaccine yeah I'm not I want to stay up
right up front I'm not an expert in
Immunology or in virology I'm a family
physician and I and I and I absolutely
want to State my opinion would be
related to what I've read and what many
of you have read uh I think the
statements that were made uh implying
that people who had survived have have
recovered from covid-19 have ongoing
immunity are accurate state stat that
there is evidence that there is very
very low risk of reinfection in that
group it's not zero so people have to
make their own decisions and if and if
this amendment likely was restricted to
saying that people who have proven prior
disease and antibodies present there
have been other measures offered here
I'm not sure the medical society would
be standing here saying that that's an
unreasonable alternative you know but
but having said so I think that answers
your question but that's based on you
know just my own scientific reading as
the rest of I don't want to claim to be
an expert there thank thank you Doctor
uh up next is Mission and she'll be
followed by Ronnie
party my name is Katherine Dion I live
in Allenstown New Hampshire I'm here
speaking on behalf of myself my daughter
who works in the health care field all
my friends who work in the health care
field and my two grandchildren who
attend conquered Public Schools the
vaccines that would be forced upon the
last third of the eligible population in
New Hampshire were made using the
original Wuhan form of the SARS K2 virus
that arrived here about two years ago
this month as an RNA virus it is less
stable than DNA viruses and therefore
much more ready to mutate While most are
concerned now with a Delta variant that
has come out of India back in February
of 2020 four variants had already been
um identified these variants all can
cause sickness and death yet people are
being vaccinated only against the
original Wuhan Alpha strain while these
vaccines vaccines May mitigate symptoms
in some people it does not stop them
from spreading the virus and in some
cases cause more lasting harm than
having caught the virus some of these
vaccine adverse effects include
neuropathies heart problems organ
failure and death Studies have been done
in Great Britain that show that with
children
99.995% of them survive having been
exposed to the virus do we really want
to change the lives of these children in
ways that are right now unimaginable by
exposing them to something we cannot
guarantee will help them Americans must
be allowed the freedom to choose the
path they will go down when it comes to
their own Medical Care how has big
Pharma taken over the hearts and minds
of politicians so that the science which
they say they are following that very
science says the opposite of what is
being passed out as Truth by the media
and government and when did Americans
allow themselves to become so fearful
that they would trust bureaucrats and
big Pharma over science and common sense
since when have doctors and other
healthcare workers lied to those they
claim to be serving by withholding the
complete information which which
includes the potential negative effects
on a medical treatment that can cause so
so many adverse effects how can anyone
make an informed decision about anything
these days if they only listen to what
is coming out of mainstream media and
our politicians and bureaucrats in DC
and unfortunately even our state and
local governments we began this session
by pledging allegiance to the flag and
in those words our liberty and justice
for all where is the Liberty if you're
going to force me to do something that I
do not want to do whether it is under
personal conscience religious religious
objections or health reasons and where
is the Justice in taking people out of
their livelihoods because some people
have chosen to live in fear of something
that is still 99% survivable for most
people that are exposed to it thank you
for hearing what I have to say today
thank
you uh
Miss Harding will be followed by Alan
Easton hi my name is R may I ask a
question um I'm sorry I didn't see you
repres no that's okay someone submitted
a
testimony that's very well written on
the right of conscious Amendment uh
articles four and five and there's no
name on
it was it Jr
huh J are okay thank you sorry for the
interruption please
proceed my name is Ronnie Harding um I
live in
wolfboro I am particularly interested in
this for many many reasons I am
currently a retired teacher I taught 36
years so I do feel like I'm quite
familiar with um children and young
people I also taught um as an Adjunct
professor at a college so quite a big
range and the fact that I'm considered
senior citizen myself so I feel like I
represent quite a few people and I'm
familiar with a lot of
germs I am here to strongly support the
amendment to HB 255 the prohibition of
mandatory covid-19
vaccines as many have stated and I
firmly believe from my own readings that
these vaccines are not a public health
or safety tool it's really kind of thing
about money in
control the CDC admits that the vaccines
cannot prevent infection or transmission
or provide IM immunity in fact New
Hampshire began having breakthrough
cases last January and Nationwide there
are now more covid cases than prior to
having vaccinations available covid-19
vaccinations really are only possibly
beneficial to certain individuals and
must be an individual option based
solely upon on a person's own unique
health conditions and needs as the
vaccine can only possibly decrease the
severity of symptoms which could reduce
the chance of hospitalization for some
at risk individuals in New Hampshire at
least 30% of current covid Hospital
cases are fully vaccinated people this
was in the union leader these vaccines
also have caused severe and dangerous
adverse reactions in many people of all
ages and so again the use of
vaccinations must be a very careful
decision between an individual and their
doctor it is not a decision to be
mandated by any employer or by
government or by any entity period for
those who've been attempting
to hard hats for workplace safety there
is no relevance hats can be used and
removed as desired a hat does not go
directly into a person's cells in their
body for those who try to compare covid
vaccines to some other prior vaccines
which has been mentioned today and some
have even tried to use the Jacob
Jacobson Supreme Court case as president
again there is absolutely no
relevance that case was about small poox
which had a which had a very dangerous
30% mortality rate and That vaccine
actually worked Co has a m 1.4%
approximate mortality rate and as we
said vaccines do not prevent infection
so mandating covid vaccines is a
unconstitutional over Brad farce it
unjustly forces a vaccine with no
long-term evidence of safety or
usefulness into people who do not in
fact need it and there may be no benefit
to them or to anyone around them
please ban vaccine
mandates thank you um Mr Easton will be
followed by Brittney
Mahoney good morning ladies and
gentlemen thank you for for this
opportunity I'm truly honored to be here
in this house um and I appreciate
everyone's time and I largely agree with
everything that has been said here today
but I'm strongly in favor of this
amendment whether or not this is the
place to challenge this amendment or
make this amendment to this
bill I don't know I'm a simple man I'm
not a lawyer I'm not a doctor I'm not a
scientist but I'm a father of five and a
grandfather of seven and you learn a few
things having children and
grandchildren one thing that I always
wanted to instill in my
children is always do the right
thing don't lie don't lie to me don't
cheat tell me the truth
truth don't hurt other
people I think those sentiments are
pretty accurate for
today when you consider this how many
people have heard the saying the love of
money is the root of all
evil follow the
money how much does it cost to get this
vaccine if I want to go to a doctor and
say I'd like to buy this vaccine how
much is
it it doesn't cost anything it's
free how can that be free if fiser just
got $19 billion in Q2 where'd that money
come from from a free
vaccine I'm curious
now I'd like to ask just your
acknowledgement how many people on this
board
received your vaccine you don't need to
be verbal if you just give me a little
head nod I'd appreciate that at your
choice I respect your opinions my mom
got the vaccine I will not get the
vaccine but that's where we're at right
now if you've ever had that conversation
walking in the neighborhood to get your
shot
yet I should not have to answer that
question should I is that an invasion of
my private
y let me explain just a little bit
further and I apologize I have no idea
how long this will go because I could
talk for
hours um the type of person I am is I do
not buy the first making model of
anything I do not buy the first car the
First new whatever the first computer
the first iPhone in fact I've never
never owned a new car imagine that
you ever hear that expression do you
don't buy a car on Mondays or
Fridays remember that
why
madna has never manufactured a vaccine
before
ever ever first time but we're going to
mandate that they everyone gets that
shot
H these are the type questions I have
with
people and frankly it's shocking to have
to go there and see the reaction my
company is currently
mandating that you get the
vaccine frankly I think it's against the
law I think it's an infringement on my
constitutional rights I think this body
needs to stand up in support of
this we don't need the the peer
pressure uh of what this is all about
something I believe is if it smells
fishy it's probably a
fish uh I'll Le I'll close with
this a good friend of
mine we jokingly say this now uh saying
his deceased mother
said I don't know where we are all going
and how do we get in this hand
basket thank you I would uh before we
have our next speaker I'd like to
welcome another fourth grade class to
the New Hampshire house welcome to our
public
[Applause]
Hearing in those cases Applause is PR
permitted uh I would like to call on uh
Miss Mahoney yes Miss Mahoney and she'll
be followed by Don
Crim
Mr chairman and committee thank you for
your time my name is Britney Mahoney and
I both a resident of Manchester New
Hampshire and an employer in New
Hampshire I support this amendment in
May of 2020 my family moved here from
Colorado to open our own business we
chose to go into business for ourselves
in park because we wanted the freedom to
live according to our values both in the
workplace and outside of the workplace
while researching places to look at we
fell in love with New Hampshire's
beautiful landscape incredible people
and support of small business I can
truly say that after the last year and a
half in New Hampshire I feel more at
home here than I have ever felt anywhere
in my life I absolutely love this
beautiful state covid-19 has of course
impacted Our Lives as business owners we
have had to buy large amounts of PPE we
have had to take social distancing into
account as we planned the layout of our
brick and mortar we have struggled to
find people willing to work early in
this year with a Perpetual cycle of no
show interviews in spite of a fair wage
and a great environment as we have
listen to the conversation around the
covid-19 vaccine this year we have
become increasingly concerned that there
will come a time when our government
dictates us to do things that fly in the
face of all that we have built our
opinions should not play a role in our
employees making their health care
decisions we simply do business at our
establishment we follow good hydr we
work hard to keep a clean facility folks
do not show up sick to work but beyond
that vaccines are simply not a part of
our conversation our employees are free
to make their choices with the input of
the people who actually are qualified to
give that input their personal doctors
that I believe is as it should be I am
an employer telling you that I do not
own my employees the desires or
convenience of an employer do not
overwrite the god-given rights of the
employees to control to have control
over their own medical decisions if the
current Administration succeeds in
pushing through their mandate we will be
forced to either not comply or go
against doing business how we see fit
according to our values we will incur
costs far beyond the cap our capability
in legal fees and probably fines as well
as a small business we are asking the
New Hampshire legislative body to
protect our right to live by our values
we are honest hardworking people our
employees are awesome and I don't want
to lose a single one of them we do not
have an Empire of endless cash to fund
or to fight Federal overreach nor do we
have the funds to provide testing for
our employees and we refuse to
discriminate against unvaccinated
employees when science shows that both
vaccinated and unvaccinated individuals
can contract and transmit viruses such
as covid-19 if our employees are unwell
we ask them to stay home in addition we
ask that the legislation protect
employees throughout the state who have
individual health heare needs and
concerns and should have the freedom to
make their choice without fear of
recourse from their employers I would
ask that this legislative body vote
through this amendment and this bill to
protect New Hampshire from federal
overreach thank you for time thank you
um next will be Don Crim to be followed
by Hillary
rondi hi my name is Don Crim and from
Bedford my infant son and I were vaccine
injured in
2007 I'm sure all of you in this room
have encountered a situation where a
doctor nurse health care professional
wanted to administer a vaccine did they
tell you that they can cause diabetes
entis um I could go on and on and on the
problem is what's going on is Criminal
these doctors are not practicing
informed consent if you want to know EX
exactly what vaccines can do I strongly
urge you to jump on your computer and
Google vaccine package insert there you
will see every side effect associated
with every vaccine out there these covid
injections are not vaccines but what the
science is showing is scary did you know
that they can cause diabetes pancreatic
damage um I actually
have four uncles three aunts two cousins
and two friends who have been seriously
injured in fact my uncle before his
death succumbed to numerous clots
throughout his body his leg was cut
off I've had four people that I know
personally that had heart damage they
had to have emergency
surgery so let's talk about the risk of
transmission start looking at a
Chickenpox vaccine did you know that
you're contagious for 6 weeks did your
doctor tell you that how about a
shingles vaccine nasal flu vaccine
rotavirus vaccine Vine those who get the
covid injection are a transmission risk
and that's what fiser has said in their
paperwork so I ask you to support this
bill this amendment and protect the
citizens of this state because the
healthcare workers are not thank
you thank you uh next is uh M Remi to be
followed by Carolyn
hu good morning I think it's still
morning um thank you for allowing me to
speak today I had a prepared statement
but hearing how well everyone has done
presenting the scientific data I think
I'll kind of go off course a little bit
um I do live in Hollis New Hampshire
I've lived up here about two years I'm a
physical therapist I work at one of the
major Community Hospitals down south
before that I worked in Boston for about
15 years at uh some of the big hospitals
down there I love New Hampshire we moved
up here two years ago when we had our
second daughter to enjoy the freedoms of
New Hampshire and and I think through
this whole process I feel like the
healthcare workers that are on the front
lines have kind of been left behind we
are the ones in the beginning that went
to work every single day not knowing if
I was going to bring this home to my
family we held people's hands when they
couldn't see their family members we're
in the ICU we're helping these patients
to get better we had to wear the same
n95 masks for weeks on end because we
didn't have enough people PPE we had to
take classes on how to use paper gowns
and put them on and take them off so
that the next person coming in after me
could use the same
PPE we have come to work every day and
have asked for nothing from everyone
except that we be allowed to make our
own decisions right now in the hospitals
we have covid patients more distressing
are the patients that are coming in with
blood clots myoc citis these are things
I have never seen in the 15 years that
I've worked in Boston I work at a small
Hospital in New Hampshire i' never
thought in a million years I'd see a
20-year-old coming in with
myocarditis he has to live with this for
the rest of his life I have a family to
support what happens if I take the
vaccine and now I'm sick and I can't
work I feel like with all these mandates
I know Governor sonunu would uh pass
something a couple of months ago it
applied to everyone except healthcare
workers what happens when we get sick
who's going to take care of you right
now we have a huge shortage of Staff we
can't afford to lose one person we can't
lose afford to lose a
housekeeper our kitchen staff a nurse a
doctor a physical therapist we can't
afford to lose anyone if you go to an
emergency room right now you know how
long you're going to have to wait almost
two days to get a bed bed in the
hospital 2 days and this isn't because
of Co this is because people are being
forced out of their jobs I never thought
in a million years that I'd have to
worry about having a job in healthcare
there's shortages everywhere but because
I'm not willing to take a vaccine where
I've seen the consequences of I'm told
that I'm not good enough to work so
please please support this bill the time
has run out we can't wait until January
these vaccine mandates are happening now
so please help us to be able to support
our families and to be able to take care
of everybody when they're sick in the
hospital thank
you thank you uh next is uh Carolyn
Stewart to be followed by uh Jim Stewart
and that's three minutes each okay thank
you committee for letting us be here
today I hope you can hear me I attend to
Mum I'm sorry uh I'm a I'm my my name is
Carolyn Stewart I'm a physical therapist
that lives in Rochester New Hampshire uh
I am here to support this amendment and
I um Wanted ditto what my colleague the
other physical therapist just said I'm
sorry I forgot your name sweetie um I
work for the Cornerstone visiting nurses
in Rochester an awesome company I love
them I wanted to be there till I was
retired but the main mandate that
Governor Mills has said all healthare
workers who aren't vaccinated by October
29th you must you you will have to leave
your job well my company is a New
Hampshire company but it Services main
patients and it needs to because the
need is there we need home care in main
just like we do in New Hampshire I know
you can't fix the main mandate but I had
to leave my job October 29th I love that
job I've been working for 31
years 31 years and I saw covid patients
last year and I was I signed up for the
covid committee that's not a pat on my
back but it was needed people were
afraid to go to covid patients so we
signed up and we went and I said to my
boss if I Got That vaccine that doesn't
work it doesn't work doctor it doesn't
look if I took that vaccine and I was
paralyzed or got convulsions like people
online are showing us if you'll watch
that who's going to pay for me and my
boss said God bless her she said Carolyn
we you can't pay for that because it's
an experimental drug the health
insurance company will not pay for any
vaccine damage nine because it's an
experimental drug Carolyn if you take
that drug that's your problem if you get
a bad reaction I couldn't believe that
life insurance we won't cover your death
if you die from the vaccine well wait a
minute we were told you're not getting
die you're not dying from the vaccine
well the health and the life insurance
companies they're on it they know
they're not paying for anybody who dies
for for that my P my friend Helen a
nurse at my company she's in the
Intensive Care Unit right now why
because she was refused icin and hydroxy
chlorin she's on a ventilator right now
and for people that say iconist for
horses that is ignorance that's complete
ignorance no doctor can say that today
Dr Peter mcalla well-renowned
cardiologist in this country and vaccine
specialist says people people are dying
from myocarditis they should be given
preventative treatment at the home
before no one should be going to the
hospital nobody in this day and age if
you're letting your patients go to the
hospital's doctors shame on
you Dr McCulla says you've got this
protocol Frontline doctors of America
has a wonderful protocol you can use
that and to not use that right now is
Criminal thank you thank
you
please I don't want to have to say it
again Mr Stewart followed by uh Mr
Minard of
Bo thank you I think Mr chairman uh
first of all I'm very proud of my wife
um my name is James Stewart I'm from
Rochester New Hampshire I'm a
horticulturist U and even though I'm
like a plant scientist I've done more
studying on this issue in the last year
year and a half than I have on my own
profession the big thing that I'm seeing
out there is a lack of
transparency there's not much truth
floating around out there you have to
dig for it you can find it but you got
to dig there's a lot of deception out
there a lot of that's coming from high
places this amendment gives me a rare
moment of pride pride in New Hampshire
and that we're trying potentially can do
the right thing
here
um Governor suu either is obusca or
lying when he says nobody's losing their
job in New Hampshire I heard him
directly say that over and
over what I am
Mo case in point my wife lost her job um
I'm also an employer and I would never
do that to my patients my uh my uh
employees what I'd like to mostly say is
that I'm a father and I'm a grandfather
this is about my
kids I want to protect them from covid
but I also want to protect them from the
wise and the big lie is that there's no
treatment for Co there is all you have
to do is look an earlier uh speaker
spoke about India you can find that
anybody here can look that up and find
out what happened in India there there
states in India just like in the United
States there's States two of them chose
to not use hycan protocol both
prophylactically and
therapeutically guess what happened yeah
just like in the United States the the
rate of cases continue in the other
states that chose to use the icin
protocol 19 just fell right off the
table the incidents fell right off the
table pretty much disappeared it's
amazing why do some of us not know that
do you know all about this why do we not
know that it's there to see it's hidden
from us by the CDC by The Who by fouchi
by the administration that's supposedly
in power right
now what I'm here to ask you to do
members is to be strong I'm asking you
to
be if there's any time that you should
get excited yes and be intense yes what
are you waiting for let's do it now
we're at a a moment in history and we
will look back on this moment like
someone earlier said we'll go like did
you your kids might say to you Grandpa
daddy mommy Grammy did you stand up for
us did you stand kids aren't at risk
here they're at risk of the supposed
vaccine it's not a vaccine it's not an
immunization does not immunize you uh M
the last thing I want to say is Jesus
the Christ said if anyone offends one of
these my little ones it would be better
for him to be to have a millstone hung
around his neck and cast into the depths
of the sea I'd be considering that if
you
were folks I want to each of you stand
up be strong don't worry about anybody s
than you sir be strong be strong thank
you um Mr Mard followed by uh Mr Brady
Owens thank you Mr chairman I'm Rick
Menard I'm the executive director of
building community in New Hampshire
we're a very small nonprofit
organization working in Manchester
Nashua and Conquer primarily with
refugees who've come here uh and and we
help with their post resettlement
helping them create lives get jobs uh
and and keep their families healthy I
require vaccinations of my employees and
I urge you to oppose this
legislation my employees have to work uh
come in close contact with all kinds of
people I want them to be there I want
them to be there to respond to people in
need regardless of what and where they
are and the vaccines do help them help
protect them from infection it's not a
cure it's not a guarantee but it's the
best we can do I want my employees to be
safe and most of all I want to make sure
that they're
not uh transmitting the disease to
others the refugee Community are are
particularly vulnerable they have to
carpool they have to work in enclosed
areas and they suffered enormously
during the first waves of covid most of
s vaccination not
all but most have because they see they
have seen it in their
families uh and as an employer I can't
afford to have an employee of a very
small company I can't afford to have an
employee out and I would not appreciate
it at all if the state told me I
couldn't require
vaccinations so please oppose this Bill
thank you very
much thank you um Mr Owens followed by
Teresa Lawrence and just a reminder that
um if you could confine your remarks to
the bill itself that would be helpful we
have a lot of people who would like to
uh talk still at this
point uh hello my name is Brady Owens uh
I'm here to support this legislature
today I'm a software developer um and I
live and work in nashan New Hampshire
I am a Sole Provider for my family my
wife is on medical disability my company
has issued a vaccine mandate as of 21
days ago in a deadline of December 8th
the company's official headquarters are
here in New Hampshire in nsha but with
people spread all across the globe with
over 600 employees in
India a huge majority of the company is
even fully remote one of only those in
the US are being subjected to this
mandate I have submitted my exemption
but I have no indication whether it
would be
approved if it does not get approved and
I do not then I do not know what will
happen then the Mandate comes with a
threat of termination I am prepared for
the worst than hoping for the best I am
looking at the 8 December deadline as
when I will lose my
job I would be very judicial about the
future
companies to make sure that they are
based in states that protect freedoms of
their working citizens that power their
economy so today I'm here to support
this
legislature earlier this year when the
bills were being discussed I I can't
remember the exact one maybe it was SB
155 it was said oh this will not happen
here they will not force injections well
it now it has happened here let us not
continue to assume something will not
happen if 2020 and 2021 has taught us
nothing it is that it is that it that
that nothing nothing is impossible even
with the most far-fetched ideas you can
dream of Supreme Court ruled in
Washington versus Harper in 1990 that
the forcible injection of medication
into a non-consenting person's body
represents a substantial interference
with person's Liberty that ruling was
not even based on religion it was solely
on someone's refusal not to receive a
medication let us stand for the citizens
of New Hampshire and block this gross
overreach by the federal government and
private businesses thank you for your
time thank you um M Lawrence to be
followed by Mr Nick
Ryder um is Teresa Lawrence here um
evidently uh she has left is Mr Nick
Ryder
here
in about a month it will be 20 years
since Richard Reed tried to make a shoe
into a bomb on an airplane so due to
terrorism all passengers are required to
remove shoes to go on board an
airplane that rule may not make sense
anymore some may say it's outdated but
it's just
shoes since March of 2020 I have watched
in horror as governments around this
country and the world have used a single
magic word emergency to bypass all
legislative processes and enact whatever
new societal rules they would like
saying it's all due to covid your
restaurant can only serve half capacity
your restaurant can only serve 25%
capacity your restaurant must close it's
just for 15 days it's just remote
learning it's just until the end of the
school year it's just a curfew it's just
until the end of summer it's it's just
one Thanksgiving to spend alone it's
just one holiday
season during this I and hundreds of
thousands of other New Hampshire
employees kept going to work we did our
best to make sure Society didn't
completely fall apart after all we were
told we were
essential that is until of course last
month when we were told to comply with
yet another new cital rule or lose our
places in society lose our essential
jobs it's just a
vaccine but enough is enough we're out
of time this is the line because once
power is taken be it your shoes be it
your medical decisions or be it any
incremental step in between once it is
taken it is never given back if we don't
speak up now then when what's
next thank
you
Mr
Micah Herz Hoots to be followed by
Carolyn Maloney I think the name is in
from
amst good morning my name is Micah
housez I live in eping New Hampshire I'm
a father of three and a manager at a
local engineering firm I have an
electrical engineering degree and a
master's in Business Administration I
strongly support this amendment to HB
255 to prevent vaccine mandates by New
Hampshire employers due to the federal
administrative State issuing OSHA rules
and federal contracts to circumvent the
legislative process the protection of
New Hampshire workers rights now Falls
to you the New Hampshire legislature the
employee employer relationship is an
asymmetrical power structure the
employer maintains ownership ship of the
property plant and customer
relationships if you fail to pass this
amendment you're contributing to a new
extreme in conflict between New
Hampshire workers and employers that is
against the spirit of cooperation and
Harmony that should exist at a good
company in my 15 years of working in a
pro professional capacity I've never
been asked by my employer for private
medical information now many employers
make a covid-19 vaccine a condition of
employment or require them to reveal
their private religious belief
employers are not doing this of their
own free will they're doing it under
duress and threat of punishment by the
federal government the legislature
should act quickly to make sure New
Hampshire employers and employees do not
suffer this undue burden if you do
nothing you are providing implied
consent to this new power structure do
you want your children to live in a
world where their compliance with
medical advice is coerced under threat
of job loss this is a new and troubling
aspect to Society based on fear I
encourage everyone to make yourself
aware of a critical scientific
experiment and how it relates to the
employer and employee relationship these
experiments are commonly referred to as
the mgrm experiments in the experiment
there are three persons the authority
figure a scientist an accomplice who
poses an experiment as an experiment
subject and a third person who is
unaware of the experiment but is placed
in the role of a teacher the scientist
frames the experiment as a memory test
and the accomplice must remember a
series of words that get more and more
challenging if a memorizer makes a
mistake the scientist requires the
teacher to administer an electrical
shock of increasing magnitude the
accomplice pretends to receive the
electric shock when the unknowing
teacher protests that it is not right
the scientist and authority figure
states only the experiment requires that
you continue a significant proportion of
people in the teacher role were willing
to administer what they thought were
pain ful electrical shocks to the
accomplished as a manager I feel like a
forced participant in this social
experiment to see what my willingness to
administer these mandatory requirements
will be if I protest that myself or my
employees do not want this vaccine I am
told the experiment requires that you
continue I want out of this social
experiment and I need this legislature
to pass the amendment to HB 255 to
protect the rights of my employees and
myself please take a stand for workers
rights by passing this
amendment uh is there Carolyn Maloney
thank you and you'll be followed by uh
Steve an good morning uh or afternoon
honorable representative uh for the
record Carolyn McKinny Amherst New
Hampshire and um I am a mother of five
and a an employer here in New Hampshire
as well
um I have written testimony that I'm
going to submit by email um and I'm
going to go go over only part of this in
the interest of time um I'm here to urge
you to support a ban on vaccine mandates
and also to encourage you and your
colleagues to do everything within their
power to protect the health and the PE
of the people of New Hampshire
especially our
children with how the propaganda has
touted these injections you would think
there's that they're nothing short of
miraculous but the most telling data all
cause mortality illuminates the truth in
the countries with the best most
reliable data it is clear all cause
mortality rates have increased after
these Mass covid-19 vaccination
campaigns since mid-February Israel saw
a continued and sustained increase in
all cause mortality attributed in the
news media to quote a murky wave of
heart attacks beginning in July all
cause mortality in the UK and Scotland
began to jump dramatically higher than
expected baselines and has remained
elevated with a notable increase in
heart failure and other cardiac
disorders in September Germany reported
deaths at 10% higher than the expected
figure and noted that a similar increase
appeared to occur across Europe around
the same time demographers had expected
to see a dip in in mortality in 2021
because covid pulled deaths from a
future year so imagine how much excess
death there has been not only to reach
the Baseline mortality numbers but to
exceed it by 10% or
more um the fizer's own six-month
clinical trial as well as madera's trial
results released in September confirmed
no all cause mortality benefit from
vaccination big Pharma has never proven
that their product reduces mortality and
we need to stop pretending that they
have this myopic vaccine focus is public
health Madness and it will soon be
affecting our children it is absolutely
immoral that a pharmaceutical company
was allow allowed to undertake covid
vaccine trials among children let alone
get their products authorized for use
and pedal by government at all levels
children are at effectively zero risk
from covid making it impossible to
reduce their risk the this virtually
untested product being injected into New
Hampshire children carries only risk no
reward and our governor and public
health officials keep pushing it anyway
it must be stopped I would also like to
enter to the record along with my
testimony an article titled moreon
original antigenic sin and the Folly of
our Universal vaccination campaign the
author points out that there's a reason
to suspect that the vaccines may be
compromising immunity to SARS Cove 2 via
original anti antigenic sin this
well-observed limitation of human
Immunology is most basically described
as an imprint established by the
original viral infection that governs
the antibody response
thereafter um um I urge you to to read
this article it's very telling about how
these uh vaccines are uh creating a
perfect storm of improper immunity for
uh generations to come and thank you
thank you for your time thank you um Mr
Anin to be followed by lean Romano of
Lichfield thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon uh to you and to members of
the committee um I'm Steve anen I'm the
president of the New Hampshire hospital
hital Association I'm here representing
all 26 of our state's Community
Hospitals as well as all of our
specialty hospitals I'd ask that my full
statement be made a part of the record
and I'll seek to make a few key points
here today the New Hampshire Hospital
Association is opposed to the non-gain
amendment under consideration it would
undermine the ability of hospitals to
determine the appropriate evidence-based
policies and protocols to ensure the
safety of their vulnerable patients
their staff and the communities that
they serve New Hampshire's hospitals
employ over 41,000 individuals the
doctors nurses therapists Environmental
Services security Food Services support
staff and so many others who have been
on the front lines of the covid-19
pandemic for over the last year and a
half the overwhelming number of our
employees support the call for covid-19
vaccine requirements that hospitals
announced back in August because they
know it as the most effective means to
keep their patients colleagues and
communities safe compelling
organizations that choose to require
covid-19 vaccinations for their
employees to permit anyone who who
objects to the VAC on the grounds of
personal conscious or prior recovery
from covid-19 would render any vaccine
requirement moot putting patients and
staff at greater risk in a study of over
7,000 adults hospitalized with covid-19
unvaccinated patients with prior
covid-19 infection were five times more
likely to have covid-19 than patients
fully vaccinated against covid-19 and no
prior infection hospitals already allow
for employees to seek exemptions from
the requirement for medical or religious
reasons before covid-19 vaccines were
widely available to those in hospitals
and other health care settings it was
not uncommon for hospitals to report
that they had dozens upon dozens of
Staff who were forced out of work uh to
quarantine or isolate due to covid-19
exposure or infection when more and more
of our staff had become fully vaccinated
those numbers dropped dramatically given
the more infectious nature of the Del
Delta variant those of our staff Who
Remain unvaccinated are at far greater
risk of infection than those who were
fully vaccinated a study published in
September shows that people who are not
fully vaccinated or at a fivefold higher
risk of infection from covid-19 10-fold
higher risk of hospitalization from
covid-19 and 11-fold higher risk of
dying from covid-19 compared to people
who were fully vaccinated for all of
these reasons and More Mr chairman we
strongly uh oppose this non gerain
Amendment and urge the full committee to
find it an expedient to legislate thank
you for the opportunity to share our
views thank
you Miss Romano to be followed by I
believe it's Noel Taka or taken of marac
I wasn't sure that I was gonna speak but
I'm gonna not read my email that I
submitted from lean Romano of Lichfield
but it this is the most important thing
that I'm going to do in my lifetime for
my children this is ridiculous this is
not a vaccine it is an experimental drug
that is being forced upon the people and
you are our voice you must must vote
this you must this is is so important to
us I know we're here talking about um
everybody's work I can't believe that
the heroes of yesterday are now losing
their jobs are you kidding me you people
have got the voice you've got to vote
you've got to make sure that this passes
and why now because if it isn't passed
somebody's going to be injected and
could be hurt you can't wait till
January when everybody has to be
injected I will not get vaccinated and I
swear I will will fight tooth and nail
to keep this away from students I I will
not vaccinate my children and I will
pull them out of school if I have to and
I do not want to my child is a an
athlete she loves going to school I love
my community I love the teachers and it
is just wrong to actually mandate this
for everyone I am also a small business
owner and I will never mandate this for
my employees thank you all for for being
here I really appreciate if you would
just vote this in this is important and
don't wait and I don't want to revisit
this in January get it done thank you um
is
there Noel taka or taken from
marac evidently not um how about Cheryl
Melville from
Belmont hi my name is Sher Melville and
I'm from Bel New Hampshire and I am
definitely for this amendment I love
this state it's a Live Free or Die state
that means a lot to me I've lived here
since I was five we came from
taxachusetts and we never looked
back I love the fact that we don't even
mandate people to wear helmets when they
ride a motorcycle do I think that's
smart no but that's what we pride
ourselves on we pride ourselves on the
fact that we're New Hampshire we're the
Live Free or Die State we either believe
that motto or we don't and if we don't
maybe we should give it to Rona Santos
in Florida
because I'm appalled that we even have
to wonder about this the fact that
that's how you open the door to tyranny
you just open it a little bit and then
it comes in what's next are we going to
have lockdowns for the unvaccinated are
we going to have them identified by some
way are we going to have police that are
going to ask them if they have their
card in the street are we going to
arrest a little grandmother as a
nine-year-olds that didn't get
vaccinated and not let them go to school
or Girl Scout or anything else El they
want to
do we need to really wake up and we need
to know that this is not about Co it's
unfortunately something a little more
nefarious than that which I don't even
want to look at because I want to think
that most of the citizens are Law
Abiding and I have a question for the
doctors who are testifying if they're so
sure about this why don't they give the
vaccination in their offices why do you
have to go to the SLE Gate Mall or CVS
or hand fors to get it if they're
backing that up so much then they should
be putting there money with them all
this thank you thank you is there Nancy
Palmer of amorist
here not seeing her uh Julie Smith of
Nashua and she she'll be followed by uh
Nicole
Susa good afternoon committee me
Members Julie Smith from
Nash I'm unemployed and and I at first
didn't plan to take valuable microphone
time away from people who have more
powerful messages to share but I decided
that it's important to use my blessing
of available time that people still
employed might not have as a late Martin
NE Maller said simplified in my own
words first they came for this group and
then later that group because I did not
speak up for them there was no one left
to speak up when they came from me I've
been speaking up for the employed in
direct rest since the Dartmouth
Hitchcock employees first came under
Assault 3 months ago for somewhat
unrelated reasons I had to take early
retirement after 20 years at a large
company and part of that severance
package was outplacement service which I
quickly took advantage of the consultant
assigned to me was excellent and I gave
her a five-star review she showed me the
proper way to design a resume by 20121
standards and make a public exit
statement Without Anger or self-pity use
LinkedIn and monster the dos and don'ts
of today's networking and make a 302
commercial also know as an elevator
stage when appropriate two years ago at
this time I would have thought that such
preparation was cutting edge but it's
not modern enough today I regret being
too shy throughout the job search
coaching process to address the 800
pound gorilla in the room at that time
mask
policies while professionals are
supposed to leave their personal
opinions at home and assist their
clients with unbiased professionalism
one can never be sure that the principle
is adhered to so I chose to stay quiet
what would Emily post say about modern
job search etiquette do you ask about it
at the end of the first interview or
another time I'd like to know then
there's the even more invasive human
rights issue vaccine status issues which
I hadn't even thought of at the time of
my consultation last spring
what I just said about the mass policies
on steroids rinse lather repeat there is
currently much chatter about the
workforce shortage since I am not 59 and
a half it will be necessary to work
again possibly doing the same thing or
something else what I wind up doing
depends not on what happens in
Washington because New Hampshire has no
representation there but what happens in
conquer I never miss an opportunity to
tell a man he's wrong and Sherman
Packard is no exception he accused the
audience of barking up the wrong tree on
September 14th and he couldn't be more
wrong in fact I would venture to get
that almost nobody in that audience
voted for any of the four members of the
DC swamp that are supposed to be
representing the interest of granite
Staters therefore this problem must be
solved here in this building and as soon
as possible right now my resume lists
some of my most recent job my most
recent job being 20 years of service
with a departure on good terms I don't
want to to corrupt that potentially
sporadic employment I do not want to
corrupt that with potentially sporadic
employment that might have less than
noble separation terms and having a good
work ethic being able-bodied I know I
would be a good addition to a workplace
that is right for me and the employer
but I do not want that employer to turn
on me with new covid edicts or violation
of my hipop
privacy if it they can do it to people
who are senior employees it stands to
reason they'll do it to a new
many elected officials in a variety of
places including my favorite Governor
Christy gome have made the l a fair
talking
points I firmly believe that government
should be small and lean I also believe
in h Herbert Hoover's rugged
individualism however with so many
people here and elsewhere crying out for
relief from medical tyranny it's time
for elected officials to do something
please vote for this thank you thank you
uh Julie Smith followed by Nicole soua
of
Amherst um I'm Nicole Souza from Amherst
oh
okay okay um I could spend the next
three minutes talking about facts data
and science like the study that found
that there's no transmission difference
between vax and unvax households or the
UK on data that shows a higher infection
rate in PE in vaccinated individuals
over 30 than in the unvaccinated ated
individuals or that all cause mortality
is higher in all of the highly vaxed
countries in this world than it was last
year or that the highly vaxed countries
of Israel gubar and Iceland are in the
top have all reached the top three in
the world infection
rates but like all authoritarians in
history facts data and science do not
not
matter and they will manufacture their
own science like the CDC who decided to
have its own peer- reviewed study in its
own journal that didn't make the data
available to Independent sciences that
came with a conclusion while they had a
magically adjusted number that no one
that they were not transparent about
that concluded something different than
the over 100 studies on natural immunity
does that sound like science to
you um authoritarians in the past they
censor not debate they conceal they are
not transparent and they Co while they
say it's for your
safety I have to ask you to have courage
today show the world that Liberty cannot
be destroyed
under the guise of
safety that America is the land of the
free and the home of the
[Music]
brave as we reflect on history people
that stand up for human rights and
against the tyrants were villains in
their presence but they are heroes in
our
history I'm not asking you to give your
lives for Freedom like thousands of
others have done in the past I'm asking
you today to have courage to push
legislation to protect our freedoms and
our basic human rights of freedom of
movement freedom of bodily Integrity be
the light in the darkness be brave stand
up and fight with your words and your
pens so our children do not have to lay
down their lives
you have the power to change the tide of
the
[Applause]
world do what you know is right in your
hearts and your
gut be on the right side of History
against tyranny segregation
discrimination protect vaccination
status like race sex and religion is in
this country as our Founders said laws
should protect our god-given human
rights thank you start start today by
voting for the amendment on HB 225 thank
you thank you very much representative
cordelli uh what we're going to do at
this point in time because we're nearing
into the lunch break I need to meet with
all committee members in the Senate
chambers here behind the wall your
opportunity to go on the other side of
the wall um we will be coming back in
about 10
minutes uh to continue the hearings it's
an opportunity for all of you that have
children or all those that need to stand
up and stretch a little bit I know as a
educator that that's necessary that we
have that opportunity but please we'll
be starting this taking a break for 10
minutes only coming right back and
continuing these hearings uh meet all
committee members in this in the Senate
chamber thank
you
you got to go to the
bathroom
he'll be followed by Howen Chase of
epson thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Dave
juv I'm a senior vice president for
public policy with the business and
industry Association I'm also currently
serving as interim president for that
Association
the Bia serves as New Hampshire
Statewide Chamber of Commerce we have
over 400 employer members with over
990,000 employees throughout the state
we have members of all sizes from the
state's largest companies down to sole
uh owner proprietor uh employers and
entrepreneurs I'm here today to speak in
opposition to this amendment and I'd
like to briefly explain why the uh Prime
sponsor in his uh comments introducing
the amendment said he was responding to
what he viewed as Federal overreach
trampling on employer rights and I
understand that point of view and we
have some members who agree with that
point of view his response however was
to create a uh State overreach trampling
on employer rights by again telling
employers this time what they are
prohibited from doing not what they must
do I I would ask all of you to remember
that there are a lot of employers in
this state who are in a very difficult
position right now and it will be made
even more difficult if this proposal
passes the house and the Senate and is
signed into law right now the law of the
land is employers of a 100 employees or
more or those who are uh health care
providers who receive Medicaid and
Medicare dollars or those who have
Federal contracts
are under a mandate to uh have their
employers vaccinated or if they opt out
uh to have them tested once a week to
show that they are covid free they don't
have the ability to just ignore that
Federal mandate if this proposal passes
and becomes law I'm hoping each of you
will go to the Employers in your
districts who are under that Federal
mandate and ask them are you intending
to comply with the federal law or are
you intending to comply with the state
law because you won't be able to do both
and then ask him if that's creating a
difficult position for them to be in uh
that concludes my remarks I'd be happy
to answer any
questions now is it
on how do I turn it
on
is it on now okay good thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr sh for taking my
question my question is um having to do
with health insurance premiums and I'm
not sure if you're the right person to
ask but it is a question that I've been
concerned about um
if employees are not
vaccinated will health insurance
premiums likely rise as a result of the
risk of high levels of of covid
infection yeah thank you for the
question I'm not the right person to ask
that we do have uh some health insurers
within our membership but I haven't
queried them on that issue I'd be happy
to do so but I don't know the answer to
it nor can I say I'm a real expert on on
health insurance and cost associated
with
it thank
you thank you thank you
uh Mr Chase and followed
by I'm
sorry
Jonathan
pay Mr Chase goad hello my name is
Howard Chase I'm a registered nurse I
have been for 47 years I practiced two
years in conquer in 45 years at Andrew
gagen Valley Hospital in burland New
Hampshire I now have an address of epson
New Hampshire what I'm talking about is
how do we know what's going to happen to
people who are vaccinated we haven't had
enough time so we need autopsies in the
United States the autopsies are
disallowed because they don't want us to
know what is happening to people who
have been vaccinated and have died what
is happen happening we can get
information from Canada any other uh
place in the world except the United
States so what is happening is initially
they thought that little injection which
creates this protein Spike was going to
stay in your arm it doesn't it goes
everywhere it goes to your brain it goes
to your ovaries it goes to every single
organ in your body so what how is this
how does this show up well it shows up
one of the most obvious is we talked
about um myocarditis when people get
myocarditis that's that protein Spike
that has landed in your heart it has
caused this myocarditis it also goes to
the brain they talk about brain fog
brain fog well um yeah they say it's
from covid well people who have not have
covid but have had the shot get brain
fog do you want your five six-year-old
child to have this little protein Spike
stuck in their brain they have enough
trouble keeping track of what's going on
uh they don't need an additional problem
we also have seen and it's been to the
point where the inh is NIH is finally
doing a study many women are having
their period
stop shortly after they get the
vaccine so
what does that mean it means their
ovaries have stopped producing eggs they
are sterilized does this last forever we
don't know but do you want to put this
protein spike in a six-year-old child
you shouldn't be putting this protein
spike in anybody who is in childbearing
age um there's Canadian studies which
I've sent i s an email to your group and
so
that is a link to all of this particular
information um
so those are the three important things
everybody else has talked about it but
in any case it can also affect males but
nobody really knows I mean it's really
hard for a male to say well my period
hasn't stopped well of course you don't
have one so in any case we can't be
giving this vaccine to anyone of
childbearing a age because we know it is
affecting them we also know that it's
affecting the ability to think and
process thank you very much thank you
now
um now we have uh does it say pain is a
Jonathan pay or Jonathan Paul does thisn
stain from London just I'd like to just
make a comment please that please keep
your comments based on the Mandate not
whether or not the vaccine works or not
this is the the B man the bill is on the
Mandate so why shouldn't why should yeah
so keep it to the Mandate not go on how
the vaccine works or doesn't work thank
you
no just to look at the nature of the
amendment which we addressing the ACT is
directly associated with the
of vaccine as a requirement for work has
nothing really to do we've had other
committees other than this education
committee dealing with the efficacy of
the vaccine mandate there are two
separate issues here and due to the
number of cards we have we'd like to
have you please address the the uh
analysis and how the act that we're
dealing with was worded that dealing
with the
prohibition of of the
vaccine as representative mowman just
mentioned thank you uh it's Paul is it
Jonathan Paul London der uh uh yes
sorry it's not your fault my writing's
back johnan Paul from London yes
followed by Caitlyn stamp from
marac
um I'm
uh dad grandfather um pastor of little
church in Kingston grew up in
Londoner um representing my friends
people I worship with who've uh had
their jobs jeopardized or taken
away because of the uh because of the
Mandate just uh believe that God has not
given us a spirit of fear but of power
and of love and of a sound mind and if
we just take a world view of what your
expecting us to talk about today then uh
I think we can come up with a question
and revelation of who can make war with
the
Beast um I'd just like to ask for us to
think about the obvious conclusion where
um these two schools of thought would
lead if we support this amendment then
it's a direction of less government it's
a less intervention it's less override
it's more trusting people to do what's
right which our government was laid out
to to do that but the obvious conclusion
the other direction is a death
sentence like you to think about that if
you would that the wish of these people
who we oppose who absolutely didn't show
up today because they're so sure of
things how they might turn out it seems
like would like everyone to mandate
they'd like everyone to mandate the idea
that you don't have employment if you
won't take a vaccine and the convictions
aren't going to change
and so the obvious conclusion is a death
sentence that you'll not be able to work
you're not going to be able to make
anything but the people who are making
the calls have made it impossible to
live through a hospital visit if you've
got things going if you are into the
hospital and you can breathe they send
you home with no Intermediate
Care and when you finally do get to the
hospital and can't breathe the protocol
is such and the the the inclinations the
uh the money that's going to be invested
in that hospital compromises the doctors
the leadership so that it's an advantage
to let those people
die and so if they don't care if the our
opponents don't care if you die in the
hospital and they go with that and I
know Hitler said it was easy to um get
the doctors to follow him until to get
the whole medical field he was
astonished at how simple it was rise and
fall of the third
rake then how can we expect that our
opposition would care if you have a job
or if you have the death sentence and if
that's their sentiment I just think that
um you've been in incredibly patient
with our exuberance today to listen to
each other um it's encouraging to hear
on the articulate um statements from
this side and then to think of Iber mton
and how available it is and um on good
terms that what's so that the feed sore
is absolutely not one what different
from what is sold to the
pharmacy and um it's too bad that we're
up against people who don't care about
the death sentence thank you is the a
Caitlyn
stamp followed by David
Maru good
afternoon um Kaitlyn stamp from marac
New Hampshire and I'm here in support of
the amendment um my story is about my
father he's 54 years old and he worked
as a biochemist for the last 20 years
and was recently told by his employer
that he needed to get vaccinated or he
would lose his job and in turn his
pension um some background about my dad
he's on been on medication for the
better part of a decade because he's at
high risk of blood clots and he also had
open heart surgery in May of this year
now his employer is telling him that he
needs a vaccine which causes high risk
of blood clots and um heart inflammation
two areas where he is at high risk
already or he will lose his whole
livelihood in
retirement um um they also tried to
force him to sign a form that would say
that he um this decision was completely
voluntary and of his own free will when
clearly that is not the case um I think
this shows that employers know what
they're doing is wrong and they're
trying to give themselves legal cover
while they force this un unethical
choice on us he did not sign the form
but he did get vaccinated in order to
keep his job um and his pension and
while thankfully he hasn't had any
issues with his heart or blood clots uh
he has had issues with um joint pain uh
since a week after his uh injection um
and he is now forced to go to the job
that made him do this to himself in pain
forcing people to choose between their
personal health and their livelihood is
the most unconstitutional thing I have
witnessed on my short time on this Earth
and I fear for the day that my father's
employer forces him to make this
decision again because they will require
boosters if we do not put a stop to this
right
now and while joint pain may be his only
side effect right now the next time he
may not be so lucky and I worry every
day that I could wake up without my
father because of this unconstitutional
and immoral mandate while you might be
tempted to let the Mandate play out in
the court system I do not and I cannot
trust that outcome alone there are
several state laws you can pass such as
the one we are here in support of today
that can provide immediate and
desperately needed protection for the
citizens in New Hampshire please do not
Kick the Can down the road do not pass
the buck this issue is too import and
too urgent for the New Hampshire
legislature not to act on thank you
thank
you David Laro followed by Henry
voo David Laro
Alexandria innocent till proven guilty
Words which seem like a Bedrock American
principal what other words sound like
Bedrock American
principles under
God all men are created equal we fix the
inequities we find in our system when
they come up we have a masking
section should non- maskers be in the
back of the bus last time I spoke before
220 committee I spoke about numbers the
actual statistics of numbers of data in
New Hampshire today I'm going to speak
to something else because it doesn't
really matter what the numbers are what
the science is this is a moral question
this is an interpretation of our
Constitution and of the way we govern
and of who is responsible for what in
your life and in America and in the
government innocent till proven guilty I
say you are healthy until proven sick
until proven
otherwise the tyho Mary example is a
poor example what we have here is we are
legislating and I am for the amendment
you should vote for this and nobody
should be mandating anything okay just
make that clear what this is is the
moral blame
game Who who can we blame when somebody
gets covid who can we blame for somebody
having something happen in their life I
say I am to blame for the things that
happen in my life and I say you all are
to blame for the things that happen in
your life this is also to me a
foundational Bedrock principle of
America these mandates are not currently
law if they are made law this is a
legitimization of the blame game this
says now you all here two people that I
was sitting with have lost their jobs
and they now have different ones my
wife's job has been on the chopping
block has not been lost yet how many
other people have to say this this is
saying that you are so dangerous that we
are going to legitimize that danger that
you all and you all present to the rest
of society we are going to mandate and
override your individual rights and
freedoms because you are such a danger
we can argue the science left and right
ultimately our are you all a danger
who's to say we had lockdowns without
due process we have schools my own SAU
District changes the segregation of the
children with their quarantine if they
test positive of covid based on whether
or not the parents are
vaccinated talk about discrimination
talk about
segregation let's talk about what's
actually killing people heart disease
I'm a I'm a personal trainer had a
Fitness business I've personally done
100 20 lb body transformation since I
was 14 years old 650,000 people sounds
like a lot that's heart disease every
year diabetes another 80 plus
thousand should we be like California if
we want a mandate to save lives and Ban
2 lit
sodas what are we actually doing this is
the freedom to blame you are
legitimizing blaming people for not
agreeing the last thing I'm going to say
we've had doctors come up and say that
this is not a problem with their ethics
because people have a a freedom to
choose whether to work what about a
doctor's office that says they will only
treat vaccinated people two months ago
when I was on the roadside at Dartmouth
I recorded a phone call to a doctor's
office an actual doctor's office and in
their office recording they said to get
service at this doctor's office medical
office you must provide your proof of
vaccine not a photocopy not a picture
you must provide the original
paper thank
you
Mr hry valo followed
by Ken
iring thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um I'll be very brief I
have some written testimony on behalf of
the New Hampshire w y MCAS uh to submit
to the committee um the YMCAs uh in New
Hampshire employ more than 2200 people
um they serve more than 100,000 Granite
sters across 85 different locations in
the state um the organization is opposed
to the amendment that is brought forward
here today um simply put um the wise
believe that community organiz ations
should be able to adopt their own
policies um on how they feel uh they
should uh treat the pandemic um they are
governed by people within their
Community uh they're Boards of directors
are drawn from people within their
community and uh so the organization
believes that uh people within their
communities should be able to decide
their own policies and uh that's that's
it thank
you thank
you Ken iring hi thank you for speaking
today my name is Ken iring by
pan de
Napoli go ahead Miss okay so I'm Ken
iring um I just respectfully I want to
remind everybody you all sworn an oath
to the Constitution when you took
office this constitution defends and
protects our right to self-govern
rep lad thank you very very much for
this important bill it's a long time in
coming I I applaud you for stepping up
and and bringing this forward this is a
very important
protection so obviously I support this
amendment now someone came up here and
said that it doesn't belong in this
committee it absolutely does our
children or our most precious
resources and we as the
adults we are tasked with making sure
that we make sure that they're safe and
protected taking an experimental vaccine
must be a personal and individual Choice
especially when it comes to the children
that's the parents'
decision people must not be coerced to
choose between taking a shot that they
don't want or lose their jobs and the
ability to feed their family and their
children and put a roof over their
heads this is
America that's not the promise of this
great nation
many have developed heart issues blood
clotting deaths sterilization in women
there's all kinds of side effects that
are associated with this vaccine and I
hesitantly call it vaccine because
they've changed the definition of that
word in order to
meet calling these vaccines vaccines for
covid what happened to my body my choice
is that only when it's politically apply
to another
issue these vaccine bills are all tied
together there's a lot of them we going
down a bad path
here hundreds of people showed up on
October 13th regarding the covid vaccine
database our government is pushing in
the wrong direction and these are all
incremental steps in the wrong
directions Governor sununu turned our
state that meeting into a police state
and nine people were illegally arrested
and I Fe Fe that with the co database
and decisions being made here and people
being forced to choose between their
jobs and their livelihoods and
potentially their lives because there is
no proof that this is a safe vaccine
doctors have been have testified that
you don't know until years into the
future and we're talking about giving
them to our children are you kidding
me Ivor meon
was brought up by rep gay she's right if
you look at India and
Indonesia if you want to mandate
something mandate iveron it's cheap and
it's safe proven effectively for
decades so I'll end with this not
everyone's going to come up and speak at
the mic but you heard a vast majority of
the people here when they stood up and
applauded rep lad when he introduced
this bill that's the people we the
people are speaking article 8 says that
all power resides in the people you are
our magistrates and officers and
therefore our servants and
representatives and at all time
accountable to us we have spoken a vast
majority spoke and said we are in
support of this bill this is our right
this is our bodies this is our state and
our
country and we choose to be
free thank you one last
thing so I'm sorry I know I'm over you
had a gentleman up here representing the
hospitals that's corporate Marxism
that's not what should take place in
this country thank you thank you thank
[Applause]
you Pam naol followed by Zack
tuba thank you my name is Pam Den I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Nurses Association and I'm a
nurse it's unclear to me why this non-
gerine amendment is coming before this
committee but I appreciate the
opportunity to provide you with the best
evidence from the healthc Care Community
there are 20,000 nurses in the state
most of whom have chosen to be
vaccinated although there are pockets of
vaccine hesitancy the American Nurses
Association reports 88 % of nurses have
been vaccinated or plan to be
vaccinated we are aware you may have
heard other testimony from individuals
who may themselves be nurses but to
reiterate these are a small number of
individuals we represent the voices of
our 1260 members and New Hampshire
nurses in general who collectively know
the facts follow the science about the
safety and eff efficacy of co9 vacine
and understand The Importance of Being
vaccinated in health care settings to
protect patients nurses other staff and
the
community vaccine mandates are effective
when employers require workers to get
vaccinated vaccination rates increase to
over
90% this is especially true for people
who intended to get vaccinated but have
just delayed or
procrastinated 90% vaccination rate
moves our community to her
immunity in a study released on Friday
both infection induced and vaccine
induced immunity are durable for at
least 6 months but vaccines are more
consistent in their protection and offer
a huge boost in antibodies for people
previously
infected some may agree that there are
legitimate exemptions when health
conditions would preclude some from
getting a vaccine but is clear that
Healthcare employees should make every
effort to be vaccinated and not try to
find
excuses we know some people are
procrastinating and continued debate
prolongs those decisions that would
otherwise be made in favor of
vaccination in no way should anyone be
granted the ability to be a
conscientious objector based on their
own interpretation of the truth
Healthcare employees should know the
evidence and the importance of their
role and the role of vaccines in the
prevention of covid-19 and its variance
and any barriers presented by debating
misinformation should be removed the
message should be get vaccinated thank
you thank
you a question did you take a
question repres thank you very much Mr
chairman um so my question goes back to
us the same question I was asking of the
medic of the New Hampshire Medical
Society um and it's a relative to formed
consent and the ability to give free and
voluntary I'm assuming nurses fall under
the same ethical guidelines as doctors
and health other health care providers
that informed consent must be given
prior to care and that informed consent
has to be uh free and voluntary is that
correct uh it's not the role of nurses
to get informed consent the the provider
has to get the provid and the nurses
then will witness informed consent so
that's within the nurse Practice Act of
New Hampshire
thank
you let's have some
order
W okay next speaker is Zach tuba
followed by Eric
Anthony yeah Zack tuba from marac
everything the previous woman just said
would be great and would be true if the
vaccines actually conveyed immunity
which if you're following the science
and listening to CDC director relle
wilinsky you would know that they don't
because she just admitted that they do
not convey immunity which completely
negates everything you just said
anyways I sent many of you a letter I
hope you read it or will read it and
know that it's not from some lobbyist or
group just from me and my family I'm so
tired of the continual lies being spun
that anyone who's opposed to government
vaccination mandates is antivaccine I
love vaccines that have a long and
robust safety record that convey
immunity my fiance and I hope to have
children in the future and when we do
they will receive their vaccines that
Grant immunity and prevent them from
Contracting and spreading dangerous
diseases vaccines for measles Ms rebella
hepatitis polio tetanus HPV and others
and when they become adults they can do
their own research and then they can
make their own vaccination decisions I
implore you not to accept the lies that
people opposed to the use of government
Force are somehow
anti-science I recently took job
interviews and received multiple job
offers for each offer I received I at
the end of the process asked the
employer if they would be requiring
covid vaccination and each employer
responded Yes that they had to follow
all government laws I've already
received multiple threatening emails
from my employer current employer
letting me know that they'll be adhering
to the federal mandate also saying that
they have to follow the law the only
thing that is temporarily holding back
my firing is the US appeals court
affirming the stay on the federal
mandate if the court system ultimately
decides in favor of the federal
government and allows the regulation to
take effect I will be fired from my job
of 10 years come January some of you
might believe that this problem of
vaccine resist
vaccine hesitancy as they call it will
simply go away if you stay silent and
allow Federal mandates to take effect in
our state perhaps you're thinking that
even the most hardened Skeptics will
Buckle when it's required for their
employment and so while unfortunate it
could be allowed to continue we look
around this room and listen and take to
heart the stories you hear today because
we and many more of us who could not be
here today are trying to tell you we
will not comply this mandate from the
the federal government is not a new law
it was not passed by the House and
Senate we implore you the rightful
lawmakers of our state who we elected to
represent us as empowered by the 10th
Amendment to uphold our freedom to
secure our Liberty to act and to do so
with urgency you have the power bestowed
to you through the New Hampshire
Constitution to fortify our laws to
protect our people our state and our way
of life by making vaccination status a
protected class in our State and at a
minimum prohibiting New Hampshire
entities from compelling receipt of a
covid-19 vaccine for employment I urge
you to vote in favor of the amendment
and HB 255 thank you for your
time thank
you do we have an Eric
Anthony followed by Desiree and Arcadia
lington looks like was
it go
ahead I speak today
as proud citizen of uh New Hampshire and
the United
States probably the main feature of that
citizenship is the purple heart that I
received while serving in the Marine
Corps in
Vietnam this otherwise irrelevant fact
compels me to be here
today you move closer to the mic can you
hear me
yeah this otherwise irrelevant fact
compels me to be here today it is
because of this
citizenship that I care deeply about the
form and the direction my government
takes and never have I been so concerned
in that respect than I am
now in a state whose motto is Live Free
or Die it would seem to me self-evident
that you reject a mandate which the
fifth circuit court of
appeals says raise raises grave
statutory and constitutional concerns
thank you citing page 18 of that
decision what might those grave concerns
be uh I would
refer the representatives to uh judge
englehart's uh
decision uh BTS versus OSHA in the fifth
circuit
staying the
Mandate and uh I would refer this as a
primer on the legal the
Constitutional and uh legislative flaws
in this
mandate I think it will help you in your
argument against the
Mandate uh it concerns there the main
concerns that I see are over the
separation of power principles and these
cast out on the mandates assertion and
virtually unlimited power to
uh to
um conduct individual uh sorry I can't
read my own writing
there I'm I'm quoting here it says this
is on page 17 concerns over separation
of powers principles cast doubt over the
mandates assertion and virtually
Unlimited
power over individual
conduct and uh that is really the
problem here you know when you give uh
Regulatory Agencies police
power over uh over the citizenry and
over State and
so for for the sovereignty of the State
of New Hampshire and for individual
freedom I urge that you uh support
representative la
Amendment and I thank
you thank
you before we go on with Desiree and
Arcadia I'd like to anybody with
children and that would are already
signed up to speak could you please come
up and let us know and then we'll trying
to get try to get the children out of
here
okay so yes go ahead um first of all I
would just like a little bit of Grace on
time since there is two of us um this is
my daughter so if you would just give us
a little bit Aradia um of
time um anyway my story is I worked at
New London Hospital which was part which
is part of Dartmouth Hitchcock and I had
had a um religious exemption from the
flu vaccine for four years that I had
worked there I was and environmental
services Tech I went into Co rooms and
cleaned them I was only one of four that
could properly clean covid rooms or the
operating room because of their mandate
that they implemented three out of four
of those people that could properly
clean those rooms left either because
our religious exemptions were denied
such as me and my sister or they just
left on their own accord because they
didn't think that it was right that they
were pushing for um vaccine
mandates um my the other part of the
story that I tell most often is my
daughter who um came with me today and
she had a reaction to a vaccine when she
was about 5 years old um I told this
story last week so some of you may know
but um I really thought that she was
going to die and I was told by a nurse
at the doctor's office that I could
bring her to the emergency room but
there was nothing that they could do
that still to this date has not been put
in her medical
record um so she can't have a medical
exemption from a vaccine because they
never even put it in her medical records
but she's standing with me so I'm going
to have her kind of talk more about um
her story and um why she personally is
against these
mandates
um I didn't remember don't remember what
happened and I don't remember the
reaction I had I only remember getting
the shot and then crying and hugging my
mom afterwards um my mom told me that I
had been
hallucinating and um that she had to run
um
it a cold a bath just to make me snap
out of it and
um it was a vaccine that had tooken
years to
make um I had three vaccines at once and
we don't know which one I had a allergic
reaction
to um and it hasn't been put in my
record as my mom said um my mom allow me
to have a vaccine that took only a few
months to
make thank
you um is there
Sarah
Jaden
con
excuse me your
name my name is Jay Isen um was did we
was that right were you calling for me
to come up no Sarah Jaden um Jordan I'm
sorry I'm
sorry I'm calling on her
first
and then Emily Phillips after
Sarah hello um I did not come here
planning to speak um but I am going to
speak I a Richard nurse
um I have a plotting disorder I have
been declined a medical exemption my
brother um died of a pulmonary
embolism um my doctor told me it was
completely safe to get the vaccination
um I thought about taking the
vaccine um without letting my fiance
know um so I could support my
family um I submitted an exemption and I
am waiting to hear from my employer
whether or not I still have a
job
I had Co when I was pregnant and
cohabitated with three of my nieces and
nephews
neither of them got Co I
survived my daughter
survived I don't think it is okay I
there's over 45 to 50 people waiting in
the emergency room to be seen because
you want to fire people who actually
want to work who have gone to school got
a degree and want to contribute to
society yet other people who do not want
to work you're gonna let them take my
taxes and pay for them to live I don't
think it's okay people are dying I am
calling ambulances they are telling me
they cannot pick up patients um until a
few days later
um it's just not okay and I I was texted
by my um boss on my personal cell phone
um she stated that the deadline was fast
approaching she listed out
um the choices I had
and I chose not to answer her and I
responded to her when I got back to work
on work
time and yesterday was the deadline of
they're reviewing him on a day-to-day
basis and I was greeted by the CNO and
the president of the hospital yesterday
which I've only seen one
time working there over two and a half
years that's all I have to
say hello everyone I'm trying not to
make it too loud um I am a employer of
eight people in the granite state I'm
proud to say I work for a family
business um that's been around for 75
years over 20 of them we moved to New
Hampshire my grandfather moved us from
Massachusetts because this is a better
place to conduct business it's a better
place to live and that's why we're here
I'm also a school board member in my
town that's Fremont New Hampshire um I'm
a mother and I am a free resident of New
Hampshire um I'm trying to speak on
behalf of all those points in under
three minutes but um I won't comply with
mandate for vaccination of my employees
I just won't um I think that if we don't
do enough to stop this we're going to
crush small businesses I mean those of
us that have survived this pandemic um
if we're forced to enforce a federal
mandate for vaccination we're going to
lose our employees I can I happen to
know that two of my employees are
vaccinated they've chosen to do so the
rest have not um I can't continue my
business with two employees um that's a
concern of mine and like I said I won't
enforce it even if it comes down but I I
need you guys to step up and make this
impossible so it I don't have to do it
like this is not my job this is like I
you're making
me you know enforce ridiculous things as
an employer um as a as a mother um you
know you you've poked the Bear right
like we're all here I have a job I've
got other things to do I've got this
six-month old baby who's breastfeeding
right now like I don't want to be here
but I'm here because this is important
and we have to stand up all of us we
have to stop just complying just stop we
have to raise hell and I'm and I'm glad
there's no fourth graders here because
we're all mad and I'm not vaccine
hesitant I have two older children who
are vaccinated per the CDC schedule okay
I'm not hesitant I've never been more
convinced of anything in my entire life
I don't want this okay and the people
who haven't gotten
vaccinated they don't want it either
okay it's not an accessibility issue all
right
so I happen to have information it's
called the executive dashboard from DHHS
as a Schoolboard member we look at it
like every day my town and surrounding
towns like I said was Fremont uh it's
48.5% as of yesterday are vaccinated of
eligible people 48% and that's similar
to the town surrounding us and that's
like Raymond Danville that sort of thing
okay that means I represent at least
half of my town okay so people will say
in the media that it's a small group of
us okay it's not a small group when this
first started 90% of this room I believe
was for this okay it's dwindled because
people have things to do okay or they
spoke their mind and they left but I
would say 90% are here to speak for this
okay um we're mad okay and I'm not going
to comply regardless thank you 30
seconds um and I think that if you don't
stand up and do your job which is what
we expect you to do okay like protect us
cuz we're not going to comply regardless
so you think it's bad now with the you
know employment and everything else
we're looking at desperation here and as
a school board member I'm telling you
there will be a mass Exodus from public
schools you push this on the kids and
they are done the Good Luck running a
public school when there are no teachers
there are teachers who don't want to be
vaccinated and there are parents parents
who will not send their kids you cannot
run public education government schools
without people attending them think
about it please do your job thank
[Applause]
you could I have your
name I'm Stephanie Elliott I'm speaking
on behalf of axon hasel today she to
leave early um thank you for the
opportunity to speak on behalf of this
important legislation which I am in
favor of and I'd like to read to you an
ex from the code of federal
regulations um Food and Drug
Administration title 21 chapter 1
Department of Health and Human
Services on informed consent of human
subjects no investigator may involve a
human being as a subject in research
covered by these regulations unless the
investigator has obtained the legally
effective informed consent of the
subject an investigator shall seek such
consent only under circumstances that
provide the respective subject to a
sufficient opportunity to consider
whether or not to participate and that
minimizes the possibility of coercion or
undue
influence the information that is given
to the subject or the representative
shall be in a language understandable to
the subject or the
representative no informed consent
whether oral or written may include any
exculpatory language through which the
subject or the representative is made to
wave or appear to wave any of the
subject's legal rights or releases or
appears to release the investigator the
sponsor the institution or its Agents
from liability or
negligence and I want to point out that
this is the um insert to the madna
vaccine and it is intentionally blank
and it is also um the same in all of the
current um
available emergency use authoriz ized
vaccinations um the basic elements of in
of informed consent are this is part of
the the
law um in seeking informed consent the
following information shall be provided
to each subject a statement that the
study involves research an explanation
of the purposes of the research and the
expected duration of the subject's
participation descriptions of procedures
to be followed and identification of any
procedures which are
experimental number two a description of
any reasonably foreseeable risks or
discomforts to the subject number three
a description of any benefits to the
subject or to others which may
reasonably be expected from the research
number four a disclosure of appropriate
alternative procedures or courses of
treatment if any that might be
advantageous to the
subject I'm going to skip to the final
one a statement that participation is
voluntary that refusal to participate
will involve no penalty or loss of
benefits to which the subject is
otherwise entitled and that the subject
May discontinue participation at any
time without penalty or loss of benefits
to which the subject is otherwise
entitled I want to just finish by
saying I am not
procrastinating I am not hesitant I am
informed and I do not consent
thank you uh is there Mr William
Johnson not seen uh Trish Jorgenson of
Northfield I'd like to thank everybody
for being here and supporting your
citizens I think it's
awesome
I have a son who's 12 who right now is
being educated at home because last
Wednesday my SAU said masss are coming
back to school not Choice anymore so
he's being educated at home the reason
that I have to send him to the sea is
because of the wonderful Freedom
accounts that all you people are aware
of I don't qualify for I make too much
money I'm not poor enough to qualify to
get my kid to a better education but
irrelevant to that he will not be having
the vaccine he was born with a heart
condition he's 12 no way in how is he
getting a vaccine that's mandated by my
SAU or by my government he'll be
refusing that as well I don't know what
that'll bring but let's hope that you
guys stop all that in the state of New
Hampshire as far as far as my husband
and having to do it for a
work that won't happen either I don't
know what that'll mean probably changing
positions other employment I don't know
but I'm curious if an employer requires
this and the 10 hours or the 12 hours
that are you're required to be at work
you work those 12 hours and you go home
and you die because you had that vaccine
who's helping my husband then who's
supporting my family
then is he getting paid still to go to
bed at night and die from having
something that they mandated for him to
go to work I mean the whole thing is
ridiculous we all know it it makes no
common sense so it needs to stop and you
guys need to be the ones to stop it
educationally and employment workers I'm
a housewife I won't be getting it either
okay thank you for hearing me thank you
for listening and I hope you guys do the
right thing thank you is there a Vicky
tuba
Bedford and uh after Vicky will be
Nathan Glazer of
dairy hi I'm Vicki tuba from Bedford New
Hampshire and I'm in favor of this
amendment thank you for this hearing of
the people of New Hampshire I'm here
today because of a pressing need an
imminent threat to our Liberty that
cannot wait for the next session to
commence next year people in New
Hampshire are going to start losing
their jobs in January all based on an
executive command which even Nancy
Pelosi stated in an April 29th press
conference that we cannot require
someone to be vac vaccinated that's just
not what we can do it's a matter of
privacy to know who is or who isn't so
what has happened since then for one the
goalposts keep moving what began is a
newly engineered vaccine experimental in
nature with a short study of documented
effects has now become mandatory
compliance because their patience is
wearing thin to quote President Biden
turn on any news channel and they'll
paint a picture of these recipients of
thin patients
they'll tell you that Americans could go
beyond covid if it weren't for the
threat that nonvaccinated people pose
the unvaccinated are the new scapegoat
and then they'll pull up a map and
they'll tell you where the unvaxxed
reside in red states with red Governors
and quote uneducated Trump supporters
end quote make no mistake about it the
Mandate is a very real political attempt
to marginalize and punish non-compliance
of political opponents and to remove the
freedoms associated with individual
autonomy if we concede to this mandate
it will not end there in Austria as of
December 6th of this year proof of
vaccination to enter public places will
no longer be valid because you will be
required to show proof of a booster shot
to enter a public restaurant or venue
and when the efficacy of that booster
wains there'll be another booster all of
our Lives will become dictated
controlled supervised and micromanaged
and the next step will be trapped there
will be halves and have knots with the
unvaccinated on the losing end it's not
enough to give Employers in New
Hampshire the option whether to require
vaccinations or not why because they
will fear who carries the bigger stick
and with a $14,000 penalty per worker
New Hampshire companies will be forced
to comply or forced to go out of
business the best way to protect New
Hampshire residents citizens and workers
from violation of basic human rights is
with this bill our duty is to protect
unvaccinated persons as a class of
individuals who have not abdicated their
rights if we stand by and do nothing
it's the same thing as allowing this
grab of power to occur I implore you to
recognize legally protected status of
non-vaccinated persons for whatever the
reason from discrimination in housing
education employment services and
movement basic needs to live please
protect our Granite Staters from federal
government overreach the Constitution
says the powers not granted to the
federal government are reserved to the
States but the individual freedoms are
not the governments to give the
Declaration of Independence tells us
they are inalienable rights they are
natural rights endowed by our creator
and each of us are accountable and
answerable unto
him thank you is there a uh Nathan
Glazer here
I guess not uh Abby Flores of
Rochester is there a John spellers of
Bristol good afternoon committee uh
appreciate you taking the time and
hearing us out here uh a lot of good
thoughts on both sides and and uh to me
it's all about freedom and uh and it
does hit Cal to me I uh retired October
31st uh company 14,000 employees
worldwide 4 billion uh and years
business um I have documentation here
that I would like to leave with you that
shows the actual email sent from the CEO
saying show us your vaccination status
or be terminated that was letter one
letter two that I have is saying show us
your vaccinated status or that will mean
if you don't show it to us you are
voluntarily
resigning as of November 30th it just so
happened that we also the the company is
going through a pre-ipo status and
therefore offered some several of their
older employees long-term employees me
I've been there 21 and A2 years and we
had an early retir program which
happened all in the same timeline so
everything for me in my age group worked
out perfectly I resigned at that point I
took the early retirement program I had
the means to do so but I'm concerned
about the younger folks those that don't
have the means that's what's going to
happen is it's going to be them that's
going to affect them the most and I look
at my job I which I just gave up $130
plus thousand a year this is going to
hit New Hampshire I have no longer have
that means there's I think there's at
least 10 employees that work for this
company that live in New Hampshire and
they all make well over $100,000 a year
but just imagine if all those lost their
jobs this is going to have a trickle
down effect it's going to afford it's
going to cause all the businesses to
make less money less money means less
employees less employees and less money
means less conect to the state it's
going to have a trickle down effect that
it's just going to devastate every I
would like to see New Hampshire which I
moved to here uh let me see back in' 08
I would still like to see New Hampshire
be that little glimmer of hope in the
New England states that we're in that we
can have that little bit of Freedom
that's left over now I'm pretty active
up in Bristol New Hampshire where I live
and uh sa 4 and they hear me out most
all the times as well but you know as
and I I I say all this because as God is
my witness and his son Jesus Christ that
still lives and is coming back very very
very soon all right this what we're
going through right now and I appreciate
your time doing it is just the tip of an
iceberg that's coming our way this all
will have a trickle down effect and and
the other stuff that's coming along is
nothing compared to this so protect the
freedoms let to be Liberty still and let
us continue to enjoy New Hampshire and
let that still be the light in KN thank
you thank you um Amy
Smith and after Amy will be Kathy
Mayo hi my name is Amy Smith I live in
Deerfield New
Hampshire for just over 20 years I've
worked in nursing and medical research
my company publishes more than 300
medical and nursing journals thousands
of books that are used in hospitals
teaching hospitals Med schools nursing
schools across the globe we have
software that Physicians use uh and
nurses use at the point of care and in
learning and in research I spend many
days digging into the research that we
publish researching multiple aspects of
healthcare and teaching our inter
internal teams all about the connections
in between the two I also talk about how
our content can help practitioners make
better decisions and have the best
patient
outcomes to have the best patient
outcomes providers have to practice
evidence-based medicine something that
hasn't been mentioned
today they also need to practice
evidence-based nursing both of these
evidence-based practices make up three
categories the first is patient
preference the second is provide our
expertise the third is research it's
really important to note that there's
three pieces of evidence-based medicine
not four there's no government involved
in patient
care there's no go government involved
in evidence-based medicine none to allow
the government to dictate whether it's
New Hampshire or federally to dictate
how a patient is treated is a gross
violation of the patient provider
relation ship not to mention
unconstitutional thank goodness that the
US court of appeals for the fifth circus
is upholding the stay against this
mandate the three dud judge panel have
called the Mandate fatally flawed and
staggering staggeringly broad the stay
which the court issued last week says
OSHA should take no steps to implement
or enforce the Mandate until further
court
order unfortunately for me my company
falls under the federal contract group
of dictator Biden's
mandate this is another gross overreach
of government my company because we have
contracts with the vas across the US are
considering us a
contractor this is happening to hundreds
of private businesses across the US my
company had no plans to force a man a
vaccine upon us they are now being
coerced by the government to implement
this mandate if my religious exemption
is not approved I will be out of a job
after 20 years 20 years of traveling
around the US and the globe teaching
Hospital staff about evidence-based
medicine research and the impacts of
patient
care in closing I'll share with you just
a bit of an article that was just
published in the European Journal of
epidemiology it's authored by a couple
of uh researchers out of the Harvard th
Chan School of Public
Health the title of the article is
increases in covid-19 are
unrelated to levels of vaccination in 68
countries in the
US
2,947 counties in the United States the
findings show and I quote at the country
level there appear to be no discernible
relationship between the percentage of
population fully vaccinated and new Co
cases thank
you Kathy Mayo and then is there a Terry
wiel hi Kathy Mayo from
Nottingham um thank you for allowing
this today I really appreciate it and
this has been a great learning
experience too um first I would I just
wanted to the director of nursing I
believe she was had mentioned something
about um the antibodies and your
immunity I I just want you to know I did
request from my own physician about
having a covid antibody lab um and the
response I got back was um the doctor
States it isn't recommended as it will
not change any clinical
recommendations the recommendation per
the CDC would be to receive a covid
vaccine regardless of antibody
status so without knowing your antibody
status how could they make that
assumption whether I would be anyway so
my husband and I both work at the same
place and we're actually a generation
that when you chose your job um you
basically stayed there for however long
you know so he's been there 30 years
I've been there
18 and they have not yet um mandated
this um they have sent out multiple
emails strongly urging for people to get
vaccinated um and my husband and I
myself I had pulmonary embolisms
undiagnosed back in
2011 not UND diagnosed on um the reason
why I had them
they they still don't know so this would
be a really scary position for me to be
in especially because I've done all my
research and such and I do believe that
they do cause clots um so for
me beyond the fact that my I would not
do it because of my religion um but my
husband also would not be wanting to
choose to get vaccinated so both of us
would be without a job and I'm wondering
too if that were the case we wouldn't
resign we would wait until they forced
us and fired us so my question which I
don't think this has been brought up yet
today too is if that's the case can we
collect unemployment I mean or we out of
a job and oh well you know so another
thing to consider and I I don't and I'm
not an D back per se um and I don't
think this should be a political
situation Democrat or Republicans I
would really really really implore you
to really go into to your heart and
again look at our generations going
forward if we're going to even have any
at this point because of this um please
please consider this and do it now don't
wait try and have a special session or
whatever you need to do because I I
implore you thank you
thank you chairman and committee members
I appreciate the time that you give to
to us and serving for us um would just
like
to read something here
[Music]
about where' it
go I'm sorry I had it all set but I
apparently lost it it'll be just a
second or
two mandatory mandatory is required or
commanded by Authority obligatory
of having the nature of or containing a
mandate it's not a
law it doesn't make any difference that
the president has said he wants to
mandate vaccinations or he passes it on
to OSHA which is not a legislative body
it's not authorized to enforce these
kinds of laws or make laws for us to
live
by apparently the federal government
doesn't care and and so I agree with the
majority of other people who have come
forward and said it's now up to our
state legislature to protect our people
here in the state appreciate that each
and every one of you are elected by your
constituents and that's what we are your
constituents who come forward to express
our opinions on different things and
also to remind you as others have that
you've taken an oath to defend the
Constitution to defend us and to take
care of us and you're responsible to us
we the people I know that you have
lobbyists who come in and try to
persuade you and have money packs behind
them but this is an issue that you
should not be listening to lobbyists
about you need to listen to your
constituency you need to do what's
right also we shouldn't be pushing an
agenda this is this is an agenda this is
an agenda to get us all to be not just
heard compliant on vaccine but heard
compliant in our man in our mentality to
obey without questioning that's not what
this country was founded upon so we need
you to remember that we need you to
understand the position you are in to
make these laws we have loyal
opposition but truthfully and honestly
the way this whole issue is being
handled that people who choose to differ
that don't meet the mainstream are
trying to be shamed and guilted when
there's no reason for it so please
remember your constituency do what's
right do what's morally right because to
not pass this law puts unvaccinated
people at risk and a death death
sentence of Another Kind when you're
denied the ability to work and to take
care of your loved ones thank thank you
for your time thank you is there a
Russen Chester of Bedford yes thank you
and after that uh we'll hear from Susan
Romo of
Hollis all set okay um originally I was
coming in here just to listen um the
last time I was here was when the
Department of Mental Health was trying
to get money from the government
government from our New Hampshire
government and it drastically impacted
mental health in our community that's
the last time I was here so that was
when Jean Shaheen was governor um I came
here today just to listen my former
experience I started my career in
accounting and went into um social work
after realizing that I wasn't a black
and white kind of person I like some of
it some of it not so much but one of the
things that I have an advantage
advantage of is I take I I look at
statistics I pay attention I do my own
research so out of 57 people that spoke
today there is 1 2 3 4 five six 7 nine
people that are opposed to
this Ed amendment of those nine seven of
them
represent represent agencies and
capacities that will
profit from this directly or indirectly
now I'm saying Medicare Medicaid anybody
that that receives Medicare and Medicaid
money they're going to lose Lots if our
government in New Hampshire
turns around and says we're not going to
pay attention to what the FED say we're
going to do what's right for our state
and our people so I want you all to
think about that out of the nine people
I was able to identify seven of them who
are financially motivated for
opposing
this amendment the t two I don't know
they were Representatives I don't know
what they are beyond that because I
wasn't able to get their names now of
the seven that I did get their names and
I googled and Wikipedia each one of them
to find out what their background was
that's that's what a good researcher
does every single person or the the
folks that you asked questions
of were they were not it was not
appropriate if you looked at their
background it was not appropriate for
them to answer those questions yes could
could we address the bill okay instead
of who uh spoke okay previously okay
bottom line the bill is there's 5 I am a
vac injured indiv
individual I am lucky because I can't
take this vaccine it will kill me so I'm
lucky but I'm here fighting for all of
those that either can't or won't speak
up for themselves because of the fear
because of the bullying because of the
you know you're nothing to us we'll get
all fine without you when did that
happen in New Hampshire when did that
when did New Hampshire become
that so I ask all of you before you vote
on this pay attention to who opposed it
and who did not now my Max injury I
would do it
again because I chose to get a flu
vaccination because I didn't want to
have to wear PPE
for disabled adults thank you thank you
for your time thank Youk you is it Susan
Romeo of
Hollis seen she's not here someone named
janeson or
Jameson how about Kell Kelly
Potenza is is there
Natalie Roman
Nelson oh I'm
sorry your name hi I'm Jameson okay I'm
from Orange New Hampshire I'm a baker
and a farmer
um a writer and an independent
journalist uh thank you Mr chairman
representatives and fellow citizens I'm
humbled and inspired to be part of this
group I feel as though you are my family
I was born right here in Conquer New
Hampshire I'm today testifying in favor
of HB
255 does anyone in this room want less
Freedom no does anyone want their
Healthcare choices to be in the hands of
politicians
okay um this brings us to the nurenberg
code of 1947 I hear many people uh
talking about informed consent today but
I didn't hear anybody specifically
mentioned the nurenberg code um outlined
in the nurburg code is that the
voluntary consent of the human subject
is absolutely
essential and not only that but this
supersedes the justification that such
experiments May yield results for the
good of society I I bring this up
specifically because there's been a lot
of oh sacrificing the individual rights
for the good of the collective and I um
I'm here to very much testify that
without individual rights there is no
good for the
collective
um why are we here to testify in favor
of our inherent birth rights why is this
even necessary very much so what I put
into my body that is a right that was
granted to me at the time of my birth
and is not something that anybody can
take
away why is it even necessary to submit
religious exemptions to retain our
Birthright if somebody doesn't want to
take something into their body just
simply them saying No thank you that
that should be sufficient I believe
mandating a pharmaceutical procedure or
product has many undesirable
consequences not the least of which is
that it is devastating to our economy
and Collective mental
health the federal government stance is
clear getting shots in arms shots shots
shots and if those don't work booster
shots this is their primary goal not
ensuring the safety of these injections
not Shing up the health of the nation
not setting up early treatment protocols
for
covid-19 seems as though they're really
just here to promote shots regardless of
whether they work or regardless of
whether or not anybody actually wants to
take
them um so here just in the last uh few
days the executive Council of our state
unfortunately flip-flopped in taking um
approximately $23 million in federal
money for pushing vaccine propaganda
unfortunate if we could stay on to the
bill okay yeah that a that's a little
off point I I granted um but that was
just to make the following point which
is that despite this failure I am here
because I still have faith in my state
government the nurburg codes protect us
against not just experimental injections
but also against mandatory testing and
mandatory
masking I wanted to share one anecdotal
comment how the one person in my immed
imediate Circle who got the MRNA
injection was also the only one who has
gotten
covid-19 thank you very much may I make
one closing statement okay stand on the
right side of humanity and reclaim our
nation our great nation from the Luna
seed is engulfed in by offering
opposition to senseless mandates and
fearmongering propaganda since when did
our birth right to bodily autonomy mean
nothing in this country I'm truly
sickened by the spectacle of corruption
that poses as Federal governing body
profit and population control have
become the only goals of a federal
government that has forgotten the limits
of its power as outlined in the
Constitution thank you very much thank
you is there Kelly
Potenza thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak I'm going to just
start off with a just a a scripture
verse from Revelation it says for your
Merchants were the Great Men of the
Earth for by your sorcery all the
nations were deceived sorcery just so
you know translated in the King James
version of the Bible is actually phakia
that's Pharma witchcraft because no one
but witches and Sorcerers used drugs 400
years ago drugs were most commonly used
in Pagan worship to hallucinate and to
get in touch with evil spirits just an
FYI as a citizen of New Hampshire in the
United States of America I am very
opposed to all to all proposed bills
that would impose state or federal
vaccine mandates actually any illegal
mandates for that matter more
importantly I am I'm opposed to the
continuation of a legislative process in
which you do not have the authority to
even enact such legislation to be frank
the first order of business when this
legislative body convenes after
hopefully making this happen and passing
this protection for all people in New
Hampshire should should be to grab a
copy of the New Hampshire Constitution
the US Constitution and the Bill of
Rights and remove all unconstitutional
laws illegal laws all unconstitutional
and illegal rules committees councils
departments that have been thrusted upon
the citizens of New Hampshire for
decades those aformentioned items are
the foundation those things the Bill of
Rights you know the New Hampshire
Constitution um they are really the
atlas and to bring it to modern day
terms it's the GPS for how every bill
should be crafted and it's the litmus
test in knowing if it should even be
passed to begin
with if it is not constitutional it
violates my natural rights my inherent
rights given by God in my
Creator then based upon the oath was
that was taken from every elected
official in New Hampshire state
government you have a moral and more
importantly a fiduciary responsibility
to the citizens of New Hampshire
everybody always cons you know always
says fiduciary responsibility only
concerns money but the word fiduciary
does not in and of itself it suggests
financial matters it actually applies in
which one person justifiably places
confidence and Trust in someone else and
seeks that person's help or advice in
some matter the attorney client
relationship is a fiduciary one for
example because the client trusts the
attorney to act in the best interest of
the client at all times the word are
faithful to their origin the Latin word
fider which means to trust we have
elected you as our public servants that
trust agreement has been
broken and I do want to say ignorance of
the law is not an excuse there's a
recent court case in uh June 9th 2017
the state versus Miller that says
this I wrote this whole statement based
upon parents because if you actually
look look there are no real Federal
mandates at this point I mean they're
trying of course as we all know why
we're here but I wrote this based upon
parents because there's really no you
know mandatory vaccinations for adults
so please understand whenever I say
parents I mean all human beings yeah
thank
you is there a Natalie Roman
Nelson how about uh Al
Grand
Dano of uh
kton so Al's not here and I have his and
as well as uh Sandy gisler's not here I
have hers okay if you could uh submit
them to up front I can't read
no I'm sorry um next is uh Gary
Carlson
courtsmith
how about uh Walter kch of Warner or
Warner Mary Sullivan of
Nashua good afternoon um thank you for
letting me speak with you uh my name is
Mary suin I'm a New Hampshire resident
on November 1st 2021 I was terminated
for my job in Massachusetts due to the
non-compliance of the vaccine
mandate I've been a registered nurse for
years the past 20 years I worked in
surgical services in the recovery room
prior to this I worked in intensive
care on March 2020 our manager informed
me and approximately 600 staff in our
department that we would need to work
ICU the hospital didn't have enough
Critical Care nurses so they looked at
staff's resumee and those with ICU
experience in these areas was sent to
these
areas despite my worry that my ICU
skills were 20 years old we were in a
pandemic and I knew that this is how I
could serve the community of the
hospital my shift was 3 to 11 weekends
and holidays most days and nights when I
went to and from work I was the only
person on the
road
before my shift I was sick to my stomach
when I got home at night I had certain
routine in place before going into the
house because I was afraid I would bring
the covid home to my family most Health
Care Professionals had a simil Affairs
and
routines on August of 2021 the hospital
informed employees that they would need
to be vaccinated by early September or
submit res
exemptions I put an exemption which was
denied I wrote appeals twice and both
were denied I can't tell you how
stressful this exemption process
was no one knew who the exemption
committee was they seldom responded to
my emails human resources did not know
the appeals process so I went up to
chain of command in our hospital I have
since found out this lack of
communication and mystery surrounding
the exemption committees is across the
board in most institutions
on November 1st I was terminated as I
said for non-compliance with the vaccine
mandate they said I placed an undue
burden on the hospital with my
unvaccinated status I didn't I guess
back in May March of
2020 two women from Human Resource
called me on a zoom to discuss my last
appeal as well as well as my last
paycheck where it would be mailed
to as this at this meeting I asked the
if the ICU was being staffed by federal
employees the answer I received was that
staff they would be hiring vaccinated
staff I asked if skill and work ethic no
longer
mattered they didn't answer
me sorry I'm
shaking I'm still in touch with my
former co-workers and friends they tell
me that they have frustrations and anger
over losing caregivers in the M of an
already profound nursing shortage they
are trying to provide care to the
patients deserve and I can't tell you
how much how helpless this makes me my
only hope is that I will find employment
in my home state of New Hampshire where
the motto is Live Free or Die thank you
thank
you there Christine BN from
conquered
followed by Mary
Sullivan good afternoon my name is
Christine Vio I live right here in
conquer with my husband and my two young
sons and I come to you as a concerned
Citizen and I'm in full support of this
amendment to
h255 um covid-19 vaccine mandates do not
belong in New Hampshire or anywhere else
in this free country
I've watched in awe and in horror at the
abandonment of common sense in our
society over the past 18 months with
every passing transgression and power
grab I thought surely now is when people
will snap out of it but incredibly
enough here we are and here I am firstly
I want to say that I'm encouraged by the
resistance developing Nationwide against
Biden's unconstitutional mandates last
week we all know a federal appeals court
Court temporarily blocked the mandates
and there are currently 27 states that
have filed lawsuits over them proudly
New Hampshire is one of those States It
Feels Like New Hampshire is on the right
path and right now I want to supplement
all the arguments we've heard today
against any mandate with a basic concept
this injection does not stop
transmission that's it period it does
not slow the spread it was never to
designed to do so it was only designed
to suppress symptoms that right there
should be enough to end all talk of
mandating this product on those
unwilling to receive
it for good but that message is still
not getting through to everyone possibly
because the herd immunity carrot has
been deliberately dangled in front of
the people since the very beginning and
for so long it's caused so much
confusion and has trapped some into
believing they're doing their part all
the while turning people against each
other in an already divided country
further confusing people is the cdc's
edit of the very definition of what a
vaccine is which they did quietly in
September two months ago according to
their definition now it is no longer a
product that provides immunity to a
disease but rather a product that
provides protection from a disease this
is a very important
distinction whatever it is this product
will never contribute to Public Health
or the common good those injected are
still getting sick and still
transmitting the virus individual
benefit is the most one can hope for but
even that is in question as the
so-called protection lasts for only a
few months time how can we mandate a
product for which we cannot provide
informed consent not one doctor or
scientist on this planet can tell you
the long-term effects of the shot two
weeks ago while discussing the
inevitable and tragic pediatric Rec
recommendation Dr Jefferson Jones from
the cdc's asip committee admitted with a
chuckle that her immunity is not a
reasonable goal of this
vaccination my husband cared for covid
patients all last year but now has
termination looming over his head simply
because he does not want a product in
his body that carries with it risk yet
has no effect on virus transmission it's
not about patient safety but about
Compliance New Hampshire must show the
country that we will not Bend to corrupt
Federal pressure to pharmaceutical
interests or medical coercion and we
will not allow these nonsensical
mandates in the Live Free or Die State
thank you very much thank you is there a
wahba Ben
benene sorry for the
mispronunciation um and following her
would be Dan
McMahon good afternoon everybody thank
you for uh giving me the opportunity to
talk today uh my name
isus I um I didn't prepare anything to
talk
today but I feel the need that I had
to um I am a wife I'm a mother of two
and I am a
nurse I have with all the
shortage that that we hear about in the
state with can't find nurses to work I
can't get a job because I don't want
want the vaccine I can't get a job
because of a mandate that says that I
have to jab myself with a product that
everybody here all the people that spoke
have been calling
vaccine it's not a vaccine it's a gene
therapy this is not my words this is
what these pharmaceutical companies call
it gene
therapy I do do not want gene therapy I
don't want to change my jeans I like the
way God created me I'm happy with
[Applause]
myself and just to add to the mix my
husband is on the verge of losing his
job too he's also a
nurse if he doesn't get the job the
jab and then I am left with two kids and
a husband with no paycheck I don't have
millions in the bank like these
pharmaceutic companies
do I don't have that I rely on a job a
day-to-day job to help people mind you
people that I was taught to give
informed consent to before I administer
anything anything even if it's a glass
of water I have to tell them this is a
glass of water would you like it if they
say no then I walk out and I document
the patient refused I don't say it was
mandated for you by you Doctor you have
to have it or you're going to be kicked
out of the hospital
today I don't do that because that's
what I was Tau that's the oath I took to
protect that patient but then when it's
my
turn I don't get informed consent for
something that's experimental that's not
even proven safe or effective you've
heard many people here list the science
I'm not going to go through that they
did a great job with that
but what I can say is this is not a one
siiz withit all like the virus I know
the virus doesn't discriminate I had
covid Twice first time all my family had
it we were sick for a week we relied on
natural treatment vitamin C vitamin D
zinc magnesium the things that
are easy to get cheap and available
everywhere not to mention ior maon and
hydrochloroquine that's been suppressed
to the
bones and we healed we didn't die that
doesn't mean I don't sympathize with the
people that are still
suffering
but there is other alternative
treatments so why am asking why am I
being asked to take vaccine or I
shouldn't even call it that I
said an experimental product that's not
even
proven thank you ma'am I have one one
last statement if you don't mind quickly
please I brought this with me today and
I know many people mention the
Constitution and also title seven of the
civil rights of um Civil Rights Act of
1964 that gives me this right I
shouldn't even be here because of this I
shouldn't even be here today to defend
myself and try to protect my
family this is an innate thing
God gave us this if this all I'm asking
you today I am obviously supporting this
man this this
amendment and I'm asking you to stop
this medical
journey to stop it today please thank
you is
there is there a Dan McMahon Troy New
Hampshire how about is Steven rle from
Manchester
and following him uh Thomas McLoud I
believe it is from Mount
Vernon hello um you guys hear me there
we go um thanks for sticking with me um
it's been a long day I'll keep it brief
um uh I came from uh from Oregon about
uh few a few years ago
2017 um fleeing uh big government
um what has been known to be uh be
called a critical race Theory
indoctrination um what I like to call
what really is The Wil cult that had
been spreading there I came here for
Freedom um because this this I believe
this state has a tradition of value
independent
Liberty I have a bachelor's of Science
and physics I got from Southern
University and so I felt I should chime
in here about um about science in
general because U I think it's
relevant and uh because uh I've got the
impression that the proponents of the
covid-19 vaccine mandates uh don't
really understand what science
is I bring this up because um the
proponents of the covid-19 VAC vaccines
the Mandate
specifically they use term terms like uh
trust the science the science is
settled I've always found these to be
very interesting terms very final very
deliberate and very contrary to what I
have what I studied uh in actually my
first year of college when they taught
us the very basics of
science what is science exactly science
is a rigor a rigorous and rational
debate using objectively collected data
repeatable results collected using the
scientific method sir if if we speak to
the bill please it is relevant
please well we we can look up the
definition of science but we're
interested in hearing is about the bill
of
course I'll speed it up the purpose of
science is to challenge the boundaries
of human human knowledge and again as as
I've mentioned that is done through
debate an example that's relevant to
this of of various uh alternative
um uh alternative treatments and
theories are vaccines
Ivermectin uh hydroxy chloroquin natural
immunity V various other
ones what I'm not
seeing from the the people specific the
CDC the NIH uh big the big farmer
companies fiser
Etc I'm not
seeing rigorous debate I'm seeing
censorship I'm seeing silence I'm seeing
and hearing doctors with dissenting
opinions and data being silenced
shadowbanned
demonetized this is absolutely not in
keeping with what science
is thank you sir to close it to close
just one second vaccine mandates are not
based on
science they're based on scientism or
pseudo science and this
is this is the efforts of a select view
to create a class of experts that cannot
be challenged government bureaucrats
that cannot be challenged and
essentially two different classes of
people those that that Safeguard truth
and those that are are deemed
peasants is there Thomas cloud from
Mount
Fon how about Nathan flowers from
Jaffrey and Eva
Arsenal from
where uh
Jam wer of
Hollis
hello my name is Jam Wilder from um
Hollis New Hampshire I have been a
resident of New Hampshire for over 40
years and I love our great state I am
also um blessed to have a loving husband
and five children uh two of which that
go to the Hollis line Co-op school and
three of them that I'm currently
homeschooling I am here today um
because right now there is nothing more
important than for you to vote Yes on
this bill my husband is the um sole um
bread maker of our home I I am a
homemaker I stay home and I um all of
our money that he gets um comes from his
employment which he is facing to lose
based on uh an unconstitutional mandate
from the federal
government um my children the three
younger ones are being home homeschooled
right now I was going to start sending
them to the schools but because of the
unlawful mandates that they have to be
masked which I consider child abuse
because um they cannot learn and they
are not able um to breathe properly so
um I thank you for your time as the
education board and and there's a good
chance you might be seeing more of me in
the months to
come um I want I just want to touched
upon a couple things as I sat here and
listened uh
today first I would like to tell you
about a personal story of a vaccine um
injury that happened to my best friend's
mother she ended up having a stroke and
then a massive brain bleed which left
her unable to use half of her body and
will spend the rest of her life probably
in a wheelchair it is documented that it
is from a vaccine injury from
covid-19 I know of many people that are
fully vaccinated and still getting Co
I'm not going to go into the science
with you because frankly the science
does not matter what matters is our
constitutional rights and what we have
been given by
God I am standing here today not only
for my husband and for my children I'm
standing here for my hundreds of friends
that could possibly lose their job that
can't be here to stand up and use their
voice I'm standing here for all the
mothers that are out there that are
terrified to let an experimental drug be
put in their babies
bodies I'm standing here for our
freedoms and I plead I plead with you
that you would not take those away from
us because there is something that you
had to see going on today we are on the
precipice and we are not the
minority if we continue to get our
rights taken away it will lead you to
another civil war and that terrifies me
so please please do what's right and
stand up for our freedoms today thank
you thank
you a Jim Gil present from
Hollis and following him Kate Smith of
Chichester my name is Jim Gil I'm a
resident of Hollis New Hampshire and I
gotta say I love the New Hampshire
legislature third largest legislative
body in the world India US Congress New
Hampshire love it you all make $100 a
year you're here serving because you're
true Patriots you love your state you
love your country otherwise you wouldn't
be working for free and going through
all sorts of grief so I thank you for
that I'm here to support House Bill
255 based on principle and
practicality the principle is if I were
sitting in your seat as a State Rep
representing all of my con constituents
I took an oath to to defend and support
protect the
Constitution and the
Constitution is protective of majority
rights and majority rule as well as
minority rights the Bill of Rights was
added after the Constitution because
people Geniuses were very concerned that
Minority Rights weren't protected so if
we quickly look at the vaccinations the
estimated number here in New Hampshire
is about 64% based on John's Hopkins
that's a clear majority they were able
to go out and and take care of
themselves and I was thrilled and happy
for them to go out and get vacinated and
have it quick and accessible and
everything else I supported their choice
and their
decision as part of the majority
rule as far as minority
rights you have roughly
36% of your
constituents that have decided and
chosen not to be
vaccinated so if you're going to do your
constitutional do Duty and represent all
of your constituents you are going to
protect your minority rights as a matter
of
principle in taking that over both to
the Constitution that's where the
principle comes in protect your minority
populations and their rights as a matter
of Duty the second thing is
practicality is for all those who chose
to get
vaccinated we have new evidence new
information leads to new
conclusions Dr fouchi and the CDC and
FDA have FDA have recently released new
information in the last couple weeks
that was never known for number one is
when you get vaccinated it begins to wne
in roughly 4 and a half to 6 months so
for the majority rights who want to be
vaccinated they know they've got a path
to go down of repeated vaccination and
they're free to do that okay the second
thing is
that the CDC changed their definition of
immunity in the last couple weeks it no
longer means that you won't transmit the
virus or and that you won't get sick the
new definition of immunity is that you
won't be you can still transmit the
virus after vaccination and you can
still get sick the new definition is you
won't be as sick or die so they've
changed that that that what does that
mean for for minorities rights right the
bottom line is is that there's nothing
more you can do to protect the majority
everybody who's opposed to this bill is
basically trying to provide additional
insurance that you can't do sir if
somebody just one last second is and the
other thing is people with natural
immunity never one bit OFA evidence that
theyve transmitted it to a vaccinated
person so than ensure that you're going
to project majority rights because you
can't keep the vaccinated from
transmitting and infecting each other
and the last thing I want to just say
real I'm sorry sir I I've given you a
lot of time over Linda Johnson Lindon
Johnson said Kate Smith basically that
would be me yeah
okay and following her would be Veronica
Noble so I speak to the bill HB 255 and
ask that you support it and I'm a
healthcare worker so I'm going to lead
you down a little pathway my name is
Katherine Smith and I'm a registered
nurse Who as a BSN this would mean that
I have a bachelor's degree in the
science of nursing I've been employed in
the healthcare industry for the last 20
years and during this time I've
witnessed the encroachment of
vaccinations into my life as a
healthcare worker in 1998 I had to have
several vaccinations as a nursing
student and once I started working the
flu season shot the seasonal flu shot
was optional then around 2010 I had to
wear a small dot on my badge that meant
that I had a flu shot if I did not want
the flu shot I had to wear a mask most
recently in 2018 if I did not have a flu
shot and I did not have an exemption I
could not work for the flu season now in
2021 I'm not able to work unless I have
an exemption wear a mask and suffer
nasal swab penetration and to my nasal
cavity one to two times a week and if we
look at what is really happening around
the country and around the globe soon I
will not be able to participate in Civil
Society if I do not have a
vaccination if I were currently living
in some parts of the world including
Australia Austria or Israel I would Beni
Deni the freedom to travel outside of my
home except for essential
purposes so I ask you to take a step
back and examine how we have allowed
this Insidious assault on our freedom in
the name of Public Health to become
normalized and thus placing Us in the
position we find ourselves today
personally I see the bigger picture is
why are we being forced to take a repeat
injection for something that has a very
short shelf life in the human body we
are a society that has been willing to
accept the risk of harm for the greater
good when it comes to polio hepatitis
measles Ms rebella Etc these attenuated
vaccinations last our lifetime but now
we have new mRNA technology that affects
our cells and apparently it doesn't
last more importantly why are we slowly
being overtaken by corporations that
benefit in the form of enormous profits
from our compliance these profits which
also allow these corporations absolute
power over our education systems our
health care institutions and our policy
makers in the form of lobbyists and and
financial benefits for our state in the
form of Grants payouts Etc you know how
it works and you know exactly what I'm
talking about for me I have personally
resigned my position as a healthcare
worker as I was told that I must take
the vaccination or have an approved
religious exemption plus submit to the
naval nasal testing my employeer has
been completely transparent in their
policy related to the federal mandates
and the FDA approved vaccinations the
moment the president stated that
Medicare reimbursement rates will be
denied to Health Care Facilities if they
have unvaccinated
staff this alone should give pause that
an insurance carrier can deny payment to
a service provider which customers have
paid for under a condition that was not
part of the original contract is
astonishing to me as a hospice nurse the
loss of my skill set in the practice of
Community Health is
unmeasurable we often talk about a
nursing shortage as it relates to the
hospital set setting but Hare nursing is
a form of a silent suffrage by its own
right what most what most fail to
recognize is that when we as nurses go
to see patients in the community one of
the main objectives from the vantage
point of the insurance payer is to
prevent
rehospitalization keeping the overall
cost forication care low in fact
insurance reimbursements has dis
factored into their formula for payments
of quality Care thank you ma'am I'm
going to
finish please quickly if a patient
returns to the hospital within 30 days
of discharge then the overall payment to
the hospital in the Visiting Nurse
Association is reduced due to the poor
patient
outcome as a hospice nurse the financial
implications for Health Care savings are
even greater because hospitals are not
facilities where patients go to die this
is not profitable for them hospitals
benefit from acute care testing
diagnosis and treatment not care and
comfort ma'am thank you very much for
your
time is there a Veron Noble
here and then Tammy Schultz of
marac hi thank you committee members for
allowing us the chance to speak today um
by way of introduction my name is
Veronica Noble and I'm an ER nurse I'm
also here with my colleague and friend
Natalie who is an ER and iceu nurse um a
lot of great points have been made today
but I'm going to speak to what I know
and every day and that's what's on the
front lines um as a Frontline healthcare
worker I support this amendment to HB
255 as a Frontline healthcare worker I
am concerned for the structure of the
Health Care
System um just yesterday in reer we had
two deaths not to covid-19 but because
we are boarding as many inpatients in
our as the floor is upstairs in our
hospital and people are not receiving
the proper care they deserve this is not
due to the lack of beds available in my
hospital um and other hospitals but to
the lack of staff to care for these
patients since the start of covid over a
half million nurses have quit their jobs
and that's just nurses not ancillary
staff that are crucial to the role in
healthcare Health Care Systems are
hemorrhaging staff and truly what do we
expect to happen if more are
fired who is going to take care of you
if you need health
care truly please consider that
question this mandate will only add
insult to
injury and as a Frontline healthcare
worker I am
fearful that more people are going to
die and not from
Co but because there's not going to be
enough staff to take care of them thank
you thank
you is there is there Tammy
Schultz um I have a card for a maybe a
GC Baker or bird there's no Address
given I'm sorry your name my name is
Tammy Schulz okay I'm sorry please
proceed okay thank you um I'm a nurse
I've been a nurse for about 17 years uh
went back to school about nine years ago
for anesthesia so I'm now a certified
registered nurse an athetist
H let's see I'm just going to start out
reiterating that these
vaccines do not prevent transmission
we can't say that
enough and that is what all of the
hospitals are basing their mandates
around that's what
CMS has based their mandates around we
we have to protect our patients we must
protect our patients it's your duty as a
health care provider to protect our
patients even if we take the vaccine
it's not going to accomplish that stated
goal
furthermore I will go off on a little
bit of the science on the vaccines I've
done so much
research just wouldn't even believe how
much but I will read this this is from a
scientific
article about why these these vaccines
should not be mandated imperfect
vaccination title can enhance the
transmission of Highly virulent
pathogens vac enes that keep hosts alive
like these but still allow transmission
could thus allow very virulent strains
to circulate in a
population these types of an of V
of vaccines enhance the fitness of more
virulent
strains our data show that anti- disease
vaccines that do not prevent
transmission can create conditions that
promote the emergence of pathogen
strains that cause more severe
disease in unvaccinated hosts should
also go back and look at the reason why
we have never up to this point had a
successful Corona virus
vaccine look up anti- antibody dependent
enhancement or vaccine enhancement
because and the vaccinated you will get
a much more um stronger effect worse
outcome so I am afraid for the
vaccinated I do care for them but I am
afraid for
them I had planned on talking about all
the sacrifices that I had made to get
through anesthesia school but I'm here
with some of my
colleagues they all have different job
titles we have all made sacrifices
obtaining the educational standards that
we are achievements many of us with kids
some of us are the primary income
earners for our
families religious exemptions some of us
just want to let you know some of us put
in religious exemptions for the flu
vaccine those were approved put in the
same letters same hospital for Co not
approved thank you ma'am thank you
I have a a card for a a looks like a GC
Baker or last name begins with a b um
there's no Address
given uh how about
Barbara uh f l o CN maybe from
stratum is there a Leah
from
Tilton hello my name is Leah Ley I am a
nurse in
Manchester um and I speak in favor of
this amendment um if you would permit me
I'd like to read a letter that I wrote
in response to my company's um vaccine
mandate that they made late in
October
in October I sat in the piku at tough's
Medical Center in Boston with my
18-year-old brother-in-law as he
received treatment for blood clots in
both lungs and Reed and recovered from a
procedure to remove a clot from his leg
according to his medical team his
medical condition is being recorded as a
complication from the covid-19 vaccine
today the H today which was the
following day after that visit the
hospital where I work informed me that I
must get the covid-19 vaccine or lose my
job I'm a bachelor's educated registered
nurse with six years of nursing
experience a mother of two young boys a
cancer survivor and recently Co
recovered I depend on my job to provide
health insurance for myself and my
family according to um this policy I
have until November 19th to receive my
first shot um and failure to comply will
result in voluntary resignation ending
both my career and my family's health
insurance immediately on November 29th I
undergo my second biopsy this year to
make sure that my cancer has not
returned I now face the choice of
getting the vaccine which I feel poses
more risk than benefit for me or losing
my career in health insurance without
health insurance I cannot afford
semiannual biopsies as a nurse when I
enter a patient's room to give them
their medication it is part of my
responsibility to educate the patient
about the medication that I'm about to
give them including what it does and why
it was prescribed the patient then
decides whether or not they want to take
that medication I cannot force them if I
do what considered assault I make the
medication available I educate my
patients but most importantly I respect
their right to
refuse in the past we as a society have
not valued the right of refusal and
instead have forced people to undergo
medical procedures without consent for
the good of society we medical
professionals look back on those eras
with horror but right now hospitals in
Southern New Hampshire and across the
state are removing the right to refuse
quote for the good of the community
stating that all staff must be
vaccinated or lose their livelihood
somehow continuously short staffed
hospitals believe that patients will be
safer with less nurses to care for them
than for a double masked unvaccinated
experienced nurse with natural
antibodies to be at their
bedside hos
um Hospital leadership stood together to
U mandate this vaccine when they should
have been standing together for the
medical freedom of their employees one
of the speakers earlier referenced the
nurburg code which is the foundation of
our ethics but I would like to read one
sentence from that that defines what
consent
is this means that the person involved
should have the legal capacity to give
consent should be so situated as to be
able to exercise the free Power of
Choice without the intervention of any
element of force fraud deceit duress
overreaching or ulterior form of
constraint or coercion I believe that
losing my job if I don't do this is coer
version thank you for your time thank
you um is there a Lori blanger from pen
Brook hello hello I'm Lori um I work as
an LNA I've been doing that for about
five years in a nursing home and I also
work as a par professional for an
elementary school for 23 years and I
feel like both of my jobs are at risk so
I'm in favor of this
amendment um I do not want to lose my
jobs due to the vaccine
mandate um please know how important it
is to pass this today so that we don't
suffer more um economy loss job loss um
I know that we're already short teachers
and we're short lnas and nurses I don't
want to see it get any worse I can see
firsthand how that is for the residents
of the nursing home and for the kids
so I plead please pass this amendment
thank you thank you is there a West
Chapman is
um Paul paen Johnson
maybe um you not put some address on
your card I didn't put my address I live
in New Hampshire Paula Johnson from
Nashville New Hampshire Nashville okay
yes thank you for allowing me to speak
today as I sit and listen all day long
to all the people that are pleading
pleading for our constitutional rights
here please don't put these mandates
through I am support of HB 255 and its
Amendment but why should we the citizens
of this state and citizens of this
country ever have to sit and plead with
our election Ed officials God help us
all if this is what this country is
coming to I can't believe this I had to
voluntarily well I didn't resign my
company resigned me over a mask because
of a disability I cannot wear I have
been discriminated up and down because
of a mask because I cannot wear it
because I can't breathe because of
health issues and yet this chamber was
filled this morning I was here twice
last week
testifying and we the people and I
talked about our forefathers up there
they're the ones who gave us our Liberty
they're the ones who set the stage and
over a vaccine that's going to do
nothing it's going to injure people the
fear of this why in God's name and I'm
saying God I could be arrested for that
cuz you can't say Amen in this state
anymore I
guess but I just I got some
information from people here today that
um it it's really sad sooo to parents
get covid vaccines for your kids ASAP
I'm going to ask this body here when did
he get his license to prescribe treat or
diagnose anybody to get a vaccine ma'am
ma'am uh it's I can't talk about this
because this is what we're talking about
for schools this the kids for schools
and this is what the whole talk about
the bill I am talking because it talks
about schools I couldn't even go into
the hospital get a test because I
couldn't wear a mask so this is what
it's coming down to if you can't go to
the hospital and you can't wear a mask
what's going to happen when they tell
you you have to get the jab you're going
to be denied treatment and they get
Federal funding and state funding so
what's going to happen then so I'm not
going to I'm now don't have a job how
many of people in here came in and
testified today are losing their job
jobs healthc care industry but you know
what it's disgraceful when you see the
lobbyists on that side and they're
talking about I have nothing against
refugees I don't have a problem the bill
it is has to do with the bill because
the lobbyists talked about healthc care
right well that's not addressing the
bill um it is addressing the bill
because it is lobbyist they don't want
they want everybody to be
vaccinated we're talking about the bill
please if you have any further comments
on the bill we'd like to hear
them yeah
know you know it's it's you only you
allow lobbyists to talk about whatever
they want to okay let's talk about these
19-year-old football players died
17-year-old football player di all of a
sudden all these students all these kids
are dying out of nowhere
Faith you know this is terrible kids
that coming for our kids in school
that's the that's the truth about it
with this Bill thank you very much for
your com you know shut everybody down
when they tell the truth these lobbyists
who help you all I
believe I believe that is the uh last
card that we have um so I thank
everybody for their attendance and their
uh their comments today um that will end
our public hearing we will take a break
and uh get ready for our executive
session on Two
[Music]
Bills okay this uh hearing is adjourned
uh we were we're going to reformat this
area so we can have an executive session
we're going to ask that any public that
remain would you please remain in
sections one or section two we're going
to have to set this up so that we must
do the executive session in this room as
it was scheduled in the calendar so we
are going to be sitting at the tables on
this end to my left going around about
halfway and then the other part of the
committee can be sitting in the chairs
facing uh the the folks which are here
so we're not in a
semicircle do you understand what I'm
saying representative Cornell
representative lad could you would you
tell everyone here so they just
understand what this means like if this
is passed what this means actually like
dating like time frame that this would
actually take effect this does not take
effect immediately people need to
understand that still of course it's
it's
not it's not been acted upon what we do
at the ex executive session we DEC
decide whether we're going to move it
forward or we're going to kill it or
we're going to send it to inter room
study the bill if it moves forward has
to then be sent to the house floor for
Action there the house floor as a total
body all 400 of us correct few short
because we are a few short in the house
right now will act upon that if it's an
ought to pass or an not to pass as
amended it is sent to the Senate corre
the Senate will do the same thing with
that bill that we are doing right here
they will have hearings on the bill they
will look at you know any amendments
that they want if they am if they vote
ought to pass as amended it comes back
to us with a it's a it's been an amended
bill so we go to a committee of
conference which we in fact would all
sit you know there' be a a confere group
put together we would look at that and
see see if we can come to compromise on
that so there are a lot of and then if
it comes back and it's approved and it
would come back to this body because it
is a house bill it would finally come
back here and then over there and and
and then on to the governor if it makes
it far so that's where we stand okay and
I understand that I understand that
whole process I think a lot of people
here I would have loved that for them to
have all heard that especially when this
was packed the way to get this done
immediately just so everybody needs to
know is the governor can convene the
legislature to get this done immediately
because if not we're looking at what
possibly March
April we we we I you can ask that
question others we have a busy agenda in
front of us right now okay this is not
an individual resolution of the house it
is a house bill it must go through all
the
steps going toose so thank you very much
for coming today I appreciate thank you
for answering that
questions to be quick as an
emergency no more lives need to be lost
understood because I
don't
not
people I was at the Museum in Manchester
New Hampshire and they were put
in
children how many more
lives anybody not shut you down should
be ashamed of
themselves
okay um can everybody hear me that's on
the executive
committee no hands are up so fine so
we're going to have to really adjust our
you know recognition rules here a little
bit uh looking around the corner you're
standing up uh representative Hill but I
couldn't see if you were sitting down so
that might be a good thing
um but uh if if during our executive
session if anybody cares to speak would
you just please put your hand up or or
you know I'll try to rec you I can't see
folks sitting behind me
here okay so um we're going to go ahead
with this executive session and the
first uh order of business will be to
address um HB
255 um the amendment that we've been
discussing ing today but the I guess the
very first thing I want to do is welcome
any substitutes to our
committee and um we have the subs uh
around the table here let's see we
have Tim yeah does everybody here know
Tim and and
Fred yeah and where else do we have
something yeah yeah Greg Hill
and Erica and then uh represent luno do
you have the the sub
which yeah Dave there's
David okay so you have two so with that
we have six people which are Subs on our
committee today welcome so the first
order of business we're going to open up
this exe executive session for HB
255 and I'm going to handle hand over
the gap to
yes yes
yes at at this point in time uh there
has been a communication that the
membership on this committee is now uh
19 members uh 10 Republicans and nine
Democrats and uh representative Allard
has been placed on Fish and
Game
I I think that your your your leadership
can be talking with the speaker's office
on that I was not upstairs and I was not
part of that
discussion when that decision was made
so um I think what we need to do is move
on with our agenda which we have in
front of us um you know the occurrence
that just has occurred uh I would
suggest that you work with the
leadership of your party to talk with
leadership of the of the Republican
Party
okay thank thank you for com comments
but we're we're going to move on with
our agenda that we have in front of us
right now so the first uh point of uh
that we're going to discuss today is HB
255 as I announced earlier and I'm going
to hand the gavl over to representative
cordelli thank you I
would yes thank you uh Mr uh chair I
would like to move off to pass on
Amendment 2239
H okay so we have an amendment on the
table uh for passage OTP
2239 this is the amendment which we've
uh been discussing all day
uh due to the fact we have discussed it
I presented it I've already presented my
points and my position and rationale and
intent for it uh I I'm not going to add
anything further to the
discussion representative
cordelli are you handing the gavel back
to me now
okay
yes
I make one comment I think in your
statement the opening of the public
hearing you mentioned the
1937 addressing defend
claim of religious exemption and the
court said it is for the
legisl not for him defendant or for us
to DET policy evolve in
health
I
Amendment with our role as the
legislative body
in
this
legislation thank you further discussion
representative
Porter
is that a question of anybody on the on
the
committee is anybody that want to
respond to
that pardon me representative
B
yeah y further
discussion represent
luno this this amendment is related
directly to uh New Hampshire employers
mandates by New Hampshire employers uh I
don't believe a church is an
employer oh on line
16 or religious entity yes so then it
would be applicable to a religious
entity
yeah Is there further disc yes represent
cordelli my belie is that in the first
section simply requiring there to be
exemptions provided for the reason of
personal conscience religious belief or
medical reasons as inin
yes thank you Mr chair until recently
the only mandated vaccinations have been
for school children and our law provides
for exemptions for those school children
um the only place that had mandated them
and this provides
comping rece to an individuals because
of further discussion yes representative
Porter or
woodcock
the the bill would go in effect what uh
upon its passage and supposing that the
passage may occur sometime in
summer July August be signed in the law
and that be upon passage uh there's no
way that if a person has a vaccination
you can make undo that so uh it would
move forward with what has been done but
from that point forward this would be
the law or law of this
state
yes
a lot of ifs uh in there
um
yes okay
yeah
ran
luno
IND
allow
represent
Hill
yeah it's not saying there was nothing
in here about protection by the way um
it only says that no entity in New
Hampshire shall compel so it's just
telling that you that you can't
require as a matter of Entry or or um
anyone who objects to having a being
vaccinated Mr
chair just ask all the members to speak
up I got a complaint nobody can hear
anything we're saying on the YouTube
stream which is still going on so you
need to speak nice and
loud yeah just when if you're speaking
make sure you have your mic
on
just you
this mention to all here that we are
being live Streed so if mics are on
we're going to have one mic cutting in
on another mic and causing
problem
e
so moving on with the executive session
here representa Hill were you responding
to a
question or uh on the on the dealing
with the with the religious
entity you know there there was there
was a question that came as religious
entity part of this yes it is and it'd
be the person would have the ability to
based upon one of those four areas noted
above to um you know uh not to have to
get the
vaccination right so as I as I see
churches um but listed as religious
entity as the as the definition of
entity um and then looking at
Section 1 one I guess it would say no
entity in New Hampshire meaning that
church shall compel receipt of a
covid-19 vaccine by any individual who
objects so it absolutely would it it has
nothing to do with protection it has it
doesn't mention the word protection in
here it only simply says that the church
couldn't compel someone who objects to
um taking a vaccination or having the
vaccination to uh be restricted from
coming into that church I would think
yeah yes repr no
[Music]
microphone it's not
working makes me feel
better it's like Mr microphone I think
you the um I I used the word protection
because I thought it was very clear from
the testimony today that um uh that
stopping transmission means stopping the
virus and the vaccine is the best way to
do this um we heard a lot about
transmission and how even with a vaccine
um you can be a transmitter but the more
people that are vaccinated means
ultimately the virus goes goes away goes
down and goes away and is the best way
to do this so that's what I was
referring to by protection I totally
understand representative Hill that the
bill does not use the word um uh
protection in it but frankly I'm very
surprised that uh during a public
hearing on this amendment that this non-
gerine amendment that clearly affects
houses of worship that we didn't have
anybody from any dasis um or or any
member of the clergy uh uh weighing in
on their ability or in fact if if this
were to become law the Mandate that
would come down on religious
organizations um that would take away
any ability to um to set up a protocol
that they could use to protect their
their parishioners during in-person
worship I'm really surprised that that
with nearly what did we clock in at five
hours pretty
close 5 hours worth of testimony that
there was not a single member of the
clergy um uh or any dases to uh to to to
either speak in support or uh or Express
concerns about this uh about
this in response um we have gone now a
year and a half a year and a half with
dealing with
covid and we have also had protocols
established by various organizations
either wear a mask sit apart from each
other you go to this food store your's
patches in the floor which tell you six
feet apart those are those uh procedures
and Protocols are not eliminated in this
bill we're talking simply that you can't
require a vaccination or a
vaccination uh can be objected to based
upon certain reasons that we have our
beliefs or opinions that we have in this
bill um so there are protocols which can
go forward and that uh uh we have not
objected to and we've seen as that's uh
been very successful in places like UNH
where they have a
90% immunity right now due to the fact
it's been done
voluntarily but now they're under the
gun to require that we have vaccinations
for all contractors and students that
are part of the contract s and all that
to have the vaccination in place or if
you don't you're going to lose possibly
300 million in na NASA
grants um I feel as um the that that
particular institution has done a real
great job with their protocols in place
be it in the dorms or on campus or in
and out of those dorms with that
procedure without having to mandate
vaccination
good
deal representative Sullivan by the way
um as I read this it seems like they
went way out of their way to try to
include all
entities um in fact it it even says at
the end any other entity um and as I
read it it seems as though parents would
not be able to require their children to
be
vaccinated parents I believe could be
considered an entity and it talks about
any individual could
object a kid is an
individual so a 10-year-old could say to
Mom and Dad I don't like shots I'm not
going to take
it you couldn't give that kid the shot
the way I read this
further discussion representative
cordelli thank you I I do not see uh
where it could be read into this
provision that uh anything about parents
being required uh or being considered as
entities um I think that uh that is a a
stretch a little too
far represent would
talk doesn't work um I just want to be
perfect clear if I understand the bill
so that means a smaller small M and pop
operation by employees they can't tell
their their gas station attendant that
he has to be
vaccinated a is that right A U something
like a nonprofit that has you know four
employees and 27 volunteers they can't
tell them that they have to be vac
any small business tells them they can't
they can't make the choice anymore if
they want how they can run the business
so this bill that you
authored uh indicates in that any small
business any business in the state
cannot do what they want to do by their
business plan is that what this means
correctly did I read that right I I
think
you're get to switch the right direction
here pardon me you have a wonderful one
up there um I I I I believe that the
small M and pop entity you're talking
about the small business has the
authority to put in place various
protocols however if the individual
that's working says they I I object
based upon my personal conscience my
religious belief um medical issues then
that person does not have to be
vaccinated in order for employment in
that small business so fall then so the
reality is any small business does not
have control over the small business
anymore staff wise because of
this the the small business has definite
control over the procedures and the and
the protocols they put in place whether
they put up a plastic seethrough Shield
or
under this bill right here the
individual has the right to object to a
vaccination
yes pardon
me the impact is that the individual
does not take that vaccination and is
working
well no no they have a right to make
protocols but you're talking about one
you're talking about one vaccination
reps in a
bomlo
EXC
excuse
representative Woodcock this is not
going to we're going to work through the
chair if we're going to
debate I had given the floor to
representative b representa b are
you representa
Tanner set
ups
kids and they requ the staff because of
children
areed they require their staff to have
vaccinations and we put
this they cannot
requ people have vaccinations
get test Tes in the
Mandate and can they still those
not Rick Mr
chairman thank you so again nothing in
this as I read this bill Nothing Stops a
business from creating a mandate what
happens is only when an individual takes
an affirmative action and says I want an
exemption which is what this says they
they have to request an exemption and
then they'll be granted the exemption
but even individuals granted the
exemption on the federal law under
threat law that's under federal law the
business has the right to ask for
accommodations given uh circumstances so
in the case of a hospital this was a a
federal law that was done based on a
nurse Who challenged a vaccination
requirement it went to the US Supreme
Court the decision was made that there
has to be a direct threat and a
correlation between there and if there
between the vaccination requirement and
the job function and if there was a
direct correlation between the direct
threat and the job function then the
business had the right to ask for an
accommodation and the accommodation had
to be reasonable similar to an ADA
requirement um and that is still the
current law is that if you're granted an
exemption you still have the business
still has the right to ask for
accommodation it may be that you have to
wear a mask you have to wear Shield it
may mean you have to wear a gown it may
mean that a nurse can't work in the
enology Ward and has to go to the
Podiatry Ward because of the compromised
immune systems of people those
accommodations are still allowed by
federal law that this law doesn't change
yet however it does require the
arbitrary as we heard today and some
testimony we had religious exemptions
granted F influenza vaccine but then
that same religious exemption was denied
for a covid vaccine so again I think
that the idea behind this it stops that
kind of arbitrary why are you religious
enough to be entitled to uh exemption
and and says that no the business must
now accept the exemption it doesn't mean
they don't they can't put appropriate
accommodations
in TV test I have to have vaccinations
for certain other things
that said a vaccination and I say I'm
aen obor I'm not going to do that um and
they say okay then they're not going to
hire me is that okay under this or is
that part of all of a sudden deal that
they they can't say that so again under
under the if I may Mr chair yes so again
my understanding under the direct threat
in accommodation language under the um
under that I forgot the title Eric I may
remember um but under that under that
title um they have to offer you an a
reasonable accommodation they can't say
absolutely no they can offer you
accommodation now you could choose not
to accept that accommodation and not
take the job but they can offer you the
accommodation if there is a reasonable
accommodation representative
Porter
I'm not Mr chair I I'm not familiar with
the I'm assuming that certain things
like Motor Carrier laws require certain
drug testing and yes they can say we're
not going to hire you because it's a
federal requirement for Motor Carrier
laws
employ have option sorry not us
okay this amendment doesn't talk about
that I said the federal law right this
amendment doesn't talk about
accommodations in any way shape or form
I'm just stating that under the federal
law under the direct thread argument so
again there has to be a correlation
between the job requirement and
otherwise and there has to be a direct
correlation between the job function and
the direct threat and then the
accommodation could be
requested cuz it's not in here it's I
can't answer the question because you're
not asking a question relative to the
law our job here is to look these things
and try to find out if they're going
water the answer is no it's not
unattended
consequence representa Leon you have a
hand
up okay representa
bone thank you
my my granddaughter is a oncology nurse
and a major hospit cancer hospital and
recognizing that hospital as the their
top oncology
nurse she will be the first one because
of her job as an oncology nurse and
knowing the Immunology problem with
patients and cancer gets her
shots that is why she became an oncology
nurse she knows the rules she knows what
will happen if she passes on covid or
something another vac or a flu or
whatnot so that's not an issue with most
most nurses or people that work in that
kind of job they know the issue and they
take care of the issue or if she didn't
want to take the co thing then she go
work in another hospital doing something
else but there's a shortage of nurses
everywhere and
every anything but she wanted to do
oncology and so she knows she has to do
those vaccines that's part of her job
and she knows it so she will not ask for
a an exemption because she know that's
not right thank you represent M do you
have your hand
up speaking loudly enough um but
um one of the things that stuck out to
me in some of the test testimony today
was uh what the representative from the
business and industry Association had to
say um and basically what he had to tell
us is that employers don't have the
power to ignore federal law um even if
this amendment passes so what this
amendment would do is it would set up a
lot of businesses in our state the ones
that have more than a 100 employees it
would set them up for a situation where
the state of New Hampshire would be
would be saying you can't do that the
federal government on the other hand is
saying You must do that um I have a
background in in Human Resources um and
uh one of the things that uh always
confounded us from a communication
standpoint uh was advising clients on
the differences between state and
federal law um but one of the things
that we all knew that we couldn't do uh
was just simply uh ignore the laws that
are there so there there are laws and
there are regulations uh in place uh
that will call uh for people uh for for
for uh for companies over uh 100 people
uh to uh to vaccinate their employees
and one of the things we'd be doing is
we would be putting those folks in into
a terrible
position the other thing that I think we
need to keep in mind as well is that um
uh because of the of the of the conflict
uh with what's going on at the federal
level um this in effect is a
nullification bill um this this this
actually would seek uh to nullify a
Federal
Regulation um the federal courts have
consistently over the years found
nullification laws to be
unconstitutional so I think that's
another thing that we need to keep in
mind
today
thanks represent
cordelli thank you uh I don't view it
that way um there is a stay on the uh
OSHA uh rules issued by the federal
appeals court um a number of States
including New Hampshire have filed a
suit um that generated this stay in the
appeals court I view this legislation as
supporting the state of New Hampshire in
their lawsuit and supporting the Court's
ruling uh the court of appeals ruling in
that stay and um I I think it will be
found um to be unconstitutional on the
part of uh the federal government and uh
the OSHA rules that are being
proposed Mr
chair go ahead so I want to speak
directly to that point so as some of you
know I chaired the house Bill 220
medical interventions and immunizations
committee which met in the last few
weeks and we issued our report last week
one of the people that testified
directly on the committee was the
Attorney General's office and it was
specifically we had a question around
the um supremacy clause what happens if
New Hampshire passes a law that is a
direct contradiction to the uh Federal
mandate what does that
mean the testimony given by the
Hampshire attorney general was that
given the current lawsuit that we have
if NE Hampshire passed a law such as
this that was uh that was in
contradiction to the federal mandate
that the um that would support the
Hampshire's position in the lawsuit and
be beneficial and that the courts would
look at the actions of the legislature
in light of the will of the state and
the will of the people of the state so
to answer your question while the the
the Attorney General's office was clear
and that they felt that passage of a law
supports n Hampshire's position in the
Federal Federal lawsuit against the
ocean mandates and the executive
orders further
discussion representative litfield thank
you Mr chair uh may I just ask you what
a question and then possibly a followup
if I could how many people signed in
today in favor of the amendment and how
many were opposed to it do we have that
information um yeah we do have is this
effective uh represent Court 2m or
around
2m yeah so on this right here I'm
reading that uh without looking at the
blue sheets those which were Pro were
110 and the con was four is that correct
that's the count on the blue sheet
pardon me this is the count on the blue
sheet now on testimony that was a little
slightly different
there it was
people testified
and
17 were
osed
opposed
yes excuse me sir I'm I apologize but I
was that okay you asked a question and
then I I'd asked if I could do a
followup this is that please thank you
thank you Mr chair um so I I'm am just
curious I feel as though kind of today
was a little surreal and me maybe I sat
in a different meeting than many other
people sat in because I saw a room full
of people many of which I would say at
least 90% they even went as far as to
bring their newborn babies in their
children um they cried they were shaking
they were scared for their lives
literally because they were afraid to
take this shot and the adverse side
effects that they may have um they were
also afraid for their livelihood their
financial Capital that they worked so
hard to build up so I understand that
I'm new to the education committee but
um but I think I missed something as far
as my job requirement is concerned
because I thought it was my job to honor
the wishes of the public and to
represent the people and I feel as
though today when I was sitting here I
heard loud and clear we want you to
support this
amendment thank you represent Cornell or
represent luno
then direct to
represent question and comments I think
it would so thank you very much um uh D
directed to uh representative
lichfield's question and and comments I
think it would also be important to
include the um the piles of
emails that we received over the last
week both in support and in opposition
to um uh uh to this amendment and then
then further um you know I think it's
also important to look back on um on
hearings that we've had uh on
controversial policy and particularly
how Bill 20 seems to um uh seems to ring
a bell where we I think had I don't even
remember the numbers numbers unlike
anything that's ever been seen in the
New Hampshire house thousands of people
in opposition to um to House Bill 20 I
think it may have been three or 4,000 in
in oppos to 400 to 400 so so apparently
in some instances when there's
overwhelming opposition uh that has not
um uh had um had any effect on um on the
majority's position on um on on on
public policy that affects Granite
Staters and I think you know finally
what I'd like to say along those along
these same lines Rick is that um you
know St Steve anan's um uh uh comments I
think were were very um uh important as
were were David ju's as well as so many
others but uh but what uh what what Dr
Anon said was um was the vast majority
of hospital employees in New Hampshire
support the vaccine requirement as they
know that is the best way to combat the
virus and keep people safe um that I
think is nearly verbatim to what what he
said I'll agree with you know yes you
can be vaccinated and still be a and
still transmit but the more people we
have vaccinated the less transmission
will happen we will keep people safe and
we will end this pandemic so for the
good of the people of New Hampshire
let's end this pandemic let's defeat
this amendment and let's let's move on
with with with more constructive
legislation for granite Staters thank
you further discussion represent
cordelli
thank you um what has been left out in
many places where there have been
mandates put into place uh is the
recognition that someone has recovered
from covid and has natural immunities
Which is far stronger than the vaccine
so this is recognized in this bill and I
think is extremely important we heard so
much talk about her
immunity a year ago but we never hear
about it now because it it's more uh we
have to get people vaccinated um and we
have to get boosters and everything else
which is fine you know if you want to
have a vaccine booster or take both
vaccine shots that's fine but there has
to be recognition that someone has
natural immun natural immunities because
they have recovered from covid people on
our committee um have uh indicated this
in the past so I think that is a a major
component of this legislation that is
being ignored in the public uh
realm um okay um thank you I think
there's one important issue that we do
need to recognize with this vaccine it
reduces but does not prevent
transmission of covid-19
it does not eliminate
transmission if people do not have the
right to object to the vaccination we
are violating informed consent um
informed consent when you go back to the
Declaration of Helsinki when you go back
to the nurmberg code you go back to the
fact that somebody cannot be compelled
to get a medical procedure against their
will if we had a vaccine that had a
perfect block of transmission this would
be one discussion but this does not
prevent transmission it simply minimizes
it so any any facility who is not
recognizing that even vaccinated people
can still spread covid is not doing
their best to protect the
people why we
[Music]
masks further discussion yes representa
Tanner people
going shot if I if I don't want to get a
shot I don't go to to the place to get
it and some of coming around sticking me
in the arm if I don't
want the question here is not whether I
can refuse or not because anybody can
refuse that's Prett
clear do but the idea is for public
health for
places I appreciate
that has to have it um I'm sure you know
people that work at nursing homes ought
to recognize that they ought to have it
but they G not all of them are and so I
think this
if you to be employ as asur onology or
at
AIDS still
chy cancer or you want to be in Clos
area where you're working really close
and that particular employ feels that he
does not she does not want um the co vac
the co virus wipe out sta or her staff
and wants to re or the government
decides the federal government decides
that they're going to full cont I don't
think it's our place to do this I also
think this is a non Amendment this the
four terms I've in the house this is the
first time that something's in non and
it's been
voted I
totally
unfortunate false to the people that
came today that we're going to take a
magic vote here and all of a sudden
they're going to get their jobs back
they're going to be able to be a conf
objetive um that going to be better and
I heard the discussion about trying to
tell them how bills how bills become
laws and um it's clear to me they didn't
fully understand that it may be
next
spring before this actually gets as a
law and then it's probably going to go
through court cases as well so I I feel
bad for the vast majority of the people
that as representative Litchfield said I
felt too when they cried or when they
were talking about how it's going to
affect the personal life I feel sorry
about that um it's hard to hard to
ignore that but I think we're also
waving this lollipop front of it's not
really
there is there any further input here
we're getting close to having to act on
this
amendment okay
further no not seeing any uh
representative Shaw would you please
call the motion it's a motion to on
ought to pass on the
amendment yes this is uh ought to pass
on amend ment
H representative cordelli yes
representative B
yes representative duet yes
representative Lon yes representative
Hobson representative
Hill yes representative sodi yes
representative Lang yes representative
Lichfield yes representative luno no
representative muse
no representative Shaw yes
representative Corell no representative
Tanner no representative Ellison no
representative Sullivan no
representative Woodcock no
representative Porter
no it's
10 gota get me oh lad represent lad yes
11 I'm sorry 11
eight uh would you please uh take the
mic so I can introduce the next
motion yes I would like to uh call on uh
representative uh lad for a motion
thank you very much uh I'd like to move
ought to pass as amended on HB
255 is there a second representative
B okay now we have the full bill in
front of us as amended further
discussion Madam chair would you please
clerk would you please call it's late
thank you I don't want to be the
chair bad enough being the clerk
today
um okay got this all
straight um this is a to pass as
amended on House Bill
255 representative cordelli
yes representative B
yes representative ducet yes
representative Lyon yes representative
Hobson yes representative Hill yes
representative sodi yes representative
Lang yes representative Lichfield yes
Representative luno no representative
muse no representative Shaw yes
representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Ellison no representative
Sullivan no representative Woodcock no
representative Porter
no 11 eight uh representative lad
yes you're so easy to
forget that's
all the 14th year is the charm I
know so the uh HB 255 as
amended passes OTP will there be a
Minority Report yes
yes
okay no it's due tomorrow um I'm
assuming that who's going to write that
um margerie you want to write it
together okay yeah we'll write it
together it'll be from it's coming from
it'll come from me
luno okay uh we have one more bill today
to deal with and this would conclude
after this one all the bills which have
been retained by this committee all 17
of them um so the bill which we're going
to take up right now is HB
suppos to
now can I have a copy of it I don't know
where mine
is it's in here
somewhere good
grief gave two
you
yeah I think I left mine up
here
somewhere does everybody have a copy of
the new
amendment
that see
now we're talking now the
that
okay I have a
question there's an
extra did you move it and B second it
who
did on which one this one no we haven't
we haven't done
anything okay
HB 607 is a bill that deals with uh
local education Freedom
accounts it's not the same Freedom
accounts that was passed last year in
hb2 this is a different proposal as the
committee has discussed but we have six
people which are new to this committee
uh so just to inform you on that um
representa cordelli I recognize you for
a motion thank you I
would
pass
am2 and we have a SE second from
representative bone um further discuss
yes representa Porter
representative thank you for letting me
express myself on this I spent the
weekend reading over the original
Amendment you just handed me another
amendment so let me finish yeah what I
found in the original Amendment were
issues that I thought deserve a hearing
and chance my questions to be answered I
don't even see
the sponsor of the original build here
to answer my questions I'm really
concerned about at 4:30 or 41 in the
afternoon after the day that we that a
new amendment being introduced to us
that we haven't had a chance to look
over Bill sponsor is not here to answer
our questions and this is major major
policy change and it's going to have a
direct negative impct
on okay represent Porter
I I think we we hear you where you're
going uh we have a motion on the table
and it's been a second now we're open to
discussion I would ask representa
cordelli to go through this new
Amendment that's been developed by
representative rille and to point out
those areas which are changes that we're
seeing as quote new and uh in reflection
to in in in
reference to the original bill or the
amendment which we had the last
week uh that we all looked at those are
two different things very different
things the original bill and the not the
original bill but there was an amendment
prior to this which was dated back was
it the 9th correct but you also said
changes well I'm talking about taking
this and contrasting it to the amendment
which was discussed by us on the 9th we
didn't discuss it it was handed out or
handed out or handed out or handed out
well at any rate would you said you
hadn't even received
it before until minutes before you
handed it out yeah okay that's correct I
stand corrected on that so uh represent
cordelli would you please explain this
Amendment state your point of
order
I also that we have a bill come to our
committee
theit okay I hear your point of order
represent l
actually the point of order is out of
order in that fact that any member can
submit an amendment the committee can
choose to adopt it or not but it can
come from any House member on a house
bill it has to be introduced by it just
has to be introduced by a Committee
Member and it has been introduced by
representative
cordelli representa cordelli would you
please explain the
amendment thank you um and uh I did work
on this with representative
verville um the only change um in what
you've just been handed um is in the
eligibility of the student section on
lines 17 through
19 the change here basically uh removes
the uh family income limit for
eligibility of
300% there is now uh no uh family income
restriction uh on
eligibility um otherwise there is no
change um in this amendment from what
you handed out uh last uh
week
um page one I'm sorry page
one
do you want me to
yeah we're never going to get through
this today this is not
it's
45 okay I have a motion on the table I
understand
that it's now 4
17 some of the folks that are here have
meetings that they have to be at uh
shortly the only other option we have
right now and hearing your your conc
concern representative
Porter you're not having seen this
amendment um even though I know the
amendment has very few changes in it
from what was handed out I understand
your position we do have a deadline
which we're having to function by that's
means to by September not September it
is late uh by November 18th we have to
be concluding our work on all these
retained bills this is one retain bill
which we got to act
on we can if we want to um re recess
this
meeting how much notice time do we have
to put out in the calendar to do that is
it 24 hours so that we're missing
tomorrow
totally and that tomorrow is what the
17th the last day to report out I
believe is the
18th so we could come back on the 18th
and Report out that
morning but uh we move into study this
because this is this is a big change
from the education Freedom accounts bill
that passed in the budget this is a big
change to Local School Districts it's
something that we really need to look at
it just can't be cable to let this go
through on a okay the question I'm
putting out there right now is not the
rationale for doing but are we going to
decide to put off any discussion on
further discussion action on this until
the morning of the 18th so so Rick I
think what Marie
suggested talk about for two
seconds
I think go ahead Bron
Shaw uh on I'm
on I think it makes
sense um to uh refer to interim study
only
because of the fact that the education
freedom
accounts uh have just barely got going
this
year and if this goes out now it means
it gets acted on this session and they
they haven't even had a year to get
going on this I think it would be make
much more sense to have this be an
interim study and then uh because the
changes
are
drastic okay we're we're in a discussion
phase there is a a motion on the
table um representative uh Hill I know
you have your hand up um th this bill
put it back down uh this bill um is a a
bill that's not the same as the freedom
accounts that we passed through by way
of hb2 this previous year those
education Freedom that past education
Freedom account was one which is not a
option of the school board to decide
upon this is a bill which in order to
become law or to become or to be used
must be approved by a 60% vote of your
local school board unlike the education
Freedom account bills dist School
District yes School scho District School
Board School District your your school
district that's correct not the board
but the the district itself at the
annual meeting so it's much different
than the saving or the freedom accounts
which we've had we in
hb2 so
um I I'm I'm of the opinion that there
is Merit to our further discussing that
here this evening and possibly taking
some action on it
rep or I see our our clerk here do you
have are you ready to close shop up no
no good clocks never change
around we're always open to a chat so
represent cordelli would you just take
on any discussion which we have right
here no action until I get back
please
um
that's um some further information that
might help you um uh number one this is
enabling
legislation um as was discussed it
requires a school district vote in order
to proceed a 60% uh super majority
um back back that was
quick to answer your
question we need more time if we're
going to put this thing off for let's
see to act on 18th we can't do it we
need the 48 hours and we don't have it
and so we need to act upon this today
and so this committee will continue and
we will take action on 607 this
afternoon
so with that I would like to have the
motion
go discussion on the motion that's on
the table
uh thank you um a few Basics with this
legislation as I said um it's enabling
legislation um nothing happens unless
the districts vote for it um with a 60%
super majority or or they can in the
future resend it with a
60% uh majority of the district voting
as
well this involves local dollars there
are no State dollars involved the
district keeps All State
funds there's no change in that
regard actually as we'll talk about this
is a win-win for the school
districts um
the um excuse me
um if um the uh
student in this
program remains a student of the school
district the resident School District
they are not an EFA student as with the
state uh
program that is why uh the state funds
continue to go
to the school district there's no change
in
that the local dollars um are calculated
um based on the uh budget of the school
district uh special ed dollars are not
involved all special ed dollars uh
remain with the
district and any student with
disabilities who takes one of these
accounts would continue to get their
services from the uh resident School
District much in the same way that a
student leaves their resident District
to go to a charter school they still get
their services from that Resident School
District
um so maybe this is the time um as we go
through the bill um chairman lad if
that's your desire it is my desire and I
think what we ought to do is capture the
change which occurs in the new Amendment
which I believe is only
one uh change that's different than the
amendment which was handed out
previously at our last meeting at the
end of that meeting so if you know that
one change then uh and you know
everything else that's in it based upon
the amendment which was handed out at
that time so representative cordelli
would you please explain the change
which occurs on page one of that
Amendment and it's dealing with the
eligibility of a
student yes that is the uh only change
in that section on page one in that um
the uh family income um eligibility uh
cap of 300% of federal poverty um is
removed so there is no family income cap
on this uh program session can I call
you
back um great
thanks if if you're looking
for um places in this bill um that we
just touched
on um the town vote requirement is um on
the bottom of page
nine um it details the town vote and the
language for the warrant article U is on
page P 10 Roman 2 U point of
order representative um uh just um one
of the things that the clerk had
explained to me uh earlier today was
that the new website has uh amendments
online is this amendment available
online yeah well I brought it up as a
point of
order oh well point of information point
of
information uh I have no
idea not point of order and that
question can be asked after
representative cordelli has finished his
presentation thank
you
um let's see um in terms of we were just
talking about special
education um on page four Roman numeral
three it details that um the uh
student would continue to get their
special education services uh from the
local school district that is on R in
Roman
three um I think one of
the uh main things that uh we should
talk about is on the top of page
seven um and that is um how the um
amount to go into the child's uh EFA
account um is determined and if I might
Mr chairman I have some samples that I
could hand out to help us through that
discussion yes
hand
to
you're going through and discussing
more likely the 80% which I think we
just
addressed the uh
300% um the 300% uh eligibility which we
had in this on page one has been taken
out so there is no level
of fin
at okay I'm just going through page one
there's nothing else there on page one
okay that has been
changed
think special that's not there I don't
believe there was any other changes made
on page
two there the only change made in this
was on page one comparing previous
Amendment right page three was the same
issue nothing changed
there from that previous Amendment you
might see some line changes due to the
fact there was that change on page
one and the same thing for page
four uh although representative cordelli
did mention on page
four and I'm looking
at the
old
that expain the special
ed component that they would be eligible
for special ed services in this
EA
Loca okay represent pelli would you then
go on and explain the rest of the bill
so try to catch it
up thank you Mr chairman um I I hope you
have two two handouts
um that um we'll use in looking at the
uh how the funding is arrived
at um the first one uh has four examples
on it Conway Deerfield New fields and
rumney um and these are the uh
calculations for determining uh the EFA
account for the child um it basically
involves the um local uh budget the
current Appropriations within the uh
District uh
we subract out the special
fing to arrive at what the local nonsp
special ed funding is we multiply that
by 80% because
20% of the local funding stays with the
district in addition to all the state
and federal
funding um we then divide that by the uh
uh attendance to rece to determine the
amount of the per puple
Grant um those are four towns that we
went through that calculation with um
with uh the Department of
Education and the other sheet that I
handed out is a more detailed uh
explanation of that calculation for uh
the Conway School District in that it
shows um where this information comes
from and it's basically the doe2 every
District um is required to uh report
this information to the Department of
Education so it's readily available
information to the department and also
to excuse me to the district and also to
the department um and that'll help the
department in monitoring the
program
um so this Conway example steps you
through that and shows for each item
in the calculation where it um that
information is obtained from on the doe
25 both in terms of the special ed
funding um the state and federal aid for
special education you'll see that on
page three I believe it
is then if I turn the page
um it's um again special a information
from the do25 and on the last page are
the ultimate steps in uh the calculation
and it shows you each one of those uh
for the uh uh Conway School District to
arrive at the perf Grant of
$487
um
so
a totally different program a student
cannot qualify for both
programs they either would take
advantage of the state based EFA program
that we have now in law or if this were
to pass they could um if the town so
voted and made the uh program available
in their District um the student could
uh opt for uh this program instead but
it cannot be in both
programs Celli for the committee would
you please explain how this works with a
Cooperative School
District um yes uh Cooperative school
district is a school district for the
purpose of this um legislation and
you'll see that it uh legislation uses
strictly the term District so it is U on
a districtwide basis if there is a
Cooper School District so the same
calculation would apply um and the same
EFA amount would apply to every uh child
taking EFA account uh from it didn't
matter from what town in that District
it would be the same across the board
within the Cooperative
District thank you representa
Porter thank you Mr chair I really have
to get this off my chest so I'm going to
make three points number one in the
we have a number of families who have
moved in recently that belong to a
fundamentalist Christian sect and their
um life God bless them they have as many
children as God sends them so the family
down the road just had
their if I'm looking at this they
homeschool all the children to they
don't send them to public schools and
they give them religious education in
the home school if I'm looking even if
conways is close to what Hills Bros are
and of those three humans that I know of
personally each ask for this for five of
their
children what does that do to the
district's bottom line we're talking
close to $5,000 a kid $25,000 a
family second the the New Hampshire
Constitution has two Clauses in it that
prevents anybody from forced to pay for
the religious education of any
child my property taxes which is what
this is based on not swep tax not
business taxes this is the money that I
send into the Town School District from
my pocket is going to
go to the religious education of these
children I being forced to
pay I just don't see that this legal
it's constitutional and I'll tell you if
it with a passing Hills bro three or
four of those families could wipe out a
couple of classroom teachers just like
that so I'm just concerned that at this
hour of night at 25 minutes by we are
dealing with a bill that could devastate
my community if it passes without giving
the wasn't even school not and I just
don't see how we can be doing that I'm
really upset as you can see because I
care deeply about my in my town and this
will devastate
them
cour so why do represent Ellison uh can
I just go back to page one on the on the
income income eligibility which
from two weeks ago a week ago correct
could I ask what the rale was for reming
that um yes in uh discussions um with
the uh Prime sponsor and others
um we had uh discussed the fact that
there had been many families um
complaining about the uh the current um
EFA program that has been put into law
that had the income cap um in a similar
fashion as does the tax credit
scholarship both have 300% of federal
poverty in uh family income caps um
it
is been made clear To Us by many people
that um the uh cap is unfair to many
middle class
families um and it is on that basis that
we decided to uh remove the cap from
this uh the cap remains in place in the
state EFA program um there's no change
to that and um uh I am not supporting
any change to that follow up yes uh then
then
hypothetically without the the
income requirement in there you could
have a
family a family income of $200,000 and
sending two children to Philip
sex the uh tuition is $58,000 a year
they would be eligible for Grants from
the local school
district if if um they were u in the
Hillsboro School District for instance
um and they wanted to send uh their
child to a private school they could
apply um if the town passed it and made
this program available in the community
um they could apply for an EFA and go to
a a private school Del
funds
represent yes thank you um when we
started talking about efas just in
general we talked about um taking the
amount of money that the state gives
gives per student to the to the local
school district 3,000 to 4,000 maybe
even $7,000 with special ed uh thrown in
there one of the things that we talked
about there was that you take two kids
out of first grade and three kids out of
sixth grade and then five kids out of
eighth grade in a school district you
lose that money but at the same time you
are still stuck with the building stuck
with the custodian stuck with the
library stuck with the ex uh
curricular and um all the other things
that go into creating a school system
for kids for the for the school year
this is uping that even further so as as
on this sheet the lowest you have is
like
$4,800 and it certainly could go a lot
more than that so now we're going to
have kids leave the school district or
maybe not even come into the school
district and um take away this this
higher level of money that and
yet that portion of that money goes to
support the building itself and and
everything around it I'm not sure I mean
I hope the rationale isn't to get rid of
lousy school systems as was quoted from
representative bone I hope that what
we're trying to do is support all our
Public School Systems but I'm not I'm
not sure that we're really going to do
that I'm also worried that there's no
fiscal note with this what is um or even
a recognition that this is going to cost
the local
um going to be a cost to the local uh uh
governmental agency whether it's the
school board or the town or whatever um
when we had the EFA come through same
thing happened we had an underestimate
how many people were going to actually
take it when we didn't have any fiscal
note at the beginning and then at the
end now we're up to8 million my last
point is we're turning this all over to
this scholarship organization which
never has had an RFP with the state is
taking 10% off the top so now not only
are we taking this money from the school
district um part of it that should go
towards not just students but towards
the building and towards the district
itself we're taking that money away and
at the same time we're going to give 10%
of that money that we take away to this
organization that just has in my
has little to no accountability for it
and the current Republican rep the
former Republican rep on their board and
so I just I think this is one of the
biggest scams uh that's happened to the
state of New Hampshire certainly since
I've lived here for 47 years and uh
people are are upset out in the
community in my communities I represent
eight communities they're
upset that something that was sold to
them as only costing the state
26,000 is now ballooned up to 8 million
and they're wondering where the money's
going to come from and how it's going to
be uh you know developed through theirs
and now I'm I'm missing a school budget
committee as a as a community member as
I sit here tonight I've got to go back
to them and tell them that the
possibility is that a group of people in
the community stir up enough
agitation um and enough
publicity comes out of the do or whoever
so that they get people at the school
district to possibly challenge the local
um School District to put this in and
and that it's going to cost them tons of
money uh tons of money that they don't
have that they're struggling a lot of
them are struggling with last Point um
and I should let Patty bring it up and
maybe even Barber you can speak to it is
things don't run like this in Manchester
you don't have warn articles you don't
have you know so and Manchester's a
fairly sizable public school system so
for us to deal with this tonight um and
and to even anticipate passing uh is I
mean I know marg's upset it just blows
my mind I mean it blows my mind that
we're doing this so um I've said thank
you uh representative Hill you have your
hand up I did don't
starta the
law talking about this
bill
money all the state money all the
federal
money
loc so to say
that money is being stripped
out it's not the case I mean the
IDE or two out
of going back that dist that's number
one number
two
prer gu was
aely done you have theill for Well I
this is a retain had for
months look that's that's you know
accus
bullsh come on folks let's let's let's
work through the chair work through the
chair represent
luno rewrote the whole
bill maybe but you're also accusing me
RSE in here you had for that week it's
the time I've seen it so I don't know
what what
the you know what it's a couple of
things it's it's the fact that
the da Dave Dave Dave just ju I I I'll
give you permission to speak but let's
just work work the way we should I know
that's the way you always way we should
like we've been doing all day represent
Luna would you like to re
rebut would you like to rebut what he's
saying then I'll okay go ahead so so
thank you very much Mr chair and
represent you
know
so I think it's important um thank you
Mr chair thank you representative I
think it's important to remember that as
house 67 started this journey in the in
the education committee that um uh that
it was nearly a year ago um and um and
then there was motion to retain
it
and then pretty much nothing actually
nothing until um minutes before we we
wrapped up our executive session last
Thursday when when the chair said hey
we've got a an amendment 607 haven't
even seen it yet uh copies were um were
were sent around I think all of our
members have certainly read and become
familiar with the amendment and theic
ches from the original bill um which now
have not any Public public hearing at
all let alone the um and I agree just
the minor change from last week's
amendment to to today's amendment that
um you know just makes a simple change
it only strips the U the income
eligibility requirement which of course
was a key key provision in uh in the EFA
Bill and in the original 607 and in the
amendment that was presented last week
so one of the justifications behind
education Freedom accounts uh right at
the GetGo was what is it going to do for
our students that come from lowi income
um low social economic um backs and I
think there was even a case made that oh
sure a lot of students in Manchester may
actually benefit from this because
Manchester on a per capita on a per
student basis has the low funded public
education uh in the um in the state of
New Hampshire so um so what we're
learning this evening from the current
amendment is that well first of all it's
no longer limited to to students with
low income second of all it no longer
applies to the city of Manchester the
Manchester school district and um and
thirdly that um that rather than rather
than providing some sort of Equitable
opportunity for public a you've got
students that that attend schools in
Newcastle and Waterville which I noticed
we didn't get any um any um um financial
analysis on but I know from having
served with representative lad on the
the school funding commission for for
nearly a year that those are some of on
a per student basis some of the most um
High budgeted um uh uh School amounts
that we've got in the state Waterville
Valley
uh just about $34,000 per student uh
Newcastle and right around $25,000 per
student um so so you compare that with
Conway of $4,000 per student or um or or
or Hillsboro uh maybe at that level wow
what are we doing for the students in
the city what are we doing for the
students in hillsbor andway um that
we're um that we're that we're actually
doing for through this this build for
the students in Newcastle wol m s and
Water Valley and um and you know we
haven't even you know pressed on on the
um what I would call a multi-year
projection going on to to page seven no
eligible student shall ever shall
receive a scholarship that is less than
the scholarship the student received in
his her first year so what if students
from Manchester say well screw this
screw Manchester doesn't apply
Manchester Manchester has given me the
the the the worst outcomes in the state
average student in Manchester performs
at the 5ifth per off 95 out of 100
students in New Hampshire do better than
the average kid in um Manchester so
screw it I'm going to to grab my family
we're going to move up to Waterville
Valley where they do $34,000 per student
I can get the uh local EFA for that and
um and U go to school wherever I want um
based done based on that type of what
does that do for the kids in Manchester
what does that do for the taxpayers in
Waterville Valley we haven't seen any
multi-year projectives on on that type
of I think there's a lot to study here
Mr chair and and you know you have been
uh above board um U certainly during my
time my my four years on the education
committee where where we take a little
slowly we look at things deeply we get
to understand things and this isn't
happening at at nearly 5 o'l at night um
under the under the gun to look at an
amendment that even even if yeah the the
income eligibility requirement is I I I
get that the change wasn't wasn't major
it's certainly a major policy change but
to be able to fully vet what we uh what
we all received a week ago sitting here
in a Cham that holds
450 uh people with virtually nobody um
uh from from any
um
constituency at all here and so I would
offer again that that we would support
an interim study U motion on this so
that we're not U proceeding to debate
and deliberate on a um on something that
is that is so impa
to our students across the
state further discussion yes repr
L
that's Mr chair yes um thank you Mr
chair I wanted to address representative
Porter's concerns um this is a far more
restrictive use of fund than the
Statewide EFA and any student who is
doing this would be a public school
student under compulsory attendance law
I would not I would bet good money that
a fundamental Christian family would not
choose to participate in this regardless
of the amount of money that would go to
their family so I I think that
those those religiously motivated
homeschoolers would never touch this
program never so that part is not a
concern a lot of them actually refuse to
for fundamental reasons as well uh but
that is a difference between those
programs so this one while it does allow
a homeschooler to enter into it it
allows they're allowed to become a
public school student as well so this
this this does not address that
population at all they would stay far
away um and I do think I'm also on the
the school fisical Advisory board for my
town um this is something that if it
makes sense for the town they would have
the chance to vote to bring this in if
it doesn't make sense it won't and and
you know that usually the budget people
support the local schools by far more
than a 60% margin so unless there was
something significant going on but there
are some towns that this could benefit
and I think giving the towns the choice
and the availability the towns and
cities is
important I would just reply since I was
mentioned indirectly in that last
comment that take that those figures
home to your town to your school
district
and ask them how that's going to affect
their
school how it's going to affect their
school and then and see what reaction
you get I bet you that you'll get quite
a reaction from from that
and this this is a bill which is an
enabling
Bill The Local District makes that
decision if they decide to go that way
then they are the ones that are going to
have to you know deal with the the
finances associated with this bill so it
it does not have on it a
uh well it does the old Bill had a
fiscal note on
it yeah that's what I'm
saying so we we've already known that
that that that's there so at this point
in time there no there's no further
discussion I think we ought to call this
motion art I have a number of questions
about details in the bill and I'm
wondering if this is the time to raise
them or we're just going to kind of run
right through this and past this
thing why don't you go and explain where
you have some questions I I well a very
specific one would be on page three well
this is the old the first amendment I
think it's still probably page three of
the new one about payment for tutors
uh it's line 16 on page
two of the First Amendment it may well
be it's still on page still on page
216 uh it says payment this would be
considered an allowable cost uh and I
guess
I'll you you I guess uh do you have to
be certified to be a
tutor or could a tutor
be a Clara who's going to teach my here
the VIS facts I what what how would that
be I I know
I I had been an uh EFA student way years
back I would have loved to have had my
aunt Milla um a high school math teacher
in New York City be my math
teer well assuming that that I have in
the same situation was not a tutor uh
but you know she needed some work but I
get her to tutor my my second grader and
pay her $15 an hour that would be an
allowable expense this I believe that
this is the um same language that's in
uh law now for the state EFA program it
is it is so okay so it is allowed we
have a clising at8 hour yes right uh I
one more question about tutoring which
is probably answer maybe the same you
can tell me uh would you have tutors
could be I
suppose uh officials in in churches
synagogues and so on could be religious
instruction you could be paying someone
to do a religious instruction as a tutor
I I I think this is academic instruction
that we're talking about um uh I think
that um if you wanted to have uh your
priest to give you a religious
instruction I don't think the priest
would charge you for
it okay so let's go ahead now I think
we're at the point where it's time to
act on this motion which we have Madam
chair would you please call the
role me in the bag in the bag huh it's
kind of early for being in the bag isn't
it
excuse me Barb yes point of personal
privilege uh I object to this piece of
legislation coming through this way with
this speed this does not give any credit
to this organization and to this
committee uh I think this is my third
year I have never seen anything quite
like this and that's
basically I'm very disappointed in the
way this is being handed thank you
Madam
clerk is to pass on Amendment 22
58 representative Celli
yes representa yes repres duf
yes Leon yes represent bobson yes
representative
Hill representative sod yes
representative Lang yes
representes
no
noes sh no representa Corell
representan Ellison
noan no wood
noter represent
yes
okay representative uh cordellia
recognize for a motion yes U yes I would
like to move uh ought to pass as amended
um on House Bill
607 with Amendment 2250 that we just
passed further discussion by the maker
of the motion representative cordelli
you made that motion second by
representative
bone further discussion on either of
anybody in the
committee Madam
clerk this
is pass as
amended uh representative Celli yes
representative
bent represent Leon yes represent yes
representative Hill yes representative s
yes representative Lang yes
Representative
lfi no
representes sh no representative Corell
no representative Tanner no representa
Ellison no representa
suanes
repres lad youen got there yet yes
yes
okay so that concludes uh our executive
session for today thank you we are
done